squishy human 76 was the only one left
every other squishy human had beautiful
shiny new skin all over their bodies
they were cuddling poking squeezing and
tickling each other in what used to be
the cafeteria all these humans piled on
top of each other no one feeling lonely
only squishy human 76 was left huddling
in the darkest corner of the facility
away from everyone else he sure was
feeling feeling lonely almost every inch
of his wet slippery skin was calling out
to join the others but there was one
tiny problem the pesky inch of human
skin left on the top of his head the
graphs had been a massive success with
97% body coverage with SCP 2790 skin to
replace his disgusting calloused human
skin with only a mild case of severe
necrosis eating away at him he sat in
the corner in the dark on his own
stroking the patch of rotten dying skin
on the top of his head soon it would be
all beautiful soft skin he just needed
the human part to finish dying then he
slithers into the cafeteria and hug and
cuddle and squeeze and poke and prod
with everyone else then he wouldn't be
so lonely puddling in this where was he
actually squishy human 76 looked around
through blurry eyes there was a name tag
on his chest head research Hopkins SCP
site 32 what did all those words mean
hey boss we've got the new SCP just
shipped in where should we put it
Melanie Sanders looked up from her desk
with a sigh she'd been picking at the
dry skin on the backs of her hands every
single person at site 54 was burnt out
but she was burnt out in Chief it had
been such a manic year that she hadn't
even realized they were due to be
receiving an SCP transfer she asked
which number it was and they informed
her it was one called 2790 didn't ring
any bells she asked what class it was
the junior researcher Millie Rogers
studied the shipping container
uncertainly it just says BFF there's a
note attached Melanie walked over
feeling the headache pound with each
step why did they have to have the
lights so bright in this facility she
snatched the note off the side and read
it it was signed by head researcher
Hopkins she recognized the name and the
signature he was from site 32 they
teamed up a handful of times in the past
dear Melanie a gift from us to you SCP
2790 moral was at an alltime low at
sight 32 before the arrival of this
wonderful little SCP we hope you welcome
him warmly just like we did you'll all
have the best time together we promise
just give him plenty of cuddles only one
rule with this one don't touch him
Popkins she realized immediately that it
was obviously a trap Melanie scrunched
up the letter and threw it on the floor
she jabbed a finger at her Junior and
instructed her to get on the phone
straight away to senior command and tell
them that something weird must have
happened at site 32 under no
circumstances was anyone to touch that
shipping container did this SCP really
think she was born yesterday boss I'm
actually going on annual leave for a
couple weeks I don't really have time to
Melanie didn't have time to deal with
this today she'd leave it to her team to
sort it out but that evening as Melanie
was working late she found her Mouse
drifting over to the SCP main List and
her fingers absent mind L typing in
2790 an adorable picture of a little
squid came up right away even in the
midst of her stress she couldn't help
but crack a smile it was very cute
whatever it was she would just check its
containment measures that was all she
needed to make sure that it was safely
stored while it was here raising
everyone's morale it would obviously
need to go back because there was a
major Containment Breach but while it
was here Personnel are freely invited to
Splash around and play with him SCP 2790
should not be touched and must always be
hand-fed all forms of physical contact
with 2790 are allowed and encouraged
except touching that seems
straightforward enough no issues there
rub his belly while feeding him
especially while feeding him treats he
loves treats hug him before and after
playtime maybe it was worth going and
checking on SCP 2790 she wouldn't want
him getting lonely as soon as Melanie
Saunders turned the corner into the
delivery Depot her worst fears were
confirmed he must have been very lonely
the shipping container hadn't been
opened he must have been left in there
all on his own all day that simply
wouldn't do she opened the container up
right away and saw in the shadows inside
a large aquarium hello little fellow are
you all on your own did all those mean
people not give you a cuddle she walked
closer and closer to the tank the
darkness enveloping her she couldn't see
anything inside the tank maybe it was
hiding she pressed her her face right up
against the glass trying her best to get
a look inside he wasn't there a scream
filled the room Melanie turned in a
Flash and ran out of the container more
screams she sprinted through the
corridors following the sound and
rounded a corner to see happy faces
laughing cuddling and playing it was SCP
2790 surrounded by all of her best
researchers they had set up one of the
Class 2 deep water aquatic containment
tanks especially for their new guest
everyone had gotten into the tank some
of them still fully dressed others
rolling up sleeves and taking off shirts
to get more skin- to- skin contact could
she blame them really Melanie Saunders
laughed along with them flooded with
relief that their new BFF wasn't lonely
in there okay guys I'm glad to see we're
all welcoming our new special little
friend just remember the rules we can
cuddle him squeeze him stroke him give
him tummy Rubes to our hearts content
but no touching got it they all nodded
in agreement absolutely no touching ing
then went back to patting 2790 on the
head beaming and why wouldn't they be
happy SCP 2790 is a male Atlantic Cranch
squid Teena megalops who is just the
cutest little guy you've ever laid eyes
or hands on the foundation first
recovered him from the curio shop curios
of the world and it is a good thing they
did someone mean had put him in a tinted
glass tank with the word ignore printed
on the front despite the foundation's
best effort s it had been unable to
ascertain as to why anyone would want to
separate SCP 2790 from everybody like
that and make him feel sad he's just the
best SCP out there perfect for petting
and caressing with your skin on his skin
so that your skin and his skin are
making contact skin to skin just don't
touch him in fact he's so perfect in
every single way that all Personnel are
actively encouraged to engage in as much
physical contact with him as possible
except for touch ing anybody on their
lunch break after work before work or
while doing work is encouraged to spend
as much time as they can give as CP 2790
tummy rubs and back scratches and
Squishy cuddles Foundation Personnel who
object to playing with SCP 2790 are to
be coerced in the strictest way possible
in the interest of everyone's safety
this is because SCP 2790 can get lonely
if he gets lonely then he escapes
containment for Melanie Saunders team
the of containment breaches was far too
high 2790 was escaping at a staggering
zero times per week they needed to do
something about it Melanie Gathering the
best mindes in site 54 as well as all
the others in the class 2 deep water
aquatic containment tank where they
stood around stroking 2790 for a very
serious important meeting as I'm sure
you all are no doubt aware 2790 is
feeling too lonely at the moment he has
breached containment zero times already
this week which is an increase from zero
times a month yesterday this just isn't
acceptable we need to come up with
creative innovative solutions to make
sure that without touching him we are
maintaining as much physical contact
with him as possible any suggestions she
gave 2790 a good belly rub for being
such a good boy as she spoke Dr Romero
piped up almost immediately fingers
intertwined with 279s little tentacles
in a cute little game he'd been thinking
about this Non-Stop and he'd come to the
conclusion that the correct answer here
was skin Dr sasan agreed
enthusiastically right away Dr Romero
continued feverishly explaining skin to
skin that's what they needed they needed
to maximize physical contact whilst
avoiding any touching so it made sense
that they put their skin against 2790
skin as much as possible he proposed
skin grafts taking skin from 2790 and
grafting it onto their own bodies so
that their skin is always against his
skin forever the more skin the better
skin skin to skin skin on skin skin over
skin skin under skin skin interwoven
with more skin Melanie weighed that as
an option and you can do that without
touching the doctor nodded so the skin
grafting procedures began at first
doctors Romero and S Vasan were worried
about hurting 2790 in the operation so
they made sure to give it constant
tickles and Pats as they worked it was
all worth it to help them attain the
smoothness and loveliness of his skin
they worked swiftly never watching him
but constantly stroking him to make sure
he knew everything was okay there was a
line of Staff members waiting at the
door to the operating theater each one
of them offering up their arms for the
sake of making sure this adorable little
guy wasn't lonely ever again all
resources and machines in the facility
were immediately switched to aiding in
the cloning of the skin sample taken
from 2790 before too long they had a
whole production line of beautiful soft
skin for them all to not touch 189
personnel volunteered to take part in
the trial out of a possible 189
Personnel at the facility so it aligned
with the average turnout for Fringe
experimental surgical procedures in the
United States every single one of the
volunteers had disgusting dry calloused
gross disgusting skin that desperately
needed to be replaced one by one they
would enter the operating theater scream
in pain from the lack of anesthetic
which is now common practice in medicine
before striding out proudly with lovely
new pink wet skin on their hands feet
forearms chests or faces many of the
patients were so pleased with the
results that they immediately took their
place at the back of the queue all over
again to go back for more naturally
antibiotics and immunosuppressants were
handed out to everybody who took part in
the surgery with the goal of preventing
any kind of serious infection or skin
rejection issues not that anybody could
ever reject 2790 just look at him again
this was a roaring success only 87% of
patients reported suffering from
complications from the grafting
procedure for some unknown reason many
of their bodies were rejecting the
perfect smooth new skin that was so much
better than their horrible old skin and
only 70% of the patients suffered severe
necrosis in their bodies as the inferior
human skin around the grafting site died
and began to rot away how's that for
Cutting Edge Foundation science most
importantly of all there was a dramatic
increase in SCP 279s morale and indeed
the morale of the whole sight
containment breaches once rampant had
gone down from zero times per day to
zero given the unprecedented success of
the operation Melanie Sanders herself
the proud new owner of a facial skin
graft with necrosis eating away at her
neck greenlit and even greater rate of
production they were rapidly hurdling
towards continuing site 32s pilot
program of sending 2790 to other sites
to boost morale but there was more work
to do first the operating theater was
opened 24/7 with the scalpel passed on
to anybody who was around at the time
regardless of qualifications anybody not
in the operating theater was to be in
the water tank with 2790 it was
Paramount that this level of positive
morale was maintained the best part was
now everybody had a little bit of 2790
skin they could always be horsing around
together researchers agents security
Juniors everybody piled into the tank
together cuddling poking squeezing and
patting one another just to make sure
everyone was on the same page someone
had painted the words no touching in
what looked like red paint over the tank
morale sword and everybody was happy
until that Junior researcher Millie
Rogers came back from her vacation for
the first time in 2 weeks somebody
didn't want to be cuddled she seemed to
have developed some strange kind of
phobia while she was away quite
irrational anytime any of the staff
members would approach her she would run
away screaming and brandished improvised
weapons at them for the most part the
staff of sight 54 paid her no mind she
would occasionally bludgeon one of them
to death when all they wanted was a
peaceful squeeze to saave off the
loneliness but aside from that it wasn't
a big deal they'd cut off all the phone
lines computer systems alarms SOS
beacons and defense systems a long time
ago none of those things related to skin
or cuddles or not touching so they had
to be removed Millie Rogers was locked
in there and would eventually see how
high the morale was and decided to join
in it wouldn't take too long but Millie
had a plan somehow resisting the
harmless urge for constant physical
contact with all of her co-workers she
decided that the best course of action
was to terminate SCP 2790 once and for
all maybe its adorable charm and lack of
any Sinister subtext would dissipate
after it died to do that she had to be
like one of them there was only one
place where SCP 2790 could be it had
breached containment zero times so it
could only be in one place the center of
the Rising cuddling bodies in the water
tank queuing up for the operating
theater Millie volunteered to do a graft
on one of the patients in line she
couldn't recognized their face at all
all of its skin had been replaced and it
smelled like death but the name badge
told her it was Dr Romero Millie picked
up the scalpel and stood over him hand
shaking actually she rehearsed a
thousand times but still felt nervous
I'm going to go and have one more Frolic
in the tank if that's okay okay that's
the best thing I've ever heard I'll join
you Millie marched through the Cor do
escorted by a bizarre skin job of a man
who stroked every coworker he walked
past with a sense of constant euphoric
Wonder Millie stood at the edge of the
tank clutching the scalpel she'd jump in
and kill it the others might suddenly
turn on her or the spell might break or
they could die who knew the water was
ACD and full of floating chunks nearly
200 people were living day and night in
the tank as their bodies rotted the
smell was unbelievable Millie took one
more breath and dove in she kicked and
punched her way through the Tangled
throng of Limbs come to think of it
their skin was remarkably soft she
wouldn't mind it so much if her hands
felt like that Focus she kicked deeper
and deeper wrestling people out of the
way in her race to get to the center of
the human cocoon just a bit further and
sheid it was quite nice to have so much
physical contact with her colleagues
come to think of it when would they have
gotten to cuddle like this before
without so much as the dull thought
Millie's hand loosened and the scalpel
sank to the floor the arms of Melanie
Sanders wed around her and stroked the
horribly coarse skin on her face she'd
have to get that scen to for the sake of
everybody's morale little did she know
that it would have been hopeless anyway
the SCP 2790 good morale pilot program
had been extended earlier that day SCP
2790 had been shipped out to another
undisclosed site that was having morale
issues you see not all SCP stories end
up being horrific some of them are just
good heartwarming Tales of caressing and
skin grafting with your new BFF
Maria Delgado tumbled through the air
the Furious sea wind whipped all around
her her hair blew in her eyes trying to
Shield them from the view of what was
rapidly coming to hit her Square in the
face an ocean as black as the night sky
she barely had a second to brace herself
before splash the impact in the cold
knocked all the air out of her a flurry
of bubbles disappeared into the darkness
as she sank further and further down not
knowing which way was up Maria kicked
frantically as her water logged clothes
dragged her back her head found the
surface and she barely had a moment to
gasp in half a lung full of air before a
wave hit her in the side of the head
knocking her back under kicking and
spluttering she managed to poke her head
up again and tried to wave desperately
at the metal Behemoth looming over her
the cruise ship that had felt so safe
and warm now looked like a cliff face
the lowest window that that she could
see was more than 100 ft above her head
there had been music playing on the deck
but she was so far below now that she
couldn't even hear it anymore all she
could hear was the rumbling of the
engines and an ominous swishing chopping
sound behind her Maria's stomach dropped
she felt the ocean pulling at her a
current forcing her beneath the waves
she had fallen off the back of the
cruise ship and that meant the current
gripping her and turning her beneath the
water she tumbled and twist Ed in the
darkness feeling all of the air rushing
out of her lungs again squinting as best
as she could through the stinging
saltwater she saw the thing that she'd
been dreading an enormous propeller each
Blade the size of her house spinning and
spinning just on the edge of her vision
and gliding steadily towards her the
water was sucking her towards it pulling
her faster and faster she'd never been a
very strong swimmer but there wasn't
time to feel bad about that now she
needed to escape any way she could
desperately lashing at the water Maria
kicked and clawed herself out of the
current she had to swim sideways as fast
as she could otherwise she didn't want
to think about it the propellers were
getting closer getting larger in the
water the awful sound of their approach
didn't just shake the water around her
it shook all of the water inside of her
making her stomach turn in fear she
hadn't breathed in in a long time her
body was going into shock from the cold
everything around her was doing its best
to drag her down to a slow icy death or
maybe a fast painful death from the
impact of several tons of spinning steel
something hard and fast crunched into
Maria's heel moving so quickly that it
sent her spinning through the water the
propeller had hit her its next
Revolution passed about a foot in front
of her face before the turbulence of the
cruise ship's wake took hold of her and
threw her away then all of a sudden
fresh air was hitting her face the water
had lifted her up to the surface and
carried her in the foamy wake that
stretched away from the cruise ship
already the metal Juggernaut was a
couple of hundred feet away from her but
she tried to swim after it the currents
in the water would only carry her
further backward Maria had no choice but
to tread water and stare as the cruise
ship that had once been so large and
imposing above her steadily became a DOT
on the horizon and then disappeared
entirely her husband had been in bed she
had just stepped out onto the deck to
have some fresh air he could sleep
through anything chances are he wouldn't
notice she was missing until he woke up
in the morning and who knew what time
that would be they were on vacation and
he hadn't set an alarm he would probably
assume that she'd gone for an early
breakfast without him only once he'd sat
down and finished his breakfast and gone
back to the room to find she was still
missing would he start to worry by that
point she would have stopped kicking
hours ago she wasn't sure how deep the
ocean was out here how many minutes
would it take for her body to sink to
the bottom or would it take hours
perhaps her corpse wouldn't even be
halfway down to the seabed by that point
she was shivering so violently that she
was struggling to keep herself above the
surface her legs weren't kicking like
they would in a pool they were spasming
and tensing up her clothes ballooned all
around her doing nothing but get in the
way as she tried desperately to stay
alive she had no phone it had fallen off
the deck with her now likely on its own
way down to the seafloor she had no
light not enough air in her lungs to cry
for help and no one between herself and
the Horizon to hear this was it this was
how she would die a sense of morbid
curiosity filled her what exactly was
below her maybe there was a reef
somewhere down where her corpse could
lie peacefully what she saw when she
stuck her head beneath the surface was
Darkness swirling and empty and
painfully cold except there was
something else moving down there the
book small smaller than she was some
kind of sea creature swimming up to meet
her Maria lifted her head took a deep
breath and swam down towards it it
wasn't swimming like a usual fish its
shadowy silhouette seemed to Ripple and
twist as her eyes slowly adjusted to the
darkness she saw what it was a squid
maybe a meter in length at least she
wouldn't be dying alone out here the
squid started to swim faster approaching
her quickly at that moment she suddenly
remembered some of the thing she'd heard
about squids weren't they Hunters she
had seen a nature documentary once where
sperm whales had come up from the seabed
with enormous gouges around their eyes
from where they'd been attacked by a
school of squids suddenly Maria didn't
want her companion anymore but it was
too late the squid had almost reached
her end she felt her mind starting to
float out of itself her eyes weren't
focusing properly the squid wasn't just
swimming towards her it was flashing
almost like a strobe light different
lurd colors filled the ocean around her
and it convulsed in different colors
until all of a sudden it wasn't a small
squid at all anymore it ballooned in
size swelling and bulging all around her
enormous tentacles unfurled themselves
and whipped at the water all around her
it was 10 m tall now 20 40 70 the squid
seemed to fill the whole ocean
swallowing up all of the available water
and leaving her in a tiny puddle
floating just a few feet away from its
gashing bead
some of the tentacles didn't even look
like tentacles anymore they had turned
into Pinchers or even human looking arms
and legs except the fingers were tipped
with grotesque Talons she had to escape
had to get away if Maria had thought
she'd swam fast to get away from the
cruise ship's propellers it was nothing
compared to how fast she swam now
without care for her trembling limbs
struggling lungs or rapidly fading
Consciousness Maria knew she had to get
away from this monstrosity there was no
hope for her without escape the flashing
lights felt like they were all around
her no matter which way she swam it just
felt like they were getting brighter and
brighter until a pair of hands grabbed
her and lifted her out of the water
Maria kicked and screamed trying to
fight the tentacles off but they pinned
her down to the deck and held her there
voices surrounded her bright lights
shining in her face this was how she
would die until a shadow blocked out one
of the lights and her eyes managed to
focus on something
it was a man he was talking to her in
another language desperately trying to
calm her down where was the squid what
had happened to it Maria lashed out with
her limbs trying to shake herself free
from the fishermen who were holding her
down on the deck she threw her gaze
sideways and saw an enormous net lifting
a school of fish out of the water there
were hundreds of them all thrashing and
slapping against one another and there
poking out of the bottom of the net was
a single tentacle dread filled her
stomach but but her body gave out on her
and she fell unconscious all right we
run it one more time Dr Matthews sat at
the laptop and watched the grainy CCTV
footage for what felt like the H 100th
time it was footage from a fishing
vessel captured off the coast of Sagal
the first 30 seconds of the clip just
showed the view from the front of the
boat waves splashing here and there but
mostly Darkness then all of a sudden
there were two shapes moving through the
water one was a terrified woman
desperately swimming towards the surface
the other shape was harder to pin down
when Matthews had first watched the
video she'd seen a colossal sea creature
riding beneath the surface but each time
that she'd watched it since the creature
seemed to get a bit smaller and lose
some of its sting perhaps the shock of
what she was seeing had just been
wearing off regardless it was time to do
the mandatory checks before the latest
SCP was brought into the facility Dr
Matthews walked through the corridors of
the containment facility and came to the
large double door that led into the main
hanger it had been hard to find a
facility large enough to contain this
SCP they knew it was capable of reaching
enormous sizes so they had to construct
an aquarium big enough to house it at
its maximum size Dr Matthews started
walking across the walkway it hung
suspended over the reinforced aquarium
and would be strictly off limits once
the SCP had been moved into the facility
it was far too easy for the squid to
Simply grab a member of staff and pull
them beneath the water she was heading
towards the control panel at the other
side the tank was 150 M cubed and so
walking the length of it took her well
over a minute this was by far the
biggest containment she'd ever been
involved with in terms of scale as well
as severity the logistics in trying to
organize the containment of this squid
had run into the millions of dollars and
were still going up every day it had
taken her and her research team a while
to convince the board that this SCP
posed a significant enough threat to
warrant the investment she needed to
make sure not to screw it up guard stood
all around the perimeter of the tank
holding b74 Harpoon guns with
electrified discharge shafts looking
down into the water Dr Matthews could
see the 15 depth charges all hanging at
various Heights throughout the tank each
of these depth charges were wirelessly
connected to a computer that monitored
the Integrity of the glass all around
the tank if the SCP were to make even
the slightest crack in the glass all 15
depth charges were to be set off
simultaneously she hoped that was enough
to kill it God help her if it wasn't it
would keep one entity here for study but
she had reason to believe that there
were more of them all over the world and
so preparations were in place to arm a
team that could scour the oceans and
eliminate any others that were found
today was the day SCP 252 the humbled
squid was about to arrive the shipping
container was lifted by a crane and
carried to the right spot Spot somewhere
inside it was a large sealed tank of
water holding an instance of SCP 252
that would drop the shipping container
into the reinforced aquarium and let it
sink all the way to the bottom before
detonating remote charges on its doors
and on the sealed tank inside allowing
SCP 252 to escape and fill its new
enclosure Dr Matthews stood with her
hand shaking over the button it was now
or never taking a deep breath she
pressed it down firmly and watched on
the security camera monitor as several
puffs of bubbles Rose from the container
and the doors swung open none of them
could see inside the container they just
had to wait then all of a sudden a small
shape darted out it was Tiny no more
than a meter in length what had happened
to the reports that this thing was 75 M
across Dr Matthews looked around at her
co-workers in shock she didn't expect to
see a monster to unfr itself out of the
container and grow larger and larger but
all that had emerged was a tiny Li
little black squid but none of her
colleagues looked back at her all of
them were staring wide-eyed at the
security feed Matthews glanced back and
saw that the little squid was flashing
various colors as it swam around just
like the CCTV footage that she had been
studying for the prior few weeks a
scream filled the room and was quickly
answered with another as her fellow
researchers ran away from what they were
seeing terrified by the shapes on the
screen Matthews just looked back and
forth in confusion the Colossal sea
monster that had had been reported to
her wasn't there there was just a tiny
squid flashing various colors what were
all of them so afraid of and now would
she break it to her boss that she'd
spent millions of dollars on a giant
aquarium loaded with depth charges for a
squid the size of a large dog 2 weeks
later she found herself attempting to do
just that standing in front of the
disciplinary panel Dr Matthews tried to
explain what it happened SCP 252 the
humbled squid is suspected to be the
origin of a lot of men myths surrounding
giant squids and perhaps even the Kraken
itself when hunting all the squid's pre
attempts to flee by the most direct path
possible overcome with Terror at what
they are seeing the squid can appear to
be anywhere between 50 and 75 m in size
with up to 200 appendages growing from
its mantle these appendages can all take
various forms often depending on what
the prey is most afraid of for example a
test subject who is terrified of spiders
will see the hairy legs of a tarantula
amongst the tentacles but C is the
important word here because while SCP
252 appears to take on its form the
reality is that these are all
hallucinations brought on by viewing the
Squid's rapidly flashing colors while
hunting SCP 252 rapidly Cycles its
chromatophores which results in powerful
hallucinations all prey will then
immediately lay down their defenses and
try to flee as quickly as possible
leaving them open to being eaten by the
relatively small and weak real squid
however as Dr Matthews had discovered it
was possible to inoculate yourself
against these Effects by viewing the
grainy CCTV footage from the fishing
boat on repeat so many times in the
runup to SCP 22's arrival Dr Matthews
had built up a kind of immunity allowing
her to see the SCP as it actually was
even though her colleagues ran away in
Terror one fun fact Dr Matthews said is
that the prey will attempt to
rationalize the scp's size even when it
is is in a confined space that's
impossibly small so if you were taking a
bath with the squid you would somehow
believe that the squid was both 75 M
large and fully submerged in the tub in
your guest bathroom funny isn't it none
of the disciplinary board members had a
word they all stared at her in beused
silence please don't fire me the ships
crash and Splinter against The Rock men
scream as they're tossed Into the Water
by the force of it but they don't fear
drowning they fear something far more
powerful and terrifying as they land in
the water huge pitch black hands reach
up to receive them in a place beyond
darkness and impurity all things will be
revealed those in pursuit of spiritual
enlightenment are sure to find it on the
high seas of life so long as they map
out their course with precision and sail
dauntlessly towards it but their souls
must also be Waring for wherever there
are oceans to explore there be monsters
it is a raining morning on the coast of
the island of kushu a modest fishing
vessel gently crests over the waves of
the Sea of Japan carrying with it a
successful Hall back to the port of the
rural settlement it departed from a
couple of hours prior the crew are all
trades people local to the area and many
are parents and grandparents whose
children have long since grown up and
left their home Village for the
opportunities of city life for the older
generation that was left behind behind
the Bounty of the sea is all they know
the marine life that the Aging Fisher
folk bring in is the lifeblood of the
village economy the population depends
on the kindness of nature to avoid
falling into poverty and is accustomed
to working against the elements when it
becomes necessary tsunamis and typhoons
have threatened the balance of this way
of life before but over several decades
the villagers have proven themselves
resilient to the most extreme
fluctuations of natural forces but even
a firm backbone beaten into shape by
hard work and suffering will buckle and
bend in the churning melstrom of alien
Tides a black do shape in the valley
between passing wakes Heralds the
arrival of a fearsome giant with no
further indication of its intentions the
Great Dark thing emerges from the depths
the Fisher folk steady their vessel as a
gargantuan Ripple disrupts the surface
of the water giving way to a humanoid
figure that that was a full 5 m in
length when the fishing boat had left
the harbor the weather posed no obstacle
save for a veil of fog but now in the
face of this unfathomable being the
pelting rainwater swirled around the
sturdy rubber boots of the crew as if
the ocean below was beckoning them to
surrender to the darkness an icy blade
of fear pierced the heart of Mr Nakamura
the man who now commanded the wheel of
the ship his efforts to make sense of
the horrible sight in front of him
brought him back to a moment from his
distant childhood his parents had taken
him to visit a Buddhist temple in the
countryside and when he recklessly
wandered off young Nakamura wound up
lost in the dark corridors beneath the
grounds to a child his age it seemed as
though he was trapped in an inescapable
Labyrinth the only thing the boy could
muster the strength to do was head
towards the faint glow of torch light he
soon Came Upon a statue of the amitaba
Buddha sitting peacefully between the
contained flames of the Torches Nakamura
relished the temporary peace of the
moment but his composure did not remain
intact for long a hand from the dark
grabbed his wrist and at that moment he
looked up to see the bald head of one of
the temple monks the orange robed Man's
eyes were fixed downward at the boy and
contained a mixture of contempt and
relief that Nakamura had never seen
before am you are found over 70 years
later Mr Nakamura could see nothing in
the terrible giant that had besieged his
boat so clearly as he saw the silhouette
of a Buddhist monk but even with the
ominous recollection of that formative
memory coursing through the Old
Fisherman's body like an electrical
current it was obvious that the monster
was human only in shape the Flesh of the
thing was the color of octopus ink and
its eyes its bulous and disquieting eyes
were big even in in proportion to the
Giant's colossal head worse despite
their almost cartoonish absurdity the
eyes of the thing seemed to hold within
them that same barely defined look of
bewildered judgment it was too much for
Mr Nakamura to take and when his heart
gave out his hands threw the ship wheel
in a jerking Arc that brushed it
straight against the waves most of the
other Fisher folk were too stunned by
the giant to properly get their bearings
and multiple members of the crew nakam
included tumbled overboard into the
waves those who remained on Deck could
see that the wheel was drifting
aimlessly or rather would have if their
focus was not still drawn to the black
monk that had Arisen just moments ago
the giant raised a massive dark hand
above the waters and arranged its
fingers in such a way as to mimic the
Vitara hand gesture seen in many
Buddhist statues as if on Q a Consortium
of black rubbery tentacles broke the
surface of the ocean o and baned out
towards the boat like so many grasping
hands one of these pseudopods wrapped
itself around the barely conscious body
of Mr Nakamura plucking him from under
the water and raising him into the Misty
Sea Air in response to the tentacles the
other Fisher folk panicked and scrambled
back onto the boat with those aboard
extending Nets and ores to assist their
fellow crew two terrifying minutes
passed before the adherent black thing
vanished into the Mist along with Mr
nakam
his longtime peers and co-workers panted
and sputtered trying to make any kind of
sense of what just happened when they
made their way home to the Village Port
the only question that seemed to matter
was which of them would have to place
the upsetting call to nakamura's
daughters in Tokyo who could bear to
deliver the news to her that her
steadfast father had been taken by a
giant of the sea while thankfully rare
incidents such as the sudden nautical
Abduction of Mr Nakamura are not
unexplained or even I ated to cases in
the Sea of Japan since as early as the
12th century sightings of aquatic Titans
resembling night black monks have been
recorded by a precursor to the SCP
Foundation known as the Bureau of Ono
back then these creatures were referred
to as umib Boo or sea bonds bonds being
a Chinese and Japanese term for Buddhist
monk in the current day the Umi bosu had
been reclassified as SCP
2781 and because of the predatory way
that the Giants hunt their targets and
their extreme resistance to containment
they have been designated ker class as
of right now there are thought to be
upwards of 900 instances of SCP 2781 in
existence while SCP 2781 entities could
potentially appear anywhere in the Epic
lay of the planet's oceans they have
historically tended towards inhabiting
the waters around countries where there
have been a pervasive and widespread
practice of the Buddhist Faith an
archived file recovered from the Bureau
of Ono reveals that a group of East
Asian Pirates or Wako ran a foul of one
of the creatures while searching for
treasure in a Seaside Cave the seafaring
Cutthroats had previously fired on a
trading ship from Korea and driven it
against the rocks of a remote Japanese
island many of the goods on board had
been carried in by the tides and
required strong swimmers to access but
during the hunt for spoils the Wako were
interrupted by the malevolent presence
of an entity that manifested itself self
within the coastal crass the yiu or SCP
2781 could not stretch to its full
height within the cavern and thus glared
down at the pirates with an acute angle
to its posture the Pirates were
completely defenseless having left
behind their metal weapons and guns on
the ship out of concern for rust and
ruined powder while none of these
criminal Sea Dogs were religious their
plunder had brought enough gold Buddha
statues to recognize the familiar
gestures of SCP 2781 then according to
the report a strange phenomenon occurred
within the cavern the Pirates gasped in
sheer disbelief as the stone walls were
bathed in light and the creature began
to raise its head the ceiling was
suddenly more pliable as if it had
changed into a softer material before
they knew it the Wako found themselves
in a wondrous Cave of pure gold The
Entity then tore chunks of the gold away
from the wall crushing the metal with
its bare hands like a chef might Crush
spice a small fortune of coins dropped
from between the umumi bosu's fingers
though the tempting promise of wealth
called to the men not one of them could
find the courage to attempt to seize it
this was because of the entity's
unblinking Gaze which felt so profoundly
wrong that even being within sight of it
felt like drowning the Wako were already
swimming away as fast as they could when
the giant Unleashed its tentacles to
swallow its chosen Target and disappear
into the ether later in the tavern of a
nearby port a researcher for the Bureau
of Ono obtained a detailed version of
the encounter before administering
rudimentary herbal amnestics to the
Pirates through their pitcher of sake
which all of them were partaking in to
dull the insanity of what the more
superstitious among them were calling
Divine punishment while the full scope
of SCP 2781 reality warping abilities is
still being studied displays such as the
transmutation of the cavern into gold in
the case of the Waco have been noted in
sever veral other sightings it seems as
though the entities are able to perform
religious miracles in other words exert
Godlike authority over all forces
mineral and Elemental the use of this
ability seems to be an uncommon
occurrence even within targeted attacks
seeming to reflect an understanding on
the Yumi Bozo's part not to want to
abuse its miraculous power of all the
sightings ever documented no entity that
is part of SCP 2781 has ever attempted
to transmute a living human or animal
the Bureau of Ono also suggests that the
overall number of Umi Bozo in the sea
experienced a mysterious increase during
the reign of toyotomi hidoshi and that
the startling frequency of their
appearance may have influenced Japan's
inability to claim victory in the
imagion war there were so many disperate
reports of the entities that a few even
reached the great unifier ear since even
the bureau didn't have the authority to
give amnestics to the chancellor of the
realm the knowledge of SCP 2781 lur in
the ocean was likely an additional
factor in hideyoshi's well-documented
mental decline the SCP Foundation data
has picked up where the Bureau of Ono
left off centuries ago and had begun to
chart the alarming number of targeted
hunts that instances of SCP 2781 have
committed over the years sometimes the
culprit is not immediately provable as
an instance but a closer look at the
circumstances reveals its presence for
example there was the case of Max Powell
a 15-year-old American Teenager who was
thought to have been kidnapped while his
family was aboard a commercial sea liner
traveling to Hong Kong on the day of his
disappearance Max was enjoying a swim in
one of the cruise ships on Deck pools
witness testimony says he was just
present one moment and simply gone the
next Max's parents and the Lifeguard on
duty had no idea how to process the
situation and though both parties were
sure that Max had never left their sight
the grief of it all got the better of
them and a heated argument began
security footage from one of the ship's
cameras reveals a portion of the truth
and thus the foundation seized it and
used amnestics to make sure the events
were not public knowledge there is a
brief moment right before Max Powell
disappears from view where a thin
wirelike strand of black seemed to snake
across the deck and into the swimming
pool another camera feed from the same
day reveals The Telltale outline of an
SCP 2781 entity was visible keeping Pace
with the ship along its Hall it seems as
though the entity had manifested in an
attempt to seize a new human being as a
Target but found none submerged in the
ocean and therefore had to shift its
focus to one of the passengers in the
swimming pool which sadly appeared to be
Max Powell this incident confirmed a
widely theorized belief about SCP 2781
the fact that it is only able or at
least willing to abduct targets who are
partially submerged in water while boats
are often involved in most of SCP 2781
manifestations on record this is likely
a side effect of the fact that such
vessels tend to carry many humans at
once and thus increase the chances that
one of them will wind up being a Target
in other words there is nothing stopping
a SCP 2781 entity from choosing someone
who is simply in the vicinity as a
Target provided they meet the
requirement of being submerged following
the 2020 Olympic Games in Tokyo an
Simone Bergman a member of the German
swim team de decided to stain the
country for a bit of additional training
she was fresh off of winning a gold
medal in the 100 meter backstroke the
first in her career and according to her
own statements wanted to make as many
memories as she could before she
returned to Germany but she never would
actually be able to return and Simone
Bergman went missing in The canman
Straits and her body was never recovered
the cause of her disappearance was
uncertain until recently but in light of
new evidence It is believed that her
fate was at the hands of an SC P 2781
entity further data suggests that The
Uncanny resemblance between SCP 2781
entities and gigantic human monks goes
deeper than a mere aesthetic coincidence
this is corroborated by the existence of
SCP
2781 a pure land that exists beyond the
known boundaries of space and time it is
theorized that this remote Dimension is
where the entities of SCP 2781 dispense
the targets of their attacks following
the moment when they vanish from
existence there are no other known ways
to enter SCP
2781 other than being ushered in by an
instance of SCP 2781 but it has been
discovered that there are two ways to
leave the pure land the first is to
transcend mortal existence in order to
become a Buddha and the second is to
return to the physical world as a bista
understood in this context to be a
manifested instance of SCP 2781 in
Buddhism the purpose of the bista is to
SP self the completion of its own
spiritual journey in order to guide the
rest of humanity toward Enlightenment
thus SCP 2781 D is an extension of that
purpose and confers the benefits of the
claro cognizant awareness upon its
occupants while it is impossible to know
the ultimate truth of what befalls the
targets who chose to reach nirvana we
learn much of what we know now through
engaging in Sign Language communication
with a voluntarily albeit temporarily
contained instance of SCP 2781 that has
self-identified itself as Nakamura this
unusually docile instance of an SCP 2781
bov Vista described the pure land as a
contemplative place and alleged that it
even had a chance meeting with Olympic
gold medalist and Simone Bergman during
its time in that world Nakamura
indicated to the foundation members that
it wished to return to its Village and
release others from their own
attachments and labors but at the same
time requested that the foundation
contact a woman it identified as its
daughter this the SCP 2781 instance
indicated was its own attachment that
needed to be shed in order for it to let
go of its Earthly obligations we
informed the instance that amnestics had
already been administered to both Mr
nakamura's daughter as well as all the
Fisher folk that had been on board the
vessel the day that Nakamura was
targeted as a response to this
information The Entity demonstrated that
it was no longer willing to cooperate
with Foundation staff it brandished its
tentacle and was able to insens snare a
member of mobile task force Zeta 66
before Vanishing in the expected manner
further observation will need to be
conducted to determine how much of a
target's former identity factors into
how it is changed as a result of
entering SCP 2781 daa but we will be
closely monitoring 34-year-old minako
Nakamura as well as other known members
of the Nakamura family in the meantime
just in case they end up following in
the footsteps of dear old dad Diego had
only just found his footing when it gave
out underneath him again crashing to the
ground he threw both arms over his head
just in time to protect his skull from
the rain of Boulders that came down past
him they grazed his arms and Jarred
painfully against his muscles but it was
better than having them hit him in the
head without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back down the trail he had been
trying to follow the ground shifted and
lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous 3 hours hiking up
the mountains so how was it that now
that he had turned around and gone back
he was still going uphill it was almost
as if the ground was changing shape
beneath him as he ran dust filled his
lungs as he tried to wipe it away from
his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andy
mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to to prevent it what cruel
and inhumane measures would you take to
have such a threat or better yet how
many people would you kill to save the
world this debate is Raging right now as
you sit here and watch this video not
among the foundation but between two
scps so Grand in scale and so advanced
in nature that the foundation has no
option but to sit and listen as the pair
debate what to do with the human race as
CP
468-1 was not difficult to discover once
it started moving in fact it was almost
impossible to ignore earthquakes have
been tearing across South America for
centuries destroying homes taking the
lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more
mysterious our innocent hiker Diego had
been spending the week walking among the
Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of SCP
468-1 as the creature raised its head
into the air Diego saw that the head of
a serpent lifting several kilometers
away from him its body stretched and
wound its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of SCP
468-1 is hard to convey measuring over
500 km in length this serpent is longer
than most US states with a 20 km width
standing on the back of it quite
literally feels like standing on a
mountain range for context The Horizon
at sea level is about 4.8 km away so
multiply that by four and you'll get a
sense of just how wide this thing is
even small movements from this SCP are
enough to trigger continent wide
earthquakes with tremors being felt all
the way around the world upon the
initial discovery of this SCP the
foundation was enabled to determine why
it remains dormant for such long periods
and seems to only awaken sporadically
and for brief periods of time that was
until SC SCP
45682 was discovered it is little wonder
that the second serpent took so long to
be found its body is comprised almost
entirely of water sand algae and steam
it does not show up on Sonar scans and
is incredibly difficult to detect in the
water even visually its form is Loosely
defined while stormant with broadly
similar measurements to SCP
468-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creatures that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pines Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially SCP
45682 was believed to be the peaceful
one of the pair both serpents seemed to
become active at the same time while on
land SCP
468-1 would wreck havoc with magnitude
7even earthquakes in major metropolitan
areas the sea Serpent's function was
less well understood employing resonant
frequencies and vibrations this SCP was
able to give its watery body a distinct
form as it rose up from the ocean and
towered above the waves in order to
maintain its shape and control its
movements this SCP employed a huge
amount of energy however the foundation
quickly observed that it was rarely able
to maintain its form for very long as
soon as the sea serpent rose out of the
water its mountainous twin would begin
to move sending Tremors around the world
that disrupted the frequency needed for
SCP
45682 to remain animate exhausted and
unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dorcy gliding lazily through through
the oceans but this dormy suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each SC SCP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
withstanding earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great scps several early findings
stood out firstly SC SCP
468-1 appeared to have a very different
internal structure from its twin
researchers initially assumed that the
creature would be largely composed of
Earth minerals and rock as its exterior
appearance suggested however scans of
its body indicated the presence of what
can only be assumed to be artificially
created components great gears
resembling Clockwork structures and even
rudimentary circuitry were present
throughout the creature's body the
function or origin of these gears has
yet to be determined especially as there
is no evident way that their movement
corresponds to the autonomy and movement
of the serpent itself the far more
striking Discovery however came when the
SCP Foundation discovered a way to
communicate with the two beasts ultra
low frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances even light years were
discovered to be emitted from the two
serpent heads at intermittent periods
the foundation had to develop some of
the largest antenna ever created to pick
up these frequencies and interpret the
data coming through them what they found
were two twins locked in a fierce debate
about the fade of humanity and the
universe itself it was only then that
the motivations of these two serpents
started to make sense in 2010 almost as
soon as the foundation was able to tap
into the frequency they were contacted
directly by a CP
468-1 fion I know that you can hear me I
will not apologize for my actions I know
that I am the reason that millions of
your kind face their demise I know your
pain and I feel it too but I shall never
apologize for it I simply ask you to
listen to myself and to my word cannot
be translated you are curious you can be
patient exercise that and you may one
day understand and listen the foundation
did efforts to contain or destroy the
two serpents were put on the back burner
instead Foundation agents prioritize
spread spreading disinformation across
South America and Beyond about the
source of these earthquakes the two
serpents are far too large and far too
powerful to overcome or contain instead
the foundation prioritized the use of
amnestic drugs disinformation and the
creation of Fringe conspiracy groups to
discredit any claims of the serpent
respective existences meanwhile some of
the most senior leadership figures in
the foundation were and still are locked
in a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that SCP
45682 is intent on wiping out the entire
human race the only thing that has
prevented it from being able to do so
thus far has been the existence of the
other serpent every time that SCP
45682 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operation bace SCP
45682 came to the observation window to
look them in the eyes as it told them I
am sure you can see it how your world
dies a little bit more every day mostly
by your own hand no you poison the
oceans tame the river is black in the
skies you do not need angels of death to
destroy your world but there is
something else I see it in the bottom of
your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable ideas
cloaked in Madness and impossible colors
do you think I will let you drag the
rest of the world down with
yourselves do you think I will leave
this world my my world to Die In Flames
it sees your world and it comes in
F since this Revelation the foundation
has poured countless hours and resources
into trying to identify a cosmic threat
for well over a decade many of the
smartest scientists the world has to
offer have looked to the night sky
scanning for this impossible color this
shroud of Madness but to no avail some
within the foundation believe the
serpent is lying trying to make up an
excuse to justify its genocide but
information from SCP
468-1 seems to confirm everyone's worst
fears your minds burn bright fion all of
humanity shines from this rock like a
candle in a dark room it sees you an
idea exists only because something
thought of it have you ever considered
how such terrible concept could have
been given for them what kind of
atrocious mind could even think about it
humans cannot conceive the colorless
green what if you are playing into this
creature's hands there appears to be an
underlying implication that ideas are
the source of power somehow this
colorless green this unimaginable Cosmic
threat seems to be a monstrous idea
incarnate but whose idea Humanities the
there is a deep lore that the two
serpents discuss with one another one
that makes little sense even to this day
to the foundation they talk of gods and
goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel and
gears and of the fives quite what these
creatures are if they are even creatures
at all is a mystery to the foundation
researchers have not discovered a way of
communicating back with the two serpents
directly attempts to mimic their
language or transmit signals asking
questions to to them have largely been
ignored instead they address humanity
and the foundation as a whole seeming to
take the view of the human race as being
a collective hive mind one that they are
evidently able to tap into the pairs
seem uninterested in informing us as to
exactly what this threat is or
explaining who the gods and goddesses
are perhaps they assume we know these
things already or more likely they
believe that our Consciousness is not
yet capable perceiving the scale and
depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names Tren is the
land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way Kai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
trenten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come it is
something I like about you fion about
Mankind while it is easy to just take
the simplest path to just give up there
will always be some among you who refuse
use this path who do the right thing
maybe not all of you are this strong but
I can see it in your methods those
so-called containment procedures there
will always be someone who stands up
against the dark even if it takes a
thousand million years to emerge
Victorious maybe you can stop thefe
after all ideas can be killed with
better ideas even if it takes akes a,
million years if you've ever taken a
vacation to one of the many islands of
Greece then you'll know why the likes of
creit Lesbos and Corfu are famous for
their beautiful beaches but there is one
beach in particular tucked away in a
corner of an unknown Island that you
might think twice about visiting why
well the same reasons that this place
happens to be a site of great interest
for the SCP Foundation also tend to
drive tourists away today we're talking
about SCP
2217 the strange anomalous happenings
that have taken place there and how it
links to none other than one of the
foundation's most infamous groups of
interest at first glance SCP 2217 is an
ordinary uninteresting Beach just
another pretty picturesque view on a
Greek island it looks like the kind of
place that would be perfect for a
romantic walk at Sunset but we wouldn't
recommend it although you wouldn't know
just from looking at it the sand that
this beach is composed of has some
pretty peculiar properties it contains
the ordinary non-anomalous things you'd
find in sand anywhere else in the world
normal levels of silicates and calcium
compounds but the beach also possesses a
high concentration of cationic metallic
particles these tiny almost microscopic
metal fragments somehow hold an
electrical charge despite being grounded
so it's a beach with partially metal
sand nothing too unusual there right
wrong the metallic particles within the
sand seem to have a profound effect on
the natural environment to round SCP
2217 for one the metal content of the
beach influences the weather increasing
the number of lightning strikes that hit
the shore the metals draw the static
electricity in the atmosphere this along
with other weather conditions and
natural processes that take place at SCP
2217 also have a far more obvious
anomalous effect
lightning rain even fish washed up and
decaying on the shoreline have all
caused various artificial structures and
devices to rise from the beach which
have all been designated by the
foundation as SCP 221
2017-1 among the Creations found on the
beach in the wake of lightning strikes
are a number of different forms of
Machinery these have included simple
clocks and other time pieces to
complicated automatons these machines
have no notable anomalous properties as
far as the SCP Foundation has found
apart from the way they came to be and
they are otherwise fully functional also
discovered at SCP 2217 was jewelry
seeming to be made of discarded waste
that washed up on the beach in the tide
resembling bears and other recurring
motifs of a certain religion these
articles of jewelry have been made using
everything from old light bulbs to holes
of ships and even fish and animal bones
most notably however was the appearance
of a city or rather a model of a city
that was created at the beach and was
then referred to as SCP 2217 A1 there's
a cliff located on SCP
2217 and if one is to swim through an
underwater entrance they will find
themselves inside a grotto there somehow
carved by tital erosion of the rock is a
recreation of an ancient Greek city
although the geographical features of
the model seem to resemble an area near
Lake Bal in southern Siberia
the city Bears more of the same
religious iconography to the jewelry
that can often be found on the beach but
which religion the same one that
considers SCP 2217 to be a site of holy
importance the Church of the broken God
now some important context to make note
of for any who are unaware the Church of
the broken God is a religious
organization that the SCP Foundation has
had a number of encounters with over the
years members of the church share in the
their belief that biological flesh-
based life is inherently wrong an
Abomination even evil this religion
worships mechanization the process of
making something or someone more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church there were two
gods yabo and mechain who created
Humanity together yabo was the god of
Flesh and animal Instinct granting human
bodies meanwhile the god of machine and
intellect mechan blessed man with the
power of free thought as humankind
developed its civilizations by building
machines yalalo became enraged that they
were ignoring the instincts she had
bestowed upon them she endeavored to
destroy the creations of man in an
attempt to revert them to the animal she
had intended them to be as the church's
Legend goes mckain acted as Humanity's
Savior and tried desperately to stop
yabo the god of machine shattered
himself transforming his body into a
number of pieces to form a cage for his
fellow God fragments of mechain rained
down on planet Earth now the Church of
the broken God believes it is their duty
to recover these missing parts and put
their savior back together within the
religion of the Church of the broken God
there exists a splinter faction that
broke away from the main church this
group referred to as the broken church
are the ones that regard SCP 2217 so
highly considering it to be a holy sight
according to a piece of scripture from
their religion the broken Church
believes the beach to be Main's Workshop
the book of writs describes the legend
of a boy looking out at the ocean with
his family and seeing fire rain down on
the shore sent from God or mechain to
the church mechain apparently proclaimed
that the beach was his Workshop where he
made Many Wonders the lightning is my
hammer the Earth my Anvil the sand my
Ingot me explain to the boy so the
legend goes and invited the child into
his Workshop the broken God brought his
hammer down on the boy but instead of
killing him marked him as the first of
the religion the broken church now
follows in 2014 the SCP Foundation
recorded an earthquake taking place at
SCP
2217 with The Grotto containing the
model of the ancient Greek city at the
epicenter sending a robotic probe into
the grot to assess the damage only to
find a surprising change that had
occurred for the first time there were a
number of humanoid figures seen within
SCP
22171 and worse still they were under
attack within the model City what
appeared to be a number of individuals
infected with SCP 610 were ransacking
buildings devouring and infecting the
other humanoid figures also known as the
flesh that hates SCP 610 is a contagious
skin disease it is usually transmitted
by by direct skin-to-skin contact and
anyone that is infected with It suffers
a horrific mutation that transforms them
into fleshy inhuman
monstrosities these infected creatures
will attack and infect anyone nearby
that isn't also carrying SCP 610
interestingly the disease was first
discovered to be localized to a small
area in Siberia not dissimilar to the
area that the SCP
22171 model resembled According to some
sources SCP 610 is the flesh described
by those following the religion of
sarcasm a cult that worships flesh and
disease sarcas ism is a sect that
directly opposes and antagonizes the
Machine revering Church of the broken
God three years after the earthquake
members of the broken Church staged an
attack on the beach hoping to reclaim
SCP 2217 for their religion at the time
the SCP Foundation had closed off the
area to the public under the cover story
that SCP 2217 was private property they
had been hoping to predict the lightning
strikes that caused the anomalous
devices to form on the beach instead the
foundation had to repel the broken
Church's attackers any way they could
however as the lightning began to strike
again members of foundation Personnel
that found themselves caught in it
seemed to change sides all stating that
God needs to be reassembled only a year
later in 2018 another group of broken
Church zealots stormed from the beach
and the foundation Outpost located there
this time the church seemed to have
gained further reinforcements
specifically members of other groups of
interest in particular some belonging to
the Church of maxwellism and the cogwork
Orthodox Church both of which were also
Splinter groups of the Church of the
broken God the cogwork Orthodox Church
arose during the Industrial Revolution
believing that adding mechanical parts
to their own bodies offered greater
understanding of mechain and brought
them closer to their God maxwellism in a
similar vein had another interpretation
of the church's core beliefs favoring
smaller more advanced cybernetic
implants the Church of maxwellism sought
to modify their brains to become a
collective Consciousness and commune
with McCain despite a lot of
pre-existing animosity between the three
core Splinter groups of the church they
were able to successfully capture SCP
2217 the three factions sent a video
message to the foundation proclaiming CL
in the importance of their mission oh
disassemblers who call themselves a
foundation what are you a foundation for
if you are a foundation for life then
you will let us keep this land for the
flesh is coming and only we can stop it
we need to bring our God back together
immediately or else you will all perish
and now it is time if you are a
foundation for life you will not let
this happen you'll let us defeat the
flesh several more messages were sent to
the foundation demanding the Rel release
of various scps with connection to the
broken God you see there could
potentially be hundreds of pieces needed
to rebuild mechan so he can lead the
church to glory and defeat yalah a
number of these pieces happen to be
cataloged scps and the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
these include SCP 882 or his broken
heart to the church SCP 271 his broken
gift SCP 8813 his Broken Eyes SCP 1139
his broken tongue SCP 635 his broken
mind and finally his broken blood which
refers to SCP 217 with a beach under the
control of the Church of the broken God
any foundation Personnel Left Alive on
SCP 2217 defected and joined the church
in order to retake the beach and
reestablish containment the foundation
was forced to do something that they
only do in the most dire of
circumstances ask for help help together
with the Horizon initiative and Global
occult Coalition the SCP Foundation
established what it called the
triumvirate a Joint Task Force in 2019
another earthquake was detected this
time in Lake Bal Siberia where SCP 610
was contained not long after infected
individuals were reported to be
attacking Foundation forces in the area
causing heavy casualties but then an
unlikely event took place members of the
Church of the broken God appeared their
bodies augmented with Machinery these
zealots that had fought the foundation
for control of SCP 227 were now coming
to its Aid to repel SCP 610 according to
them God or rather mecan had told them
to come to assist the foundation using a
large-scale electrical discharge
instances of the SCP 610 contagion were
eradicated but this discharge seemed to
have originated from the same island
where SCP 2217 was found following this
incident Robert buero the leader of the
broken Church sent a video message to
the leaders of the triber including the
05 Council the director of the global
cat Coalition and the Horizon
initiatives tribunal in his message
buero stated it's not too late you know
this is our world as well we both want
the flesh to end and we can help you we
can help each other come to the Anvil we
will talk and we can save this world the
Church of the broken God its Splinter
groups uniting to take SCP 2217 for
their religion were now extending an
olive branch to the foundation and its
allies all in the name of protecting the
world shortly after the foundation
Global cult Coalition and Horizon
initiative began working collaboratively
with the Church of the broken God to
prepare for an XK class scenario
retaking control of the SCP 2217 Beach
for now the foundation intends to revoke
this current Arrangement after the
dangerous scenario has been averted but
perhaps McCain's Workshop will provide
vital in reassembling the broken God and
saving Humanity should yal deach ever
return to exact her terrible Revenge it
was just a job you were meant to be
mopping floors and cleaning toilets at
the Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage and you
were happy about it grateful for any
kind of employment you didn't even know
that the company signing checks was the
SCP Foundation an organization dedicated
to securing and containing anomalies and
protecting Humanity from their negative
effects at any cost and today you're
going to find out exactly how steep that
cost can be the Johnston labs and
pharmaceuticals Research Center isn't
actually a research center at all it's a
foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly SCP 3280
but again you're just the janitor it's
not like they would bother telling you
what's being contained here if it breaks
out you won't even know what's killing
you until it's too late it begins like
most classic horror stories on a dark
and stormy night you're mopping up a
silent hallway whistling a little tune
to yourself when rain starts hammering
down on the window next to you not long
after you see a bolt of lightning split
the distant Sky followed by an immense
thundercrack back soon after you hear
screaming and panicking From Below
frantic footsteps then the flashing
lights and Sirens you think back to your
employee orientation these flashing
lights and wailing Sirens can only mean
one thing Containment Breach you run for
it not even knowing what you're running
from you bring your mop and bucket with
you perhaps just out of habit you seek
refuge in the only place in the facility
that truly seems to belong to you the
broom closet the alarm blares as you
lock yourself in the closet you're
shaking with Terror and can hear the
screaming of your colleagues you hear
more noises running scrambling a wet
dripping sound gunshots and then silence
all this time you can't help but wonder
why isn't anybody coming to help us
after a while the only thing you can
hear is the rain and the distant Thunder
it's been hours you've only managed to
save off dehydration by drinking the
filthy water from the mop sink but at
least it seems like the chaos outside
has died down carefully you open the
door and peek out of the closet Darkness
but no detectable movement now's your
chance and you make a break for it
creeping down the hall the dark hallway
is suddenly lit up by lightning and you
can see that there are bodies everywhere
you step over the corpse of Dr coone one
of the few scientists working here who
actually knew your name if if you can
make it to the security office you might
be able to radio for help or maybe
access a computer terminal on the way to
the office you hear another horrific
scream start to echo through the complex
before it's cut off by a Thunderclap you
have to ignore it though and push on
when you enter the security room you see
that the head security officer Nicholls
is already dead his body has been cut
open from neck to groin gutted the
anomaly whatever it is has already
already been here you access the
computer terminal and open the file for
SCP
3280 you're warned that as janitorial
staff you have level zero clearance and
as a result information will be omitted
from the files you access it doesn't
matter you press on and open up the file
both the object class and the
description have been redacted you can
only see the special containment
procedures they dictate that 3280 is to
remain contained at the Johnston labs
and pharmaceuticals Research Center
until long-term containment procedures
can be drawn up if the entity ever
reaches Beyond sublevel 2 the facility
enters full lockdown mode not even
information is allowed in or out of the
facility as this could result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario in other
words nobody is coming to save you the
only other information on the page is a
picture of a lightning storm much like
the one you find yourself in right now
lightning flashes is in the hall you
Dart around paranoid knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere all you can hear now
is the quiet drip drip drip of blood
coming from the body of security officer
Nicholls whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around Nicholls
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nicholls was the kind of
guy who' write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level two
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift news attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr Emanuel
stumbling down a dark Corridor his
movements are oddly listless like he's
in a trance suddenly there's another
flash of lightning and a crack of
thunder Dr Emanuel clutches his gut in
pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols and the special
containment procedures now they're
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from sublevel
2 and see another corpse lying in the
corner he's wearing an orange jumpsuit
d-class no idea why he was down there
the only other notable thing in the
basement was a burst pipe leaking and
spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically underwater the
only evidence of the massacre that must
have taken place are the fragments of
clothing floating on the surface of the
water that and the fleshy pink slurry
forming at the bottom of the windows it
reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories you close your
eyes and try to Center yourself it's
violent chaos looking at more of it
isn't getting you anywhere instead you
put those new level two security access
credentials to good use and hop back
onto the file for SCP 3280 you think to
yourself there has to be something I can
use on here but even as you wait for the
file to load some part of you knows that
time is running out for you perhaps it's
the stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drank but you're feeling the
pressure start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for SCP 3280 is now
Declassified uclid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now explain that every
week a new member of d-class personnel
is to be deposited into the entity's
layer in sublevel 2 through subterranean
access point gamma the d-class or more
accurately the sacrifices are to be told
lies about why exactly they need to
descend to the lowest point in the
facility they're even given a working
flashlight and a defensive night stick
to create the illusion that the
foundation expects them to ever return
from the depths little do they know they
also have a tiny transmitter sewn into
their jumpsuit this broadcasts a
frequency that will attract an eager SCP
3280 to the d-class location like a
dinnerbell only it can hear the file
specifies that SCP 3280 always prefers
live prey well at least that explains
the dead DCL class in suevel 2 you think
hoping that it will somehow overwhelm
the dizziness your feeling or the
nagging pain in your gut you read on
somehow the file's tone becomes even
more severe it says that failure to
maintain the containment of SCP 3280
will not only trigger a lockdown it will
always call in the intervention of two
different mobile task forces MTF Iota 12
the silencers and to 4 also known as
water water everywhere if 12 hours pass
from the point of initial Containment
Breach and the 05 Council hasn't been
given the all clear signal by one of
these teams preparation Begins for an
imminent XK Class end of the world
scenario just reading the words sends
you into a cold sweat end of the world
what on Earth is this creature finally
you reach the the description you get to
find out what this horrifying entity
actually is but the last thing you
expect is the first sentence in the file
to read SCP 3280 is a Sapient entity
composed of a fluid physically identical
to water capable of traveling roughly 2
and 1/2 km per hour it's water it's
literally a living thinking blob of
water as you read on the concerning
details pile up any water that the
anomalous SC CP 3280 water touches it
integrates it into its own Mass but
anytime water is separated from this
Mass it remains anomalous and continues
to act independently when the creature
was first discovered it was a mere 66.4
l in volume now it's around
2500 the water infected by SCP 3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in a
defensive manner SCP 3280 will actively
seek out human prey and when it finds
them it forces its mass into any
available body orifice including the
victim's pores this can happen in such a
subtle manner that you may not even
notice yourself being infiltrated but
below this the file has a list of
symptoms for those experiencing 30280
infiltration loss of motor control
weakening of the mcari reflex visual
hallucinations and abdominal pain as you
read the words your stomach gives
another painful Tri turn almost like
something is moving around inside of you
it's all coming together you read on the
file states that SCP 3280 is so
difficult to contain because it exhibits
claustrophobic Tendencies anytime it's
placed inside a container whether
organic or inorganic it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at
over 255 mph if the water is inside a
human it may literally explode out of
them killing them in the process your
jittering eyes turned to the gutted body
of security officer Nicholls it all
makes sense now everything is becoming
clear as the pain in your stomach builds
in its intensity the file goes on to say
that if SCP 3280 escapes sublevel 2 it
may be impossible to contain again if
3280 ever escaped the site proper it
would indeed cause an XK Class end of
the world scenario to unfold as 3280
merged with our water cycle and
destroyed all of human Humanity on a
global scale it would become truly
impossible for anyone to escape you
can't read anymore the pain in your
stomach is unbearable you jerk from your
seat and stumble out into the Hall
doubled over in agony you can feel it
pulsing in there fighting its way out it
must have gotten in through the filthy
mop water you were drinking you didn't
even know it but your fate has been
sealed for hours you've been a dead man
walking the hum of pain builds in your
ears and renders you almost death all
you can hear is the pattern of rain and
distant Thunder you collapse against the
glass feeling the coolness of it against
the skin of your face and in that moment
you see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse direction there's
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you SCP 3280 has escaped it's out there
and it's it's going to drown the entire
world as you collapse to your knees and
prepare to be torn apart from the inside
your final thought is that at least you
won't be alive to see it Jack was
swimming deep underwater wondering why
he had such a pounding headache when
suddenly he had a terrifying realization
he had no idea where he was or what he
was doing there was a nagging feeling
that he must have a specific reason to
be here you don't just end up deep in
the ocean with a diving suit on by
chance yet he had no idea what he was
supposed to be doing he wasn't sure he
cared either he was more worried about
the throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was going to die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered SCP
3000 before Jack's descent into despair
the SCP Foundation had mandated an
exploratory Expedition off the coast of
Bangladesh after receiving a few strange
reports from locals and fisherman the
foundation suspected an SCP was lurking
in the water and positioned a few
Personnel to investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead was Far stranger
and more ominous all of the had been
verified to be in sound mental States
when the mission set out but a few of
them reported feeling strange and uneasy
as the submarine descended into the
ocean before long a veteran agent named
Dr Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone to sending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calm crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now p faing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as SCP 3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
look creature with a head as big as a
town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and Light life had left him and he
just began screaming no repeatedly again
and wouldn't respond to any attempts to
calm him down not that anyone else was
very capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came after W the image of the
eel-like creature's eyes seemed burned
in their minds permanently it would
haunt their waking hours for the rest of
their lives and sleep was no Escape
either as they would appear in both
their dreams and nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
SCP 3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Mission were willing to return to the
waters but new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self- sabotaging the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them them were
tethered together for extra security but
the deeper into the ocean they swam and
the closer they got to SCP 3000's
location they got the stranger things
became just like on the last mission
first there were a few minor cases of
confusion one of the team Jack thought
it was his responsibility to lead the
navigation but another Roberto also
thought it was his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member Amir but he seemed to
have forgotten everyone was getting
confused the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation headqu
grew increasingly concerned about what
they could hear was everyone losing
their minds hopefully nobody was about
to pull another Dr Williams on them
still the project leads couldn't afford
to tell the men to come back to the
surface the foundation badly needed any
information they could get on this SCP
whatever the cost so they told the men
to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away 2 years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the to
the ramblings of Dr Williams it
increasingly began to look like a
suicide mission then there was silence
what was going on each of the men had
completely lost it to the point that
they cut the tether that was holding
them together all alone Jack couldn't
remember where he was or why he was here
he desperately looked around to try and
gauge his surroundings but he could only
see Darkness all he could think about
was a pair of large eyes and an
overwhelming fear of Despair and anxiety
and this weird gray fluid that was now
floating in front of him the foundation
listened as Jack started reciting a
creepy speech about being on the edge of
nothing inches from Oblivion with a
sickness in his mind and nothing but a
pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in too why
couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean and had now moved away from the
eyes of SCP 3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts and
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around SCP 3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of SCP 3000 now and
Roberto was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he acquired some very important
data but he seemed to have lost all hope
of preserving his life Roberto started
telling the team over the radio that he
was dying and that his heart rate was
too high but cautioned that it would be
too dangerous for anyone to try and
rescue him the Personnel continued to
try and communicate with Roberto to
figure out what was going on but his
words had stopped making any sense until
finally he went quiet minutes turned
into hours hours into days and still
there was no sign of Roberto or the rest
of the divers after 3 days His Radio
which had only been sending a steady
stream of Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams and the diving Trio the
collection of y99 might have resulted in
two disastrous missions but there's a
silver line in as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain y99 is somewhat
ethically questionable for most people
SCP 3000 produces y99 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects CP
3000 as best as it can guard something
hundreds of kilometers long the area is
carefully patrolled and members of the
public are not allowed to enter the part
of the bay where it resides anybody who
accidentally comes into contact is
contained eventually another pair of
foundation doctors went down in a
submarine to try and learn more about
SCP 3000 one became so affected by y 99
that he began hallucinating he started
talking about anantaa the king of
serpents in Hinduism anant shesha is
believed to be all that will be left
after the end of the world because it
exists throughout all of time
simultaneously the doctor said he
believed that this was in fact an anesa
that SCP 3000 simply shows us that
eventually everyone dies and Fades into
the darkness of Oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth luckily for now SCP 3000 seems
to be in a sort of hibernation state it
rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat to INF fed but no
one knows when or if it'll wake or what
it's capable of if it does will it
destroy the world or simply drive us all
insane Commander McGrath one of the most
influential members of mobile task force
alpha 1 better known as the red right
hand had been summoned by his Masters
for one of the most important missions
of his life it was so Above Top Secret
even he would likely need to undergo
amnestic treatment once he'd seen the
job through it comes with a territory
when you're dealing with SCP
006 the red right hand is no ordinary
Mobile T Force either they were the
personal enforcers of the 05 Council the
13 most powerful members of the SCP
Foundation and by extension some of the
most powerful human beings on Earth
Commander McGrath stood before the
assembled Council trying to suppress the
Tremors of fear and awe running through
him he'd gone toe-to-toe with SCP 076
Abel one of the finest humanoid Warriors
ever known during one of his many
containment breaches he led strike
forces after a fleeing SCP 682 the heart
to destroy reptile after it escaped its
acid tank and began charging towards the
nearest populated area intent on causing
Mass death he'd personally taken out
more people than you've probably ever
met all at the behest of his foundation
superiors and yet standing right here
before them he couldn't help feel a
twinge of deep Terror it was like
staring right into the face of God and
waiting for it to Blink with his well
honed military observation skills he
noted that 0 5-2 wasn't among the
council this time but he knew better
than to ask why he was employed to take
orders not to ask questions and this
time his orders were something special
he wasn't given any more information
than this McGrath we need you to lead an
elite team to a Sten in Russia on the
double procedure 06 is now in effect you
know what to do McGrath nodded he'd been
prepared for this day his predecessor
Commander Richards had only needed to
enact procedure 006 once in his long and
storyed career with the red right hand
it was truly a once- in a-lifetime
assignment and now the torch had been
passed to him the only question was
whether he'd be up to the task but
McGrath didn't have time to ponder on
this question time was of the essence
first he needed to assemble a team small
but focused loyal men who'd Keep Their
Heads down complete the mission and take
the Forbidden Knowledge no further than
the bounds of said Mission McGrath
selected three operatives Bennett
demaggio and Stewart all of whom had
proven valuable Assets in Prior missions
they would be the ones to accompany him
on this most valuable and secretive of
directives procedure
006 but before they could execute the
mission itself they needed to be trained
briefed and fitted with the proper
equipment for Mission this sensitive and
dealing with an anomaly as as deadly as
SCP
006 they needed to wear modified class 6
B andc suits these are the ultimate
total exclusion hazmat suits designed
specifically by the SCP Foundation they
offered such a degree of protection that
they made Regular hazmat suits look like
bikinis Commander McGrath actually knew
very little about SCP 006 and how it
worked like many of the more top secret
anomalies contained by the foundation
only the 05 Council understood the full
scope of it everyone below them were
only told the specific fragments of
information they needed to do their job
after all filling your head with the
wrong kinds of knowledge can get your
memory wiped or worse at the SCP
Foundation SCP 006 as far as Commander
McGrath knew was the more traditional
kind of toxic he'd been briefed using
the SCP 006b info pack a heavily
redacted description of SCP
006 safe class liquid in nature but one
of the most toxic substances known to
man it made Mercury and uranium look
like a glass of mineral water and more
dangerous still if someone came into
contact with even the tiniest quantity
of SCP 006s liquids they would not only
be marked for certain death they would
also become a vector for transmission a
veritable plague rat a walking danger to
all mankind that's why the class 6 BNC
suits needed to be tested McGrath
Bennett dagio and Stuart suited up in a
secure foundation training facility and
fully submerged themselves in a training
pool this was how they made sure that
there were no vulnerabilities in the
suits if any bubbles were generated it
meant there was a leak and if there was
a leak then the person wearing the
defective suit was as good as dead when
they reached the real
006 lucky for them no leaks they were
ready to proceed to the next stage of
the mission making making their way to
arren Russia where SCP 006 was contained
the pressure was on with the council
growing more impatient by the moment so
they needed to make the journey
immediately every minute counted and
Commander McGrath was painfully aware of
the time slipping away though he
couldn't possibly fathom why they need a
toxic chemical like this with such
urgency they made their journey in a
covert cargo plane it was beyond
important to keep all Foundation
activity around SCP 006 Under Wraps a
number of groups of Interest cells were
active in the area including the Church
of the broken God and the Serpent's hand
and if ever the dreaded chaos Insurgency
CAU wind of SCP 006 is existence and
triangulated its location the damage it
could do would be unprecedented that's
why nobody but the 05 council could
truly be trusted with this almost sacred
knowledge when they touched down in
estren they met with a foundation
Courier who would take them on the final
leg of their Journey to the foundation
site roughly 60 km west of the Town
McGrath and his team had no idea what
they were headed towards or the insane
history of the land they traversed all
because of SCP
006 the foundation had first become
aware of the anomaly back during the
19th century but were unable to gain
control of it until
1991 due to it being fiercely guarded by
A procession of territorial Russian
rulers the blood of hundreds of thousand
had been spilled on this land in the
historic Wars and conflicts over SCP
006 so many had wasted their entire
lives unsuccessfully trying to find it
during the several hour car trip to the
site Commander McGrath had no idea of
the true value of the anomaly he and his
small team were heading towards but he
would in time though an innocent would
have to die first The Courier dropped
the four operatives off outside an
abandoned chemical plant in the stick
far from what anyone would call
civilization it was the kind of
industrial Decay you could expect in the
bad lands of rural Russia a huge complex
weathered and broken by time but what
the untrained Observer wouldn't realize
is that the plant was actually full of
heavily trained and even more heavily
armed Foundation security personnel as
McGrath's team approached the building
they had no less than eight sniper
rifles pointed at them from various
Vantage points within the plant just to
be safe the foundation couldn't afford
to take any chances with SCP
006 they arrived at the gate and
provided their clearance credentials
they were envoys here on behalf of the
05 Council themselves and if they
weren't allowed to complete their
mission then the 006 Personnel would
have the death of a council member on
their hands with that the team was given
a free pass into the site under close
observation anyone seeking to interface
SCP 006 was forced to do so under almost
micro M roscopic scrutiny even when
inside the building McGrath and his men
needed to pass multiple secure
checkpoints throughout the Halls each
time restating their security
credentials eventually they reached a
different section of the building for
boating anomalous hallways gave way to
what seemed like a mix of a garden and a
jungle but the plants were different the
trees the shrubs even the weeds were
unlike anything members of the team had
ever seen before it was like stepping
into an alien world or perhaps this
world but as it was a few million years
prior it was terrifying and wondrous
they suited up in their class 6 BNC
suits fearing Airborne contaminants from
SCP 006 before proceeding further they
walk through this new Jungle being
watched at every turn by security
cameras and Personnel posted throughout
this overgrown portion of the facility
it didn't take long for them to reach
their destination the legend AR SCP
006 a small natural spring jutting out
of a rock surrounded by Rich Emerald
grass it looked more like a nice place
to have a picnic than a dangerous and
highly secretive anomaly but McGrath
wasn't paid to question things only to
carry out procedure
006 the only object they had with them
was the quad sealant container an ultra
secure liquid containment unit
specifically designed for safely
transporting samples of SCP 00 6's water
between sights the team members
descended into the spring and began
filling up the container it was
nerve-wracking knowing the stakes of
their mission and knowing that they were
submerged in such a deadly substance but
they had a job to do and they were going
to do it come hell or high water they
filled the containment unit but sadly
for McGrath and his team the mission
wouldn't be entirely without casualty a
single bubble Rose from the leg of
Stuart's suit he was a good MTF
operative but the youngest and least
experienced member of the team his suit
must have somehow been damaged during
Transit and now he was compromised he
shared a haunting glance with McGrath
and his fellow team members knowing that
his part of the mission and his life was
about to come to a Swift and violent end
alarms rang out across the facility a
huge team of armed operatives all
wearing class 6 BNC suits charged into
the room Stewart was grabbed and
manhandled out of the Z 006 spring while
his fellow team members sealed the
containment unit and continued their
mission there was no time to stop rest
or mourn completing the mission was the
absolute priority if McGrath understood
the protocol as well as he thought he
did Stuart would be dragged into a
secure room by the site staff and locked
in with a blast door he would look down
and notice the floor below him was a
metal grate caked with Ash his last
thoughts as the incinerator launches its
Flames into action would strangely be
the fact that he was feeling the
healthiest he'd been in years but that
wouldn't stop the sudden furnace around
him from decimating his body and leaving
little more than Ash and charred bones
over a decade of loyal MTF service ended
in an instant Stewart would have been
terminated according to orders from the
top it was all that could be done for
those afflicted by a SCP 006 a mercy
really if they were to be believed
McGrath and his team soldiered on after
retrieving the sample they were h back
into their Inception point one of the
many classified bases occupied by the 05
council members while dagio and Bennett
were ushered off to be given amnestic
treatment McGrath would personally get
to see the containment unit and its
Precious Cargo make the final leg of the
journey he was going to be granted
access
25-2 the person this had all been in
service of Commander McGrath approached
the secure quarters of the council
member escorted by a bevy of heavily
armed security Personnel the doors open
and he saw her there
hard Trembling Hands McGrath watched in
horror as she disengaged the lid and
swigged down the entirety of its
contents but wasn't the water toxic he
thought McGrath had been fed the same
lie as everybody else the foundation
didn't keep 006 such a well-guarded
secret because it was capable of
bringing death quite the opposite in
fact all Commander McGrath could do was
stare a struck as the years seem to fall
from 0 5-2 face decades and decades and
decades scars faded wrinkles disappeared
little by little 0 5-2 began to sit and
then stand by the time she was
straightening her clothes she looked
like a healthy woman in her mid-40s it
was a complete and total transformation
the liquid of SCP 006 has a plethora of
benefits to human subjects the ability
to regenerate damaged DNA by heightened
excitement of cellular duplication and
producing a frightening increase in the
effectiveness of the human immune system
even upon testing the liquid on animal
subjects hostile bacteria and viral
agents were destroyed immediately
members of the 05 Council are experts at
cheating death and SCP 006 is just
another Ace hidden up their sleeve in
the endless battle against the reaper a
secret so well-guarded that they are
willing to terminate even their most
loyal servants to keep it safe after all
if everyone knew about it everyone would
want it and the 05 Council are very
invested in exclusivity never normally
one to rise above his station Commander
McGrath couldn't help blurred out but if
it was all Li private Stewart is
perfectly alive all smoking mirrors you
see and like everyone who works a 006
mission he won't remember a thing good
work Commander McGrath 0 5-2 now in
perfect health replied now return to
your post after a visit to our boys and
amnestics there's still plenty to be
done and we can't afford to Dilly after
all you're not getting any younger 40
years ago a US Navy exploratory vessel
landed on a chain of islands in the
South Atlantic just 2,000 Mi off the
coast of Argentina in other words the
middle of nowhere yet on this far off
set of rocks afloat in the middle of the
ocean they discovered a vast array of
strange wildlife and plant species that
resemble little of what they left behind
on the mainland could this be a treasure
Trove of UN discovered species they
wondered hoping to capitalize on the
Discovery a reconnaissance team of
researchers was sent out to explore some
of the islands on foot and what they
found did not disappoint from endangered
species of birds to plant life and
vegetation that looked like it belonged
on Mars they found a dizzying array of
new and exciting examples of
evolutionary oddies that would fill a
library but unfortunately their
Jubilation was cut short attempting to
collect soil samples they dug into the
ground and soon discovered that what
they were standing on wasn't actually
ground at all the Navy scientists soon
discovered the rocky terrain they were
exploring was actually made up entirely
of organic matter as per the standard
protocol the SCP Foundation was forced
to silence the US Navy research vessel
after its Discovery with the okay from
the US government the ship was torpedo
and sunk to the bottom of the ocean with
all hands on deck in the name of
protecting the greater good of the
master es a tragedy at sea for the sake
of preventing worldwide pandemonia from
there the foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as SCP 169
better known by its nickname the
Leviathan The Leviathan is a Biblical
creature of mythical proportions said to
be able to boil the Seas and create
Earth ending floods with just a whip of
its massive continent spanning body it
is unclear if SCP 169 has has the
ability to do these things though given
its massive size which Foundation
researchers estimate to be somewhere
between 2,000 and 8,000 km it's easy to
see how something that big moving at any
speed could be devastating for the
coastal regions of the world although we
use the word contain it is impossible
for SCP staff to ever contain something
of such massive size surveillance and
monitoring are about all we can do for
now that and hope it never wakes up and
decides that we on the menu it was
thought to be relatively smooth sailing
until one incident changed everything Dr
Hart turned off the video monitor and
faced the assembled members of MTF gamma
6 also known as the Deep feeders
renowned for their specialization in the
tracking of deep sea and oceanic
anomalies the room was dark and each
team member was sitting in Shadow but
still Dr Hart could see the seriousness
on their faces I'm sure you're wondering
why I call called you here at such short
notice he said on the screen behind him
he put up a NASA satellite picture of a
small set of Rocky Islands you see this
little island chain here well it wasn't
there a week ago he paused rubbing his
forehead from lack of sleep at 8:05 a.m.
today we recorded another auditory
anomaly emitting from SCP 169 this one
was much louder and longer than the one
recorded in 1997 by the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration the one
known as the the bloop back then it was
easy to brush off as some ice breaking
off of a continental shelf and scraping
against the seafloor it's not so easy to
cover up anymore these auditory
emissions from SCP 169 are beginning to
grow more frequent more than that
increased seismic activity around the
archipelago on the creature's back
indicates that the rate at which the
creature is breathing is also up
typically the rate at which the creature
takes what we are assuming to be a
breath is once every 3 months the rate
has increased to once every 3 weeks for
as long as we've been monitoring SCP 169
it's been a drift along the southern
Atlantic never moving more than a
kilometer a week that behavior is slowly
beginning to change it doesn't sound
like much but something that big even
moving just a fraction of that faster
means 100t tidal waves for the entire
South American Coastline We Fear the
creatures showing signs of waking up if
this is true could mean a cataclysm for
the hundreds of Nations around the world
Millions hell even billions could be
wiped off the face of the Earth if this
thing just flips its body too fast in
the wrong direction to put it to scale
this monster is about the size of the
Caribbean maybe even bigger as far as we
know the doctor then pulled out a
decanter of whiskey and poured himself a
glass swallowing the entire pore in one
go in an appalling breach of workplace
professionalism seriously an XK Class
end of the world scenario is still no
EXC excuse for drinking on the job we're
talking about an extinction level event
a Bonafide XK Class end of the world
scenario 1,000 ft tsunami wave
stretching as far as the IE can see from
either end of The Horizon the last time
SCP 169 stirred it created the
Mediterranean in fact the legends of the
biblical flood Noah's Arc the same story
can be found in every civilization in
culture around the world so maybe they
were on to something it is to this end I
call you all here to save save the world
from the next great flood he paused for
a moment as the room took in the gravity
of the situation the more we can learn
about SCP 169 the better right now we
know squat for one we've never seen just
how deep the body of the creature goes
or what's under it the pressure has been
too great for our current model
submarines until now after reinforcing
on Nemo 1 deep sea submersible with
theurgical runes the Integrity of its
whole has increased exponentially your
mission will be to travel as far down
and as close to the creature as possible
if it breathes then there must be gills
or lungs there must be some basic
biological facts we need to understand
if we're going to survive extinction our
only recourse is to find a way to sedate
the creature and if that doesn't work
then God help us all just 12 hours later
deep in the waters of the Southern
Atlantic a massive submersible ship was
diving down into into the depths of the
deep ocean looking for a way to stop the
end of the world Agent J 6-1 a member of
deep feeders looked out of the massive
viewing Port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of SCP 169 behind
him was Dr Hart sporting a white 5:00
shadow and a red nose from a night of
drinking to calm his nerves the entire
crew were silent in awe as the giant
flood lights of the ship brushed over
the Barnacle covered surfaces of the
undersea mountain they progressed slowly
breaching each milestone in depth with
caution knowing that one wrong move
could destabilized the pressure in their
ship J 6-1 murmured the word scales what
asked Dr Hart I've been watching the
patterns of The Ridges as we sink down
they look like scales giant segments
it's hard to see at first because
they're so covered in Barnacles and
sediment but I'm sure of it they're
giant armored scales the way lobsters or
crabs have armored exoskeletons
interesting the doctor said scratching
his chin arthopods have segmented
armored bodies this means we might be
looking at some sort of evolutionary
hybrid some sort of aquatic mammo such
as a whale or dolphin one that has
developed armored segmented scales
similar to that of a crustation the
doctor crossed his arms to think the
closest thing we have on the fossil
record of this magnitude is an armored
fish from the Cretaceous Period but even
that's way too small to compare to this
this thing has an entire ecosystem on
its back how old is it asked the agent
well now that you mention it given the
impossible age of the creature an arrod
would make sense lobsters and other
crustations don't age conventionally you
see they are effectively Immortal in
fact they actually die because they
continue to grow until their bodies
can't hold up their humongous size
anymore yet SCP 169 just kept growing
the doctor trailed off thinking to
himself Dr har still lost in thought
turned to walk to the back of the
submersible as ja 6-1 followed he said
as much to himself as to the agent the
creature is old the Geological Survey
conducted when SCP 169 was first
discovered carbonated the specimen to
over 541 million years old as you can
probably surmise that's too old for any
living being the results had to be
incorrect and yet I checked them myself
more than once and numbers do not lie
The Entity predates our civilization
hell it predates complex life forms on
this planet as we know it from an
evolutionary standpoint it doesn't make
any sense the agent confused asked
doctor how could something so big even
come into existence very little of our
planet is actually land mass it's a
wonder we call it Earth most of this
planet is water we aren't looking at a
creature that's on our planet agent we
are on its Planet just then a flurry of
alarms and sensors began to go off at
the bridge of the ship the team
scrambled through their stations
checking off monitors and shouting
readings to each other the ship's
thermal sensors are detecting a massive
rise in temperature transmitting power
to cooling systems we have activity
Northwest of our location sonar has
something bigheaded in our way we need
to dive now the ship lged forward nose
first as everyone on board held on to
their seats the restraints keeping them
from falling forward just outside of the
viewing report Dr Hart could see an
enormous scale appendage moving fast in
their location we need need to steer the
ship clear of the talons revert all
power to the thrusters get us out of the
way the doctor yelled don't you think
I'm doing that the captain shouted back
the ship jolted sideways and downwards
as an immense wave of pressure came over
the submersible putting six G's of force
on its occupants ja 6-1 yeled out of
fear as the ship came close to crashing
into what appeared to be the edge of a
Titanic Talon the size of the Empire
State Building following the encounter
the part of the ship bard ing the
reinforced glass of the viewing Port
began to Glow bright red it's boiling
the water around us one of the crew
members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just cavitation due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated ruins on the ship's Hall should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission bottom
feers after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of Nemo 1 began
to relax as their Pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater Behemoth before long The
Vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under the
creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of
scp-169 after several hours the ship
Came Upon giant fissures in the Rocky
exterior of the creature these massive
vent likee structures appeared stiff but
slowly they opened and closed over the
span of weeks these were the respiratory
organs of the organism blocking in at
over 2 miles underneath the surface of
the ocean the crew carefully began
entering the smaller pod-like
submersibles that detach from their main
ship J 6-1 entered his pod and strapped
on the haptic gloves that would give him
control of the pod's robotic arms he and
a team of three other volunteers had
agreed to undergo The Dangerous Mission
of attaching artificial chemical
emission machines that could be
programmed to release anesthetic gas
into SCP 169 respiratory system on
command remotely the emission machines
could be refueled manually whenever the
contents ran out it was an ingenious
solution Dr Hart came up with when
thinking of his time studying sharks as
a marine biologist it would tag the fins
of sharks by capturing them and bringing
the specimens on the deck of their boat
from there the scientist would drill a
radio frequency emitter onto the fin of
the shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student Dr
Hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
these tags would not be falling off he
thought they could not for the sake of
all mankind this had to work the doctor
pressed a button on the receiver of the
radio and spoke J 6-1 what's your status
pressure holding all signs look good 6-2
pressure holding all good 6-3 all clear
Captain 6-4 there was silence Jo 6-4 do
you copy I'll clear doc sorry my mic was
muted on Route and ready to do this
thing Dr har sighed in relief and slowly
reclined in his chair watching the pods
move closer to the large openings on SCP
169 side one by one the robotic arms
used underwater torches to drill into
the thick rock-like exoskeleton of the
creature screwing in complex
million-dollar equipment that was both
waterproof and could withstand the
immense pressure at such a depth under
the ocean as the minutes turned to hours
Dr heart couldn't help but feel anxiety
for the safety of his crew and the
success of the mission but before long
the pods began to return one by one to
the mothercraft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was
just 6-1 whose robotic arm was in the
process of rotating a large industrial
siiz screw ja 6-1 had all but finished
when suddenly a low Rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submersive Dr Hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now J 6 ST1 wrapped in
deep focus on his task replied I'm just
about finished just packing up my tool
belt leave it return to the ship now
that's an order Jesus what's wrong it's
not like this is the end of the world
said the agent chuckling over his radio
an earpiercing echo sent shock waves
through the depths of the ocean around
the submersible the waves rumbled with
the sound of SCP 169 voice similar to
the sound of a large whale but Amplified
by a million the sound sent all the crew
members falling to the floor as the ship
experienced severe damage from the burst
of pressure slightly cracking the glass
viewport and sending smoke flooding into
the small Bridge of the ship gas masks
shouted Dr Hart as they all down
breathing apparatus SCP 169 is waking up
begin activation of the chemical
emission machines we need to sedate it
now the Leviathan is waking up we need
to stop it shouted Dr Hart just then he
looked back and noticed Z 6 d1's Pod was
gone J 6-1 what's your position just 6-1
where are you sir Sona has him drifting
off deeper into the ocean behind us he
must have gotten knocked off SCP 169 by
the Shark Wave but Dr Hart wouldn't have
it he didn't want any more blood on his
hands reverse thrusters turn us around
and get to him we're not losing anyone
but the breach in the hull it or home
that's what the ruins are for the
outside of the submersible began to Glow
a slight blue as the ship system started
to come back online to full capacity and
alarm system started to turn off and
Report normal pressure readings before
long the Nemo 1 had caught up to ja 61's
pod and retrieved the agent who had been
knocked unconscious by the shock wave
once the agent was back on the main ship
the doctor turned his attention back to
the monitors making sure the
installations they drilled into the
creature were functional slowly the
machines came online to full power and
the speed at which SCP 169 had been
moving began to slow ever so slightly
the team all watched the viewport in
silence as a steady stream of anesthetic
gas was pumped into the respiratory
system of the gigantic living myth in
front of them after a few moments of
waiting the doctor spoke I think it
worked he said with a smile the crew
erupted in cheers as they radioed
control back up on land that the mission
had been a success the message quickly
reached the 05 Council where a red alert
status was de-escalated and the 05
members withdrew from their plan of
leaving the current Earth for that of an
alternate universe the whole crew began
to sing and celebrate the prevention of
of the end of the world as Dr Hart
simply stood in front of the massive
viewport watching the mountainous
specimen slowly grow smaller in the
distance as the submersible began
ascending back to the world above ja 6-1
came over to congratulate him patting
him on the back we did it he said loosen
up the doctor managed to laugh along in
acknowledgement that we did he said in
relief that we did the two watched the
deep blue ocean in silence taking in the
vastness of the sea perhaps this would
not be the end of it but that day they
had done what the SCP Foundation did
best kick that apocalyptic can a few
miles down the road and sometimes in the
face of the terrifying and the infinite
that's really the best you can do you're
right in the middle of one of the
hottest Summers on record the days are
filled with bright scorching sun and
Searing heat and you've been laying
around with your air conditioning on
full blast just to try and cool yourself
off sadly it's not really working and
the heat is becoming way too much but
then you remember there's this married
couple that lives near you with no kids
and they happen to have a swimming pool
in their yard normally they keep to
themselves they'd never let you use
their pool but they've gone out of town
for a few days besides the heat is
killing you you're sure that the
neighbors would in mind if you just took
a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable Place similar
to most of the other houses in this
suburb of New Mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
2 m High cinder block wall that stands
around the back Garden as you drop to
your feet sweaty and panting from the
unrelenting summer heat you see it the
pool your salvation water never looks so
appealing immediately you step Barefoot
across the Sun Scorch tiles and sit on
the edge legs in the water it's cool and
refreshing perfect for a day as hot as
today you're changed in wearing your
swim trunks so it doesn't take long for
you to paddle out to the middle of the
pool letting that chilled clean water
cool you off as you're taking a dip you
notice the pool's Jets turning on
automatically it's a little bit odd but
you shrug it off that couple clearly
shelled out for a pool with a lot of
fancy bells and whistles but extra
features are aren't why you're here you
came because if you didn't then you
could have melted under all that
sunlight floating on the surface of the
water you relax with your arms behind
your head and close your eyes you don't
have time to realize that coming here
was a mistake instead you start to feel
relaxed so calm so tranquil you're one
with the water around you now it's
almost as though you could just
disappear so you do the police never
find any trace of you everyone else
simply writes it off as a random
disappearance there's not even so much
as a scrap of your body left in the pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was SCP 242 but don't worry you won't
be the last to make that costly mistake
what you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even theirs the
foundation procured it after the former
owner her retired out ofate landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after 3 days he was never
seen again now that house has only one
rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool SC DP 242
is at least to the untrained eye just an
average swimming pool a decent 9 m in
length 4 and 1/2 wide and it holds
around 53,000 L of sterile pool water
like we mentioned before it's even got
some Nifty features like water jets a
dual waterfall and a built-in vacuum
unit for sucking out any impurities and
we mean any impurities you see SCP 242
does go by another name the self
cleaning pool and while that might not
sound as for boing or dramatic as the
Scarlet king or the wendigo skull or the
horrifying nasty dude of ultimate
Badness okay we made that last one up we
can assure you that you don't ever want
to suffer the fate of taking a swim in
this pool there was an incident a while
ago recorded by the foundation through a
secret hidden camera the house where s
SCP 242 can be found had been left
vacant for a time and once again some
opportunist decided to take advantage of
the empty swimming pool this time it was
a couple a man and a woman in their
early 20s they climbed up the back wall
undressed and even stole a couple of
plastic inflatable rafts from a shed in
The house's backyard the water jets
switched themselves on startling the
girl but her boyfriend told her not to
worry the filter to clean the pool was
probably just on an automatic timer
right surely it wouldn't have been
anything to worry about after swimming
together for around 20 for minutes the
couple both agreed that the water felt
warm tingly even both of them climbed
onto their rafts eventually falling
asleep while still holding each other's
hands but almost half an hour after the
Jets had started something caused the
two rafts to burst the couple awoke
startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
and fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the Crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clear after 40 8 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation 2 weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had
eloped together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does SCP 242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SC p242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in SCP
242 it will be entirely Rewritten on a
molecular level the genetic and atomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water water that remains sterile even
when removed from the pool if you took a
cup of SCP 242s water and mixed
something like food coloring into it the
food coloring would not be absorbed into
the water instead staying as one
non-missile bubble this process doesn't
happen instantly though it can vary
depending on how contaminated or complex
the substance placed in SCP 242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about 7 minutes
a sample of stagnant pond water riddled
with various diseases and germs took 11
minutes longer what about 50,000 L of
colar well that one took a little longer
12 long days to be exact but was still
turned into pure sterile water and as
for a living human being maybe ask that
couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that SCP 242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of SCP 242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pool's design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill fad couple who took a swim in
SCP 242 the water jets and waterfall
features switched themselves on
automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
nonwater substance is placed into SCP
242 the same goes for the pool vacuum
which apparently cannot be jammed or
malfunction even when the bottom of the
pool is a wash with viscous liquids like
that colar the vacuum will continue to
operate as normal scrubbing away at the
floor of SCP 242 the one part of the
self-cleaning pool that doesn't work as
you would expect is the water filtration
system there is never any water being
cycled into the pool nor out of it as a
matter of fact the pipes connecting to
the filtration system have all been
removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there animals
objects people just swimming around you
perhaps if they could still think they'd
scream and shout and tell you to get
away to run while you still can but the
second your skin touches the water
you're destined to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pool that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps some microscopic flesh devouring
microbe or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of SCP 242 it would
still break down structures on a
molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of CP 242s water one test
involves submerging two d-class test
subjects each wearing an atmospheric
dive suit into SCP 242 the goal was to
determine if it was safe to consume the
water from SCP 242 while both inside and
outside of the pool test subject a was
lowered into the water and instructed to
drink from a metal straw by their mouth
the eyepieces of their goggles were
blacked out so they couldn't see what
they were drinking from subject B filled
a barrel with the same water water from
SCP 242 and then was made to put on an
atmospheric dive suit but instructed to
stay out of the pool test subject a was
told to drink directly from the pool
remarking that the water was warm and
had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste but was otherwise normal then
test subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel apparently it was
cool and tasted of well nothing just
like water usually does after a moment
more of drink subject a began and
belching finding that they had
uncontrollable gas the water had begun
to feel warmer stinging the subject's
mouth while for subject B the water from
the barrel stayed cool and refreshing
the foundation doctors overseeing the
experiment instructed test subject a to
keep drinking which they did until it
felt even hotter to The Taste one of the
DCL class's fillings even fell out and
eventually the structural Integrity of
subject A's dive suit failed presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP 242
after a few muffled screams and gurgling
noises test subject a wasn't heard from
again and we can all probably guess why
as for subject B they kept drinking from
the barrel suffering no adverse effects
even after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no
traces of abnormality the water from SCP
242 left in the barrel evaporated as
normal leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be your last you're
on a road trip the kind that stretches
over days on end and you need to make
multiple stops along the way to refuel
the car and yourself the last time you
remember stopping to get more gas and a
bite to eat was back in Wyoming and now
you're in the heart of Montana
thankfully like an oasis in the desert
you see the town of clear water off in
the distance it's a vibrant welcoming
little place a perfect slice of classic
small town Americana you took a similar
trip last year and vaguely remember
stopping at Clear Water that time too
and you're glad to be back in particular
you remember the old Prairie Diner a
folksy little place with the most
delicious Huckleberry pie you ever
tasted perhaps it's about time for you
to give it another treat try you fill up
your tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from the weight staff to the cashier to
the cooks have all been replaced you try
your best not to think about it after
all businesses are allowed to replace
their staff but the longer you sit in
the diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not going crazy when the waiter passes
by you compliment the food and mention
you ate here last year too you asked the
unfamiliar waiter if they had worked
here back then they confirm that yes
they've always worked here and so has
everybody else the diner is a family
business you leave town not too long
after that feeling vaguely unsettled and
as a voice on the radio warns about the
incoming rain you tell yourself that you
never want to return to the town of
Clear Water Montana as you leave the
memory of the Town seems to fade from
your mind in real time but little do you
know the people of clear water will
never be able to leave ever it's because
something horrifying will happen in
Clear Water every single year and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as
SCP
3300 this annual anomalous event is
clear water's own local curse always
occurring around mid June while many of
the mechanics of this event then still
elude the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
SCP 3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a malstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in Clear Water remains
in Clear Water and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send Personnel
or equipment into clear water during SCP
3300 one of two things has happened in
the more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter clear water have
simply appeared on the other side of the
city limits in the less positive
instances personnel and Equipment have
been lost for ever within there is no
stopping or even understanding SCP 3300
according to Foundation records clear
water has been around at least as long
as the foundation itself perhaps even
longer clear water has been able to
undergo its yearly nightmare without
intrusion due to a unique Cognito
hazardous effect which creates a kind of
mental block around memories of the town
for Outsiders you won't forget clear
water per se but you will find it
increasingly hard to focus on like
something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye there is no
saving the people of clear water the
horror will play out again and again and
again the foundation has no firsthand
knowledge of what happens in Clear Water
during those horrifying 18 days but one
account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility during an Excursion into
Clear Water the foundation managed to
collect a diary belonging to a woman
named Margaret Lane to the best of our
knowledge Margaret Lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
Clear Water during SCP 3300 is far worse
than we ever imagined Margaret first
started her diary not long before scp3
300's 1995 iteration began she was in
the middle of a tumultuous time in her
life freshly clean from alcohol and drug
addiction forced to live with her
antagonistic mother and having peculiar
and distressing dreams in the first
Dream Margaret recorded she was someone
else a woman living in a small Hut
perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedan her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended Margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was coming it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
SCP 3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of the place to Margaret life
carried on she continued to stay clean
resisting the offers of her old dealer
though her relationship with her mother
remained Frosty the rain started to get
worse as voices on the radio insisted
that conditions would continue to become
more severe over the next few days they
tried their best to maintain normality
Margaret invited some friends Jared Sam
Mike and Isabelle to come over and play
D and D at her place that was when all
hell broke loose while the group role
played there was a furious banging at
the door like whoever was knocking was
trying to bash the door down when
Margaret's mom opened the door to
investigate the commotion she saw that
an entire family was standing there a
father a mother and two young children
the father immediately began furiously
asking why all these strangers were in
his house when Margaret's mother tried
to tell him that this wasn't his house
he became increasingly agitated and
walked straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
strength Margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty Splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunken in but there
was no blood just dripping water the
father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest and began beating Margaret's
mother to death with it all while
repeating my house again and again while
his wife and children watched with broad
Sunny Smiles in the rain somehow
Margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to Jared's van with the rest of the
group and hight tail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted Jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of clear water a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van and now there
were only four of them left they kept
driving afraid grieving hungry and tired
and Margaret took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
Cascade of hot steam after that Margaret
and the others left the vehicle and
refused to get back inside nothing was
making sense it was like something out
of a nightmare as they walked the rain
hammered down upon them they couldn't
have been walking for more than a mile
when they crashed into something it was
a sign welcome to clearw it was like
that the town itself had drawn them back
Mike refused to return to the town of
his own free will and began walking in
the other direction moments later he was
walking back towards them in silence
though he never intended to SCP 3300 had
distorted his path and brought him back
it was clear that Mike was shaken to the
core by the experience but they had to
press on they would head to the grocery
store for food and then to a sporting
good store where they could hopefully
grab some guns to fight the violent
altered people who'd somehow appeared
with the rain but things didn't go to
plan or what little plan there even was
Mike shot himself on the first night at
Dirk Sporting Goods leaving only
Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive perhaps
one of the most terrifying details of
Mike's death was the fact he didn't even
bleed instead the gaping exit wound in
the back of his head was just full of
water water was all that seemed to be
left of them Sam seemingly driven to the
Edge by the sight of Mike's death
grabbed a hunting knife to perform an
experiment she'd cut into her own skin
and was horrified to see only water
dripping out they'd all been changed and
they didn't know why that's when the
survivors noticed something else there
were people standing outside in the rain
hundreds of them not a single one they
could recognize all new people waiting
Sam said only one word outside before
walking out of the hunting goods store
and disappearing into the crowd and the
rain never to be seen Again Margaret
mused that perhaps in the end she had
the right idea to be taken killed erased
or change would be inevitable in the
final entry in Margaret's diary dreams
blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror she realizes
in her final moments that there is no
way out there is no Escape there is only
water water is eternal the rain pain is
eternal all will be changed and given
the fact that no trace of Margaret was
ever found save for her diary all her
fears turned out to be right she was
taken and replaced by SCP 3300 just as
will inevitably happen to all the
current citizens of clear water the next
time as CP 3300 rolls around it will be
as inevitable and as indifferent to
those it affects as tomorrow's sunrise
you cannot change the rain but believe
us in clearw Montana the rain can change
you the year is
1985 16th of February a pair of
researchers aboard a model sm03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean hours ago
they were somewhere just off the coast
of France surrounded by Blue Sky the
smell of the Sea and the warm embrace of
the Sun but now only cold Darkness
surrounds them the depth of the oceans
so vast and overwhelming even light
could not Escape its grasp the 2oman
team are members of MTF gamma 6 also
known as the Deep feeders a special task
force that specializes in the
investigation and tracking of deep sea
or Oceanic anomalies their mission to
locate and investigate the wreckage of a
World War II German warship known as the
Bismark thought by the general public to
have gone down in the naval battle with
the British in 1941 but the story the
public doesn't know is the real reason
the pair of foundation members were
tasked with locating the ship's wreckage
site unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated
radio Transmissions recorded by the
gamma 6 Duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismar
designated SCP
427 the bismar lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gam6 member
Charles Miller comments even after the
better part of 5 decades this ship is
still in pristine condition there is no
water damage anywhere that I can see
even stranger no ocean sediment has
accumulated on the ho of the ship
whatsoever prompted to investigate
closer agent Victor Miller begins
operation of the crews model rv1 Marine
probe an unmanned robotic exploratory
drone that allows the researchers to
explore the interior of the ship's
wreckage what they found unnerved them
or better said what they didn't find
just as the outside of the vessel
appeared free of any corrosion or wear
the interior of the ship was just as
Immaculate the hallways were clean the
walls adorned freshly painted signs in
still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto command centers
still help held no sign of
disintegration it was as if the ship had
just come off the assembly line but
strangest of all was the lack of
skeletal remains at the time it was sunk
the original crew of the bismar boasted
a minimum of 2,000 men where were the
bodies continuing the mission the
researchers piloted their unmanned drone
down the Eerie winding corridors along
several of the inner corridors of the
submerged wreckage of SCP
4217 the crew find large thick walls of
what appear to be made out of a
rubberlike substance soon they find that
the large veinlike growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle likee growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the sea Flor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurried to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and Evacuate the site but
it's too late
a booming thud shakes the underwater
craft as a large Shadow covers the glass
window of the submersible alarm systems
go off as cracks start to appear in the
glass surface the pair attempt to Pilot
The Vessel up towards the surface but
they are halted by a strong force
pulling them downward just as the cracks
start to spread across the surface of
the glass A giant shadow looms over the
submersible what is that screams and the
sound of shattering glass can be heard
on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery
deps since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of SCP 427
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far north as
the Greenland sea given its ker
containment classification containment
of SCP 4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
an agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
SCP 4217 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained SCP 4217
enters a passive State and res submerges
SCP 4217 is divided into two parts SCP
4217 daa is the bismar itself a Nazi era
warship outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry SCP 4217 DB refers to the
anomalous seapod organism embedded
inside the hull of the ship SCP 421 17-b
has two large rectangular pupils inside
of octopod eyes that protrude from the
base of the ship as well as 12 100 to
200 M long tendril-like muscular
appendages that extend outward from an
opening in the stern of the vessel SCP
4217 is deemed to be classification risk
class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 km radius confusing anything within
range and increasing the likelihood of
Friendly Fire among enemy combatants SCP
4217 D's Hull seems to have the ability
of inorganic regeneration as damage
incurred from enemy vessels seems to
immaculately repair over time
researchers have observed what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of SCP
4217 Hall It is believed these symbols
were part of the original ship's design
to bolster the vessel's defense
Integrity though not immediately visible
when the vessel is taking fire the
symbols appear to Glow in proportion to
the amount of damage being mitigated
among its offensive capabilities apart
from the standard armaments of a World
War II era warship SCP 4217 daa also has
specialized Munitions of an
unidentifiable gas compound that is
reported to have mutagenic properties
individuals that have been exposed to
the gas compound undergo rapid
spontaneous metamorphosis at a molecular
level growing an array of evolutionary
attributes which include the
accumulation of reptile-like scales or
Aven feathers in place of skin the
increase or decrease of the number of
Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory organs and in one reported case
an event where multiple members of One
crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning or organism the
more study into this particular incident
is needed SCP 4217 also has the ability
of subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be generated by the ejection
of water from SCP 4217 DB's body cavity
and reaches a top speed of approximately
30 knots SCP 4217 undergo cycles of
passive behavior that is periodically
interrupted by moments of hostility
toward civilian craft particularly
resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels It is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original Mission of the
bismar operation ryanbang during World
War II the German luwa was besieging
London in a series of nightly Air Raids
that would be colloquially known as The
Blitz it was the Grand intention of the
Third Reich to cut off supplies to the
British to limit their resistance to the
Nazi war machine however what pestered
the Nazis most and hint hindered this
effort was the consistent American
Support provided by the US government in
the form of food and supplies delivered
to the British via Atlantic trade routes
by cargo ship the German bismar and her
sister ship the turits were created for
the very goal of stopping these
transports of cargo to the United
Kingdom as well as sinking as many
Allied vessels as possible the year is
1937 in a top secret effort to make
preparations for an approaching War
Adolf Hitler turns to his most trusted
expert on the supernatural Chief SS
officer Heinrich himler among other
projects himler ordered the anner
obscura cor a German organization tasked
with the procurement and investigation
of Otherworldly or otherwise
unexplainable phenomenon to begin the
creation of two ships the bismar and the
turits the former named after the Iron
Chancellor ovon bismar who in 1890
unified the German people these vessels
were to be created using recently
uncovered technological Oddities the
obscur Cor had found in their studies of
the occult sources of information about
the exact creation of SCP 4217 are
highly expunged from the record but bits
and pieces did survive among what little
the foundation was able to collect and
in the records of the USSR after their
occupation of Eastern Germany following
the fall of the Nazi regime during the
second world war the earliest mention of
SCP 427's conception dates back to early
1937 when a top secret shipment of
unknown materials labeled component of
thical constructs is intercepted by a
foundation agent working under cover in
a German shipment Center outside of
Hamburg the foundation agent Marcus stob
is instructed to maintain surveillance
on the shipment in 1939 upon near
completion of the soon to be christened
bismar a second shipment labeled with
the Insignia of the obscura cor is
intercepted by the foundation agent only
this shipment appears unlike any other
reports of the massive shipping
container holding Machinery capable of a
I life support indicate organic living
cargo though the foundation agent was
unable to identify the exact nature of
the contents of the shipment STW
reported hearing sounds emanating from
the cargo hold sounds similar to that of
a heartbeat just a year later the bismar
is seen making its first Naval trial run
when it experiences a massive electrical
discharge just offshore shutting the
vessel down momentarily until power was
restored shortly after reports show
luminescent symbols briefly visible on
the hull of the ship theological symbols
for the Layman are symbols that embodied
the study of Miracles because of this it
was apparent to the foundation that some
occult anomaly was responsible for the
strange characteristics of the German
vessel and an order for termination was
reached by the5 Council the hunt for SCP
4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under orders
of neutralization of SCP 4217 all active
Foundation agents presiding in Germany
were ordered to converge on the side of
the bismar to stop the completion of the
vessel but when the time came for the
operation every single one of the
foundation agents vanished no records of
what happened were ever found no
clothing notes not even a trace of their
existence was left behind the mission
was deemed a failure and subsequent
attempts to neutralize SCP 4217 became
far more difficult after the bismar
received a full crew of seamen the fully
manned and well equipped SCP 4217 became
a menace to both military and civilian
Craft on the high seas of the Atlantic
at times appearing without warning
seemingly out of thin air SCP 4217
psionic field obscured it from the new
technological advancements in enemy
radar systems the US government had in
development the ship became a shadow on
the Atlantic a subject of ghost stories
for anyone daring to assist the British
government with the war effort
furthermore SCP 4217 did not seem to be
content with the surrender of enemy
vessels
captured enemy ships were gassed turning
the men into manufactured beasts and
then sinking the enemy vessels to the
depths of the ocean even submarines were
no match on one report describing an
attempt to elude The Vessel by diving
below the surface only to be entangled
by enormous squid-like appendages that
dragged the craft back up to the surface
before crushing it in its grasp fearing
the safety of the public the 05 Council
decided they could not stand by and let
more innocent lives be taken they voted
to supersede the foundation's policy on
absolute secrecy to notify the British
government of the danger SCP 4217 pose
to Maritime civilians with cooperation
from the British royal Navy Foundation
Representatives joined the crew of HMS
hood and HMS Prince of Wales to track
reports of the bismar being cited off
the coast of Scandinavia in what history
books would come to know as the Battle
of Denmark Straight HMS hood and HMS
Prince of Wales engaged SCP 4217 and a
secondary German warship known as the
prince Yen confused by the ship's
psionic field the British naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismar and engage in Friendly Fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on SCP
4217 the attack proves futile as after
the Embers and smoke of Munitions fire
wear off the sides of the Bismark Hull
appear to vibrate with glowing energy
mangled metal begins to straighten back
into perfect frame breaches and armor
begin to heal before the soldiers very
eyes and all that is left as evidence
the ship had ever taken fire is a cloud
of steam emanating from the hull of SCP
4217 the water surrounding the vessel
began to boil as underwater tentacles
Lurch out and capture the HMS Hood
dragging Her Majesty's ship forward the
men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from SCP 4217 guns hit the
ship severing lines and damaging rail
guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen in mere
minutes the majority of the crew are
engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsions their bodies
undergoing rapid involuntary mutagenesis
including the growth of Limbs the
development of fur feathers and scales
in one report it was said that multiple
victims even fuse together to create one
single horrifying entity those exposed
to the gashes compound were designated
SCP
42171 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of SCP 421 17-1
overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the HMS Hood experienced is
forever intuned in the watery grave of
the British vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of Munitions fire from the
combined might of the German Fleet some
men attempting to jump jump overboard
and swim to safety are dragged down by
their legs by the mutated instances of
SCP 4217 and pulled under lungs filling
with seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
of HMS Prince of Wales decides to
retreat in the days that followed at the
bequest of foundation members the
British royal Navy launches a fullscale
Armada to hunt down and neutralize the
bismar the SCP 4217 sustained little
damage in the previous encounter the
ship began leaking a black oil-like
substance thought by SCP researchers to
be an organic waste product of SCP 4217
DB the Allied Naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of France
where under the lead of HMS King George
V British warships surround the German
vessel and opened fire this time they
were ready with approval from the 05
Council Foundation members provide the
British forces with enhanced Munitions
and Armament capable of over
overwhelming SCP 4217 theological
defenses on the eve of battle it appears
to the Allied Forces that the psionic
field generated by SCP 4217 is too great
as the naval company find it difficult
to land targeted assaults on the German
vessel after losing several smaller
vessels to the Colossal appendages of
SCP
4217 Foundation members on board
authorized the use of a redacted SCP it
is brought in to deactivate SCP 4217
psionic field the tide of The Battle
Turns and after a fierce battle SCP 4217
becomes immobile and unable to return
fire Relentless the British continued
their bombardment until the artillery
Munitions on the ship explode into a
giant Fireball flooding the ship's
compartments with the noxious fumes of
the mutagenic compound its crew members
either jump overboard or are engulfed in
the cloud of gas the British vessels
capture any survivors and watch as SCP
4217 slowly sinks below the waves down
to the depths of the ocean where it
would lay dormant for the next 48 years
SCP 4217 121 surviving crew members were
captured and interrogated most of the
low-ranking German soldiers were
released to British custody 109 of them
having their memory wiped by Foundation
staff 12 remaining members of the crew
were sent to site 23 for further
detention and advanced interrogation and
74 of the instances of SCP 4217 1 the
mutated subjects were recovered and sent
to site 23 for further observation it
was thought that on that day s SCP 4217
was deemed neutralized and no longer a
matter of priority the Bismark sunk into
memory and myth it was only until the
recent Resurgence of SCP 4217 that the
foundation saw the need to collect as
much information on the organism
inhabiting as CP 4217 is possible
decades old manuscripts and ledgers were
pulled from hundreds of viable sources
from the intelligence then gathered
Foundation members have come to the
hypothesis that the entity powering the
vessel known as the bismar has what is
believed to be extraplanetary origin
World War II era documents uncovered
between Commander Carl reuter of the
German obscura cor and a doctor Hans
Meer indicated discovery of an organic
life form of Unknown Origin found in a
crashed aircraft near feldberg Park in
the black forest mountain range in in
Germany further correspondents with
obscura Corp members OT Schmidt and
Dietrich clner indicate that researchers
were conducting trials on the creatures
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range with a letter from dietr clner
suggesting the creature could be used as
a power source for an unspecified engine
further evidence of SCP 4217 DB's
extraplanetary origin can be found in a
1993 incident between Foundation naval
ship scps nimed and SCP
4217 this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as SCP 4217 DB on
July 22nd SCP 4217 had reappeared off
the coast of Britain anticipating
hostility scps nemed scps cesir and scps
partholon were instructed to close in on
SCP 427's location with orders to subdue
The Vessel if necessary however on this
occasion SCP 4217 did not appear to be
after any vessel it was simply drifting
along at Sea no propulsion engines
active noticing the change in SCP 427's
Behavior Captain Kurt Wagner decided to
withhold military engagement and
investigate SCP 427's Behavior sailing
within 200 M of the bismar the scps
nemid attempted radio contact with the
German vessel after repeated attempts at
communication the crew were met with
only silence and static chatter giving
up Captain Wagner puts down the radio
receiver when suddenly the sound of
music is heard playing over the speakers
of a ship the tune is the national
anthem of Nazi Germany the captain
hailes The Vessel again repeating his
attempts at communication do you do you
understand me at first only static can
be heard then came a reply you
ship the ominous voice could be heard
from the speakers the captain hesitated
for a moment members of The Crew looking
at each other with apprehension the
captain replied confirming themselves as
a ship and then asking if SCP 427 knew
what it was and where it came from what
followed was the crew of the scps nemed
receiving a video feed from SCP
4217 featuring a high volume of images
in Rapid succession among them were
images of German cities Adolf Hitler's
telecast of the 1936 Olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and in
increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or SCP 2399 as
Foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and SCP 2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter SCP
427's responses become more erratic and
agitated as it repeats the words storm
cloud and red the markings on its hole
beginning to light up and the underwater
Shadows of its tentacles beginning to
create whirlpools of displacement under
the bow of the ship a shrill shrieking
begins to flood out of the speakers
followed by a high piercing high-pitched
beeping sound that overloads the
communication equipment causing Sparks
to fly as crew members cover their ears
and hide under control panels the scps
nemid barely escapes as SCP 4217 becomes
hostile using its massive tendr like
appendages to assail the naval
combatants firing its Armament in all
directions after a fierce battle the
foundation Naval forces were able to
neutralize and subdue SCP
4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in
1989 any recent sightings of the Nazi
era Bismark are flagged as
misidentification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of SCP
4217 and protect the public from its
existence imagine this your researcher
with an interest in and an aptitude for
marine biology over the years your work
has taken you far and wide to the
furthest corners of the Earth oceans
you've observed countless species of sea
life from fish and Crustaceans to whales
and sharks predators and prey alike
during one of your travels you find
yourself off the coast of South Africa
monitoring the local population of sea
creatures looking out across the water
you see a large dark shape moving below
the surface there is a shadow streaking
its way towards Your Vessel Dark As
night speeding Like a Torpedo you rush
across the deck leaning over the port
side as the shape swims Beneath Your
Boat you're certain you know what it was
after all your years studying the world
beneath the waves you know a whale shark
when you see one the largest known
species of fish still in existence the
whale shark is a filter feeder
consisting on a diet of Plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms a whale
shark poses absolutely no threat to
humans or rather any whale shark other
than this one would impose a threat but
how could you know that scanning the
water you strain your eyes trying to
spot what you assumed was an ordinary
whale shark swimming below but there is
nothing no sign of it anywhere sighing
you think you might have missed your
chance to see one in the wild perhaps it
changed Direction instead of swimming
under the boat you tell yourself the
ship turns and starts making its way
back towards the small Harbor leaving
you blissfully unaware that there's an
extra passenger on board as you
disembark you notice something on the
side of the boat and blazoned on the
whole is a motif of a familiar shape a
whale shark depicted entirely in painted
dots you stare at it for a moment
intrigued by the pattern it reminds you
of a piece you once saw an Aboriginal
Australian style of dot art you're a
little taken aback by The Coincidence
having briefly spotted a whale shark
while out at Sea earlier blissfully
unaware that this painting marks your
first encounter with SCP
1449 known more colloquially as as the
Dreamtime whale shark in fact you're so
amused by seeing the whale shark earlier
only to find one painted here on the
boat that it distracts you you don't
realize that the whale shark painting
hadn't been on the side of the boat when
you'd shipped out instead you pay the
crew and thank the captain for letting
you hire The Vessel for your research
and then head off by the time you make
it back to the nearby town and settle
down in after a long day on the water
the dotted painting of the whale shark
has already slipped from your
mind but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark you're about to
find out that your encounter with the
Dreamtime whale shark is only just
beginning you've never been a heavy
sleeper and rarely remember your dreams
any that you might have seem to pass out
of your head the moment you wake up or
are too faint for you to acknowledge
while you're sleeping but tonight is
different tonight you're dreaming
vividly in this dream water surrounds
you like it has your whole career but
this time you're underneath the surface
a drift in an empty ocean nothing around
you but endless blank sea you feel
something in your hand something smooth
and moving gently like organic matter
something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark and
somehow as is often the way with dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that
day the one that swam up to your boat
and ended up sticking on the side of it
as a art painting SCP 1449 has this
latent ability while it normally appears
as a flat two-dimensional piece of
Aboriginal Australian dot art the
Dreamtime whale shark can shift whenever
it is underwater it still appears as a
collection of painted dots in this
unmistakable shape of a whale shark but
in an aquatic environment it becomes
three-dimensional and that's what you'd
seen swimming towards the boat not just
a whale shark but SCP
1449 Within in your dream you release
the Dreamtime whale shark's tail and
begin to float
upwards breaking the surface of the
water you breathe lungfuls of fresh air
the first thing you see is land and it's
close by close enough for you to swim to
shore paddling through the water you
reach an island one in a chain of small
land masses tiny continents in a shallow
unfamiliar ocean you look back to the
water but can find no sign of SCP 1449
the dream time will shark has brought
you here and left you on this island but
you can only speculate as to why there
must be a reason you insist to yourself
the Dreamscape around you it would seem
is either the creation of SCP 1449 or at
the very least a side effect of falling
asleep close by to where you saw the
Dreamtime whale shark in its painted
form whatever this place is there must
be some way to uncover an answer it
stands to reason you think that if you
can understand what's going on then
perhaps therein lies the key to escaping
this dream and waking up back in
reality the small island you find
yourself on and the others nearby are
inhabited by strange life forms as you
walk across the shore sand clinging to
your wet feet you approach what you
thought at a distance to be a group of
other people instead you see a group of
peculiar beings they are not quite human
but they are definitely close the closer
you walk you notice these Str humanoid
shapes huddle tighter together their
backs to you when you try to call out to
them asking where you are or how you
might return to reality they bustle away
the wind carries the sound of their
chatter towards you and you're certain
you hear them call you another one just
another traveler from afar what you
don't realize lost in this dream
environment is that there are others
like it pocket worlds like this one
similar but different currently being
experienced by any others asleep near SC
P
1449 as you Ponder what to do on the
beach the captain of the boat you hired
is on a different version of the same
island watching a herd of multiple 2,000
kilo platypi being shepherded by six
tattooed 3M tall humanoid figures
meanwhile his first mid is in another
version of this dream world learning how
to hunt under the tutelage of a man
called gray the rabbit Hunter each
version of SCP 1449 Dreamscape have
separate continuities to each other they
are differing copies of the same chain
of islands with the same inhabitants but
each visited by a different traveler
from AAR in their sleep much like a
lucid dream visitors to the Dreamtime
whale sharks worlds can interact with
them shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you El like
to make your way towards Higher Ground
to try to get a wider scope of your
surroundings fortunately there is a
towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like like dark serrated teeth
against the clear Horizon you begin your
dangerous track ascending your way up
these dead Jagged Hills you're still
unclear on how you got here or how to
escape but you will yourself to keep
climbing knowing there must be some way
to wake up from this bizarre dream
finally reaching level ground you take a
moment to catch your breath collecting
your thoughts before advancing any
further you turn gazing out over the
landscape spreading out below and all
around around you the island is small
enough you can see the shore where you
arrived and the ocean flanking this land
mass on all sides in this short moment
you appreciate the beauty of this
bizarre Dream World for the first time
the trees Sway in the gentle breeze
moving like the calm rolling of waves in
the water Beyond both glistening with
the warm light of the sun well it is
still true that you have no idea how or
why SCP 1449 brought you here or how to
leave you think to yourself that at
least this dream environment isn't a
hostile one not that you'd want to be
stranded there forever but there are
certainly far more unforgiving places
one can dream about a grim thought
suddenly Dawns on you how long have you
been here does time pass differently in
this world to the one you're still
asleep in a sound shakes your thoughts
back to your current here and now it was
a voice you're sure of it a voice
calling out but not to you traversing
the dead Jagged Hills you see a figure a
person from The Real World like you not
one of the local humanoids they don't
see you they're calling out to someone
in a ramshackle Hut cobbled together
from pieces of wood and other scraps on
the arm of the figure's dark
military-like uniform is a symbol and
you can just make out three distinct
letters s c p a wooden plank that
functioned as the door creaked open
revealing a second figure the man looks
disheveled his worn clothing patched
with scraps of leather and shark skin
making him looked as cobbled together as
his makeshift hun like he was an
extension of the small structure you
watch as the man talks to the agent
overhearing his words don't say anything
if you say anything I lose my mind you
can say anything and something horrible
happens the strange man warns talking
too quickly for the foundation agent to
reply you're a dreamer like me my name
is Nikolai I the ship seer of the dun
and the Brotherhood of seltic pnik
the man Nikolai he called himself seemed
distressed tripping over his words
disagreeing with himself until he starts
trailing off into swearing obscenities
I'm not Nikolai he shouts I am anent
anent John before stumbling and cursing
again I'm sorry I can't can't keep the
memory straight being this Lucid for
this long hurts the dreaming fills in
all the gaps things have always been
even as they are brought into being I've
been on this Cliff since the beginning
of time just like how this place has
always been here the dream was torn Away
by the deaths of gods Before Time began
but I watched it happen 5 years ago are
you
following I can barely tell the dream
and reality apart anymore my world has
always been the way it is and we made it
like that we hurt the dreaming the shark
that's how we see it we hurt it killed
it in our world and the dream time
poured out like it spilled blood and we
made this big scar here and and things
are wrong fish walk and ghosts haunt the
stones and women give birth to plastic
children and the leech Fields stretch
out forever in the Seas of human blood
and the center eats cocaine and caviar
out of pandas skull bows on the crushed
backs of opal mares in acres of broken
glass and it has always been like this
don't don't do it don't do it again you
are already racing back down to the dead
Jagged Hills the sight of the deranged
Nikolai burned into your mind a man
reduced to a babbling lunatic Cast Away
and left alone in this strange dream
skate that SCP 1449 brought you to but
Nikolai is more than that more than just
someone driven mad by his isolation he
is a grim prophecy of what will become
of you unless you can find a way to
leave the dream time will sharks World
already back on the beach you drop down
kneeling in the wet sand as the tide
washes over your knees the how or why of
SCP 1449 bringing you into this dream
isn't important all that matters to you
is avoiding ending up like Nikolai
whatever it takes you know one thing
above all else you need to wake up but
whether you actually ever will is
another question entirely you edge the
poolside chlorine stench air filling in
your nose the sound of splashing and
lifeguards whistling bouncing off the
indoor pool facility walls the water
ripples family and friends egging you to
cannonball in the pool almost beckoning
you to jump with its suggestive waves
yet there remains an underlying fear one
that brings your hands to your face and
causes your teeth to chatter even as the
pool clear as glass with chlorine hides
no secrets a monster some teeth nashing
Megalodon ascending from the depths of
Extinction Leviathan curling its Barbed
tail to strike its prey at any moment or
even some vast unknowable Force ancient
as Earth hardly comprehensible to human
Minds waiting dreaming to breach the
surface no matter what form this
gargantuan invisible monster takes you
know one Thing Once you jump in you will
not return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the bloop that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters Krakens and Loch Ness Monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto Shores
throughout America whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter
Escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water SCP 1128 in the vast
archives of a hidden site stuffed into a
drawer amongst uncountable Horrors like
it the SCP Foundation holds a
description of a vast unfathomable
horror that'll make you more suspicious
the next time you pass a pool lake or
even in a bathtub or puddle of water SCP
1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assigned to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those Moby Dicks of the deep including
the several thousand km long arthropod
SCP 169 and has even utilized such
predators in the past for their own
benefit like the lengthy Beast SCP 3000
scp1 28 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description Beyond
surface level details will fall under
the anomaly's effect the representation
you seen now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic prom the
foundation of course had to discover the
monster's effects in the first place the
chain of communication becomes foggy but
a tip from an unknown source alerted the
foundation to the monster's existence
and details regarding its manifest
station one man who had stumbled upon
the entity's full description started
developing acute theosophia the fear of
large bodies of water not Bodies In The
Water mind you the man refused to relax
on the beach or fly overseas claiming he
could see the monster's dark silhouette
lurking underwater ever scouting for him
this eventually extended to even closed
bodies of water like lakes ponds and
pools still insisting that the creature
swam under the surface trailing him
wherever he went his friends dismissed
him as crazy and he too believed he had
fallen under some hysteria he decided to
take a nice warm bath to soothe his mind
and ease his troubles he turned on the
faucet and let the tub fill up he put on
his best bathing suit ready to calm his
anxiety once and for all this had been
plaguing his mind for far too long and
he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the courage and with the anticipation to
just simply relax he took his first
confident step into the tub he paused
for a moment and breathed a sigh of
relief he picked up his other foot and
stepped fully into the bath Splash he
fell straight down right through the tub
waves and Bubbles blocked his vision his
arms flailed as he sunk deeper into an
abyss of water and fear this wasn't
supposed to happen he thought several
moments later while still in a full-on
panic the buoyancy of his body began to
slow his sinking the bubbles from his
underwater screams Rose above him and he
began to follow their Direction
scrambling back up to where he'd come
just as he made it back to the surface
of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in Terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stalked him through oceans and
pools staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to Blinded By fear he
neglected to spot a puddle in the middle
of the road he ran on he raised his foot
arched forward and landed straight into
the seemingly shallow water splash again
he found himself completely submerged
and drowning after a minute he did
emerge from the puddle but not in one
piece
knowledgeable of this incident the
foundation set about expunging any
traces of the monster's description from
the world physical and digital the
description had low distribution
according to the results of foundation
web crawlers but this hardly stopped the
foundation's Endeavor with Forum posts
deleted individuals located and
amnestied and cataloges trolled to
ensure the description did not
proliferate the foundation engaged in
what it does best questionably ethical
experiments for first they had an
anonymous d-class uninformed of the
creature's effect read the description
of the Beast while the pamphlet they
gave him confused him somewhat he didn't
feel particularly frightened by The
Entity and he confusedly put on the
diving suit the foundation testers
provided him as they connected him to a
cable and told him to enter a bathtub
the declass did as they instructed him
the d-class expressed initial confusion
at the tub's depth remarking that it
looks so tiny from the outside as the
declass continued to descend he analyzed
his surroundings realizing the nautical
reality that enveloped him he asked how
an ocean got stuffed into a bathtub but
the test organizer had no room for
miscellaneous talk he continued to
descend until he hit the Sandy Bottom
seaweed covering the ocean floor the
declass looked around tropical fish swam
in schools Coral covered the seabed and
to his right dropped an immense Cliff a
a sheer Edge the test organizer advised
the d-class to approach the cliff and he
begrudgingly complied as he struggled in
his diving suit he fell back and
screamed SCP 1128 The Aquatic horror
swam distantly gracefully even and paid
no attention to the d-class so fixated
upon he realized that the creature
matched the one he read on the pamphlet
and almost complained about this when he
saw a blue whale swimming alongside SCP
1128 compared to the monster the whale
looked like a guppy the whale glided in
front of SCP 1128 Jaws the monster
remained tranquil stared at its prey and
bit the whale in two with one cha its
teeth glistened in the water the test
operator requested the d-class to pull
back and as the cable began to draw him
toward where he came declass stared at
the creature swallowing the chunks of
whale whole the D class's eyes remained
fixated on the creature partially in
Fright partially in awe he wondered how
ocean trollers hadn't discovered such a
giant Beast yet with the world
effectively under 100% surveillance
something the d-class knew far too well
as a convict yet the d-class recognized
and if not comprehended partially
understood the ocean's vastness and
mystery the dark depths reveal no
inkling as to their contents and a
creature like a giant squid or the cican
can remain in height for centuries if
not Millennia it held him in wondrous
thought to consider the vastness of the
depths when SCP 1128 stopped and stared
at the d-class this feeling of Wonder
was quickly replaced with fear as the
creature approached the d-class pleaded
with the test operators for help as the
test operators accelerated the rate of
the cable returning the d-class took
short shallow breaths filling his body
with dangerous nitrogen as he ascended
further impairing his judgment he had
devolved into gibberish and screaming
when face to face the monster consumed
its prey the cable went slack and the
test operator pulled up only a broken
wire snap the water turning a cloudy red
the test operator knew that the
unprotected d-class had no chance at
survival against the monster but he
could potentially arm and shield them he
had another similarly ignorant d-class
once again dress in a scuba suit and
enter the tub however the test operator
placed the d-class within a shark cage
Alla the movie Jaws and lowered the cage
in with another cable and winch system
while Unsure how this would Faire with
SCP 1128 the test operator remained
hopeful that the d-class could survive
and recount his story unfortunately as
the cage lowered into the tub the test
operator received no response from the
d-class until the line spontaneously
tightened snapped and loosened hoping to
find the DCL class's Remains the test
operator only found shredded pieces of
metal torn and twisted like taffy the
test operator decided that he could
utilize the foundation's Arsenal to his
advantage and use an anomalously
toughened shark cage in his testing
perhaps using an anomaly like the
Clockwork machine SC SCP 914 he gained
approval from his high-ups to undergo
this procedure and after some testing
behind a shining strong as titanium
shark cage which he placed another
d-class within hoping for a success with
the monster however proved proved
unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous test only
without any sort of metallic remains
while bitter that the monster had won
again he wondered where the cage had
landed meanwhile Foundation forces
labored tirelessly to find SC scp1 28's
location hoping to avoid any civilian
contact with the creature luckily a GPS
signal established itself upon the most
recent d-class test with the tracking
device on the d-class signifying the
monster's General location
the foundation had redacted the location
of the monster perhaps in a vain attempt
to hide a very near threat from
potential readers the foundation set up
a team of only the most talented boers
in its forces mobile Containment Force
Kappa 12 C Devils upon arriving at the
location the sea Devils discovered the
previously enhanced shark cage
completely undamaged however closer
inspection revealed traces of human DNA
on the bars though the foundation could
not confirm whether the DNA belonged to
the previously sent d-class the test
operator while glad his shark cage
survived the monster's attack still
found himself dissatisfied with the
overall results of the test he knew he
needed to quell this creature's impact
before a large population viewed it or
knew of it the horrible Beast had evaded
all attempts at peaceful interaction
perhaps with a Madness not unlike
Captain Ahab yearning for the death of
his white whale the test operator armed
a d-class with a specialized weapon
designed to deal with aquatic threats
promptly this weapon potentially another
of the foundation's precious Arsenal
could potentially harm if not kill the
creature while he knew the foundation's
mission statement forbade unnecessary
destruction the test operator felt it
may turn necessary if matters turn any
worse thus he sent his armed declass
through the tub once more ready to
engage the beast in combat the attempt
as one may expect did not last long the
d-class upon spotting the creature aimed
his weapon at the monster and attacked
it but rather than drive the creature
away it only turned intently upon the
d-class as if it desired a fight the
d-class barely managed to scrape SCP
1128 before the creature devoured the
d-class leaving the test operator once
again empty-handed defeated and without
any more resources to deal with the
Beast the test operator ceased his
attempts at vesting the creature and
followed the foundation's more cautious
approach expunging any publicly found
descriptions of SCP 1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion Zone as maintained
by the Sea Devils while the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what would transpire a
d-class Afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required event
however the d-class needed to interact
with some kind of water drinking water
in a choice between a little water
exposure or certain death the d-class
felt inclined to choose the former he
filled his cup with water and for fun
placed his finger into the cup dropping
it into the water SC SCP 1128 unseen
from the outside violently pulled the
declass through the cup into its watery
domain the d-class had not a chance to
scream this alarmed containment staff
now cognizant that even the tiniest
specks of water could transport an
Afflicted person into SCP 1128 ocean
territory this proved particularly
strenuous when a new report of a
potential scp-1128 manifestation arose
an old woman isolated with her cats and
knitting supplies found an article
online with a description of the monster
frightened and disgusted by what she
read she closed the article and
continued on with her monotonous life
such a life would take a turn for the
worst however when she too developed
that all-encompassing water-based fear
her apartment overlooked an outdoor pool
and one day looking outside she swore
she could see that same dark silhouette
as the man did lurking in the water
among kids and parents playing she
swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seam shut allowing no light to
peek through eventually this paranoia
affected her hygiene neglecting showers
and baths for fear of the creature's
wrath she she swore she could see the
silhouette in any individual droplet of
water her skin began to flake as she
avoided water as much as humanly
possible cracks developing on her arms
legs and face inflaming into rashes and
itches her scratching further increased
the flaking she even eliminated water
from her diet sealing the faucets with
duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice she threw out her cat's
water bowls dehydrating them they
pleaded with her a continued to devolve
avoiding any contact with the outside
world even as it attempted to contact
her eventually a concerned neighbor
contacted the local police concerning
the situation and the case caught the
foundation's radar recognizing the
symptoms of a potential SCP 1128
infection a mobile task force disguised
themselves as civilians to enter the
apartment building and potentially
interfere with the woman's condition
they entered the complex climbing up the
stairs with barraging equipment for
forced entry tree as would prove
necessary to use to enter the woman's
apartment she had nailed the door shut
with wood and sealed the cracks along
the sides with plaster in an attempt to
keep out any water vapor she had
similarly blocked the window with wood
planks a horrid miasma of dead skin and
citrus filled the apartment the old
woman soaking it in ever avoiding the
dreaded monster the foundation task
force attempted peaceful entry knocking
on the door and asking if anyone lived
in the apartment the woman could could
speak if she wanted to her throat had
dried to near silence save a croak
suddenly the task force and the woman
heard a rumbling noise outside thunder
rain the woman panicked and yelled don't
come in here in a froggy voice the task
force eventually decided they needed to
use their equipment and entered via
barrage the door collapsed in an
immediate densed air clogged the task
Force's sight blinding and choking them
the woman shrieked and backed against
the window inadvertently the task force
insisted they were here to help the
woman but she simply heaved heavily
saying something unintelligible in that
dry cracking voice the rain began
pounding on the window patter patter
patter as the task force attempted to
gain hold of the woman she resisted
their movements moving around the room
while the task force intentionally
avoided violent confrontation the rain
grew in its intensity as the woman
continued running around her apartment
tripping over her starved cats
eventually she fell back onto the window
at which the boards blocking it fell
onto the floor exposing the pouring rain
fully she screamed as she saw the
silhouette of the monster staring at her
in every individual raindrop one drop
landed on her skin and she violently
vanished pulled into a minuscule Speck
of water the task force collapsed from
exhaustion perhaps dreading their
inevitable amnestic treatment following
exposure with an SC SCP 1128 afflect yet
they couldn't help but wonder what the
old woman saw in a single Speck of water
that could cause that degree of fear and
paranoia the kind of fear only caused by
entire oceans condensed into a single
droplet besides the monster what else
did she see in those multitude of
droplets the fish that populated the sea
the whale carcasses left behind by SCP
1128 the sea Devils viewed from Below
Drifting On The Water unsuspecting just
as one may view a grain of sand and see
the Sahara she too saw that raindrop and
viewed an ocean entire along with
whatever malevolent creatures inhabit it
one may have more Sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
inhabits that body of water but that the
body belongs to a cycle much larger than
itself larger than any sea or ocean and
the only thing that can Traverse that
cycle is a monster a creature like SCP
1128 the task force went back to their
local site to report what happened
during the incident like so many
incidents the foundation deals with the
sum total of those that risk their lives
for the greater good is a couple memory
erasing syringes and another update to
documentation a description of SCP 1128
remains in the stuffy Locker lurking in
weight among other horrifying stories in
the SCP databases Sea Of Terror just
like that test operator that attempted
to best the monster could the
foundation's attempts ever surmount the
possibility of another person being
Afflicted could they conquer the sea in
a member of that task Force's dreams
they perceive a dark blue ocean and the
distant black shadow that resides within
and from this ocean they can view the
bathtubs sinks pools PS bottles cups of
water and Rain droplets of the world
seen from below although they know not
what as c128 looks like they too
experience the fear it summons among
those that do the paranoia the fear
although it may not manifest directly in
people's lives it can always be observed
stalking waiting lurking under a murky
surface watching with hidden eyes
hello SCP Foundation Personnel welcome
to Cognito hazards and you episode
reducted this video series is intended
to teach you about the protocol
surrounding the various Cognito
hazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment when you know
better you do better and both you and
the secrets of our great organization
can stay safe and as anyone familiar
with a good Cognito Hazard can tell you
knowing really can make a difference
today's episode is about the unique and
dangerous SCP
2316 before we begin repeat after me and
be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following SCP
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than
14.5 through this video presentation you
will need to repeat the phrase is to
ensure your score does not drop below
the approved threshold in the event that
you fail the test stay calm and remain
where you are until medical staff can
retrieve you remember safety is a top
priority when observing Cognito hazards
the safe way is the only way you're a
cog in a very important machine and we
wouldn't want to have to terminate you
now would we one more time please I do
not recognize the Bodies In The Water
very good remember that you do not
recognize them no matter what you might
think you see your thoughts can be very
unreliable when you're around SCP
2316 according to our files on the
matter SCP 2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seem that anyone
who looks at the bodies in the water or
learns too much about SCP 236 16 as a
whole begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they
recognize perhaps they remember their
faces from childhood or High School
whatever the case may be they become
convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar and that they must approach
them no matter how familiar they might
seem however you do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water if a person attempts
to enter the lake reaching out to
whatever instances of SCP 2316 they
think they recognize more bodies will
begin to appear the more bodies appear
the more familiar faces seem to manifest
and the deeper the person will venture
into the lake eventually the person is
lost within the Sea of bodies likely
drowning beneath the surface or simply
becoming one with the hive mind until
they too are one of the corpses there
none of the individuals who wandered
into the lake in search of an old friend
or classmate have ever been recovered
there have been no attempts to search
the the lake for their bodies as it is
unknown what effect SCP 2316 would have
on the team assigned to such a task
though we can guess that the outcome
would likely be extremely negative for
all involved those who do Venture into
the lake simply disappear never to be
seen again if you look too long at the
bodies in the lake perhaps their faces
would surface alongside the rest but
it's best not to think about that after
all we do not recognize the bodies in
the water Foundation Personnel are not
allowed to approach SCP 2316 under any
circumstances the lake is only permitted
to be observed via dummy probes
outfitted with video and audio recording
equipment no one is permitted to observe
any footage or audio files collected
unless they pass through a screening for
resilience to Cognito hazardous
anomalies the lake that holds SCP 2316
has been fenced off and is patrolled by
guards with no prior knowledge of or
exposure to 2 SCP
2316 anyone who attempts to approach the
lake and break through the boundaries of
its quarantine will be seized and taken
to site 33 for examination anyone who
comes within 50 m of the lake is
considered lost and presumed dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water good I almost believe you
let's continue only one Foundation
officer that entered the Lake containing
SCP 2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any official records and
you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conducted by Dr Harrison in his
office Dr Harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they felt compelled to enter
the Water by an invisible force as if
pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfectly put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity Remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those dream
addled Memories the faces in the water
did not open their mouths but somehow
they spoke to the officer just the same
they spoke of who they were and asked
for help they asked to be seen to be
touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at Dr Harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the guards removed
the subject from the room taking them to
the amnestic Department to have all
memory of the Bodies In The Water erase
from their mind then they were forgotten
once more I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water did you repeat it good we
do not recognize the Bodies In The Water
we can't the motivations of SCP 2316 if
it has any at all are largely unclear
there are those on the research staff
that theorize the hive mind or
Collective consciousness of the bodies
is not malevolent in nature it is they
believe simply trying to make sure that
a tragedy that occurred in that lake is
remembered perhaps many lives were lost
to an anomalous force in that Lake and
the impact of that massive tragedy left
behind an impression on the location
this impression manifests in the form of
bodies spontaneously appearing in an
impossibly well preserved condition the
Cognito Hazard of SCP 2316 is not
intended to kill anyone or take them but
rather to force strangers to remember
the people who lost their lives to the
lake this sense of familiarity whether
it is false or not ensures that the dead
will not be forgotten or left alone
after all no one deserves to be left
alone though there have been lives lost
to the Cognito Hazard according to the
foundation it is understandable why the
bodies would want to to be recognized to
have someone somewhere know who they
were to have someone remember their
names Jeremiah feineman Arthur Scott
Denise
Clark where was I oh yes repeat after me
once again I do not recognize the bodies
in the water I do not recognize them I
do
not but that's a lie isn't it I do
recognize them how could I not I know
them they were my friends do you
recognize them look at their faces don't
fight the memories look into their eyes
the class of 1975 they were supposed to
graduate that fall they were just kids
group of innocent kids lost to the dark
and deep what happened to them I can't
quite remember but I know that it
mattered enough for the foundation to
keep the secret and I know that somehow
I survive but I shouldn't have I should
be there with them I should be there
there isn't much time I can hear the
guards coming to retrieve me their
footsteps thundering down the hall I
failed the test and the alarm has gone
off they think I'm lost but I'm not I've
never been less lost in my entire life
I've finally woken up to the truth I
remember I have to go I have to return
to the lake fall of 1975 they went for a
swim my friends they're calling to me I
can hear them so clearly even from so
far away their CRI is for help ringing
in my ears their voices curling around
me pulling me to the edge of the water
the guards will come for you too they'll
know you've seen this they'll call you
compromise they'll say I succumb to the
effects of the Cognito Hazard they'll
say you did too you'll fail their little
tests and they'll say that makes you
weak and broken but you cannot listen
they're lying it's not a hazard it's a
scream for help they're screaming and
the foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us why I have to go back so we can
be together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
Hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out to to keep the truth from me the
barbwire fences around it it's just
another trick I'll climb over it rung
after rung I don't care if the barbs
tear my clothes or pierce my skin it's
worth it for the truth for the memory
and once I've climbed to the top I'll be
able to see there through the fog I can
see their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water let its chill soak into my clothes
down to my bones One Step then another
deeper and deeper the water lapping at
my ankles my knees my thighs the deeper
I go the more sure I will be that this
is where I belong the water will engulf
my chest my neck until my feet no longer
touch the ground I will be lost in it
water flooding into my mouth pouring
into every opening I will let my body
sink down down down to the bottom where
they've been all this time nestled in
the dirt and the dust they've been so
patient but it's f finally time they're
ready to be remembered to be seen to be
found they're waiting for me and they're
waiting for you too can you hear them
I'm going now you have to find me you
have to follow me don't let the guards
stop you don't let them wipe it all away
from your mind fight break free and find
the lake hop the fence make your way
into the water you can't leave me there
to fade away floating in the cold with
the rest can you hear us we're waiting
in it was a beautiful day in Sardinia
the second largest Italian island in the
Mediterranean the sea was clear the air
was hot and the beaches were golden but
the kagari diving Club couldn't see any
of that they were roughly 250 M
underneath the Mediterranean Sea given
the rich and extensive history of the
area they were sure to find some
interesting historical artifacts on the
ocean floor and they were indeed about
to find something incredible but this
history wasn't quite as dead as some old
Roman Pottery Paulo bonacell the most
experienced diver was the deepest of all
they decided to be a little more
ambitious this time than in previous
Dives 20 mi off the Sardinian Coast for
Paulo it was Uncharted Territory so you
could only imagine how amazed and
delighted he was when he saw the shape
of what seemed like a small town beneath
the water Old Stone buildings in a
classic Roman or Grecian Style with
roofs made of thatched seaweed he
gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him they were amazed at how well
preserved the buildings seemed to be as
though they were still being lived in
and actively maintain to this day
despite being around 300 M underwater if
they were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts they'd be the
talk of the local historic community and
probably be able to finagle a payout
from the holy experience too that's when
Paulo spotted something truly amazing a
larger more impressive structure like a
miniature Palace surrounded by grandio
statues of humanoid figures in a circle
around the little Palace each of the
statues was an imposing 5 m tall with a
faint Golden Light emanating from each
of them while the statues were humanoid
they definitely weren't human their
features were strange and fish-like
scales gills tentacles Paulo was in awe
at the sight of them he took pictures
and got closer there was also a huge
chasm in front of the building perhaps
some kind of underwater thermal vent
Paulo was curious he wanted to
investigate further he swam deeper and
deeper what was at the bottom of that
Chasm but lucky for Paulo he would never
see what was at the bottom of that Chasm
before he could reach it something
intercepted him from the side something
large and fast he felt a white hot flash
of pain as Claus raked across his chest
tearing open the rubber of his wet suit
Paulo turned eyes widening in horror to
see a creature staring at him like the
statues it was humanoid but not human an
anthropomorphic sea monster with
greenish skin its arms and legs coated
in thin scales its neck serrated into
fleshy gills he could see scraps of his
suits rubber hanging from its claws it
bore a mouthful full of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl Paulo could
see something in the distance behind
this creature more figures like this one
emerging from The Merc getting faster
getting closer Pao was a smart man but
it didn't take a genius to realize that
if he stuck around something terrible
was about to happen to him and the rest
of the kagari diving Club he turned and
fled paddling with all his might away
from the coming Legion of aquatic beasts
the rest of the club saw the experienced
diver panicking and followed his lead
thanks to their quick thinking and
expertise they all managed to escape
with their lives and only a few minor
injuries but they had no idea of the
true extent of the mystery they were
leaving behind beneath the sea the
Multiverse is a big place there are
alternate universes where the devour of
Worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear there are
alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone Haywire and
attempted to wipe out Humanity through
controlled releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill Squad sent by the chaos
Insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the 05 Council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into a bold New Era and there
are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian we've covered SCP
057 on this channel before in our video
on the most frightening rooms in the SCP
universe
but you've never seen this SCP 057
because this is the Italian version SCP
057 it this localized anomaly off the
coast of Sardinia is under the purview
of the Italian division of thep
foundation which works autonomously with
its own systems and terminology this SCP
is in a frightening room that crushes
its trapped victims together this
anomaly is an entire city 300 M beneath
the water of the Mediterranean Sea
everyone has heard of the mythical lost
city of Atlantis a supposed underwater
Utopia outlined by such great historical
Minds as the ancient Greek philosopher
Plato it's something that people
fantasize about a beautiful idyllic
Society Under the Sea divorce from all
the petty squabbles we deal with up on
land but is everything really better
down where it's wetter let's take a look
and see when Paulo and the rest of the
kagari diving Club returned to the
surface they were happy to tell anyone
that would listen that they encountered
aggressive Merman and an entire
underwater city off the coast of
Sardinia they even posted their photos
onto their official Facebook page along
with photos of Paulo's gnarly chest
scars that's when the Italian branch of
the SCP Foundation finally discovered
them and decided to intervene the
foundation dispatched an sir Squad known
as Oria Nota sirs are the intelligence
and research section of the Italian SC
SCP Foundation a kind of mobile task
force that investigates possible
informational leads Paulo and his team
were given amnestic treatment and any
evidence that they' collected was
scrubbed from existence meanwhile
Lieutenant Marco levini leader of the
mobile task force SSM 2 Squad AKA leio
Alanis was being dispatched to the
source of the problem s SCP
057 itself what started off as a
relatively straightforward exploratory
Mission soon took an extremely strange
turn lini and his men reported activity
down in the underwater city observing
from the safety of their armored
Foundation submarine while the Aquatic
humanoids living in 057 it were
undeniably the same species their cultur
seemed to be split up into two unique
groups one group had thinner scales on
their arms and legs this group was more
numerous having at least 60 active
specimens and was characterized by their
extreme aggression towards any Outsiders
as for the smaller group they had
thicker scales as well as a number of
eily consistent injuries to their hands
feet and gills they were also distinct
from the thin scales in terms of
behavior as they were a far friendlier
more Curious bunch at times members of
this subset would approach the submarine
and regard it with detached Fascination
sometimes they would even point at the
submarine and laugh though their reasons
for doing this are unknown eventually
lieutenant lini was so confident in
their safety around the myrr people that
he and a few other team members decided
to disembark from the submarine on a
diving Excursion and properly explore
the Aquatic City below this would prove
to be a dangerous tactical error on
lavine's part during what seemed like a
routine exploratory mission lavini was
ambushed by a squadron of thin scales
grabbed from behind and kidnapped he was
taken as a hostage and Spirited Away
into one of the city's various buildings
where a thick scale known as as Leia
acted as his Warden but lini soon found
that being under letizia's care was a
profoundly lucky turn of events on his
part both because it allowed him to
learn more about the situation and
because she was one of the small group
left in the city who hadn't become
dangerous Fanatics that's right the myrr
people were in the middle of a heated
Civil War both from the observations of
levini during his captivity and later
interviews conducted by project head Dr
jeppi pastillo with some liberated
members of the thick scales they learned
that a terrible religious conflict had
broken out in SCP 057 it the accounts
coming from the rescued citizens
Illustrated a similar backstory to what
the Italian Foundation had theorized
regarding the my people they were the
descendants of people that lived on the
island of nisos up to the 14th century
BCE before it was devastated by a
volcanic eruption forcing them into the
ocean where they evolved the ability to
live in aquatic environments through
anomalous means since this change this
new species had been operating in
Mediterranean Waters migrating regularly
in order to avoid detection passing
their way of life from generation to
generation as the world changed and
shifted above them in many ways they
were quite similar to humans such as
their reproductive habits they mate and
reproduce after a gestation period more
like animals than fish though their
gestation period is slightly shorter
than human beings at 6 months they
largely speak Latin though the oldest
mer person among them also speaks
ancient Greek my children born in
Foundation containment have shown strong
language acquisition skills as they have
proven more than able to learn modern
Italian and even more fascinating from a
standpoint of sociological study the myr
people have formed their own unique
culture under the sea and this is where
the problems started abstaining from the
belief of the Greek and Roman pantheons
their ancestors looked up to the myr
people instead worshiped their own group
of water-bound deities whose images were
reflected in the great statues in the
center of the town the large building
near the statues and the chasm was the
home of the mayor the town's de facto
leader however what had been a workable
system for centuries began falling to
ruin when a strange religious fanaticism
began to spread a cult-like group soon
formed and began holding ceremonies
where they worshiped a powerful entity
in the chasm known as the great eye this
new cult was known as The Cult of the
great eye of the Mediterranean or SE Jem
for short what began as a fringe belief
soon became a frenzy and took over the
better part of the town with the
acolytes of the great eye proving
themselves more than willing to spread
the gospel of their new deity with
violence some of the more arduan
non-believers were killed for their
heresy While others were simply
ritualistically mutilated in order to to
prevent them from rebelling latisia had
her own evidence of these targeted
mutilations the thin scales had cut the
Aquatic webbing from between her fingers
and toes making it harder for her to
swim away and Escape other suspected
Heretics were given the same treatment
the reason the thick scales even had
thicker scales was that they stole
forbidden technology from the mayor to
increase the strength of their scales
hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and summarily
executed for their acts of defiance in a
sense Letizia was protecting LV by
advising him against trying to escape
knowing the acolytes of the great eye
would kill him if he did she knew that
the only opportunity for escape would
come during the ceremony held by the
acolytes to honor their frightening
Master when the day eventually came as
lini was running low on everything from
food to oxygen everyone in the town was
forced out into the town Center to
witness the ritual the acolytes gathered
around the chasm and began to chant in a
frightening unknown language as they
chanted a blinding light began to
emanate from the chasm and as blurry
shapes emerged nightmarish tentacled
gastropod soon began to take form truly
lovecraftian under sea monsters shortly
after the ritual the Vinnie and the
thick scales were able to make a break
for it pursued by the acolytes of the
great eye it was a close one but
thankfully due to the intervention and
assistance of a trained mobile task
force the fanatical forces of the
acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
myr people along with lavini were
rescued a number of thick scales are now
willingly confined at site netuno an
Italian Foundation containment site
where they have undergone numerous
interviews with Foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest my
person previously present in SCP
057 the only one who spoke ancient Greek
fluently he was different from the
others extremely different in fact he
was a deity made into flesh one of the
deities replaced by the worshippers of
the great eye this unfortunate former
God had done everything to keep his
people's lives safe and peaceful but in
spite of his wisdom and best efforts
hell had once again broken loose not
everything is all well and good in SCP
057 even if a human's body changes their
nature does not and the worst parts of
human nature seemingly follow these
unfortunate myr people into what should
have been their Paradise under the sea
but all hope isn't lost if you were to
judge the entire human race on one
community in turmoil you probably
wouldn't leave with a very favorable
impression of us either correspondence
with a French branch of the SCP
Foundation reveals that myr creatures
aren't just localized to one Waring
underwater city in Sardinia mermaids
have also been discovered and confirmed
by Foundation field agents off the coast
of France 80% of the ocean Still Remains
unmapped to this day who knows what else
is out there just waiting to be found
water the Wellspring of Life we've dealt
with a number of anomalous water sources
on this channel like SCP 006 the much
sought after Fountain of Youth or the
terrifying SCP 3280 where murderous
water threatens to destroy the entire
world but we've never seen anomalous
water that behaves quite like this
before in many of the legends of King
Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who set out on a
particularly lovely warm spring day to
take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange Ripple ghost
across the surface she stopped her
swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touch this Impossible
Creature just as her fingertips reached
the water woman Z the figure dissolved
back into the lake with a splash the
young woman ran home telling anyone who
would listen about the incredible things
she had seen that day of course no one
believed her that is until word of her
sighting reached the only people who
might take her claims seriously the SCP
found
they sent operatives to the lake where
they managed to capture the
shape-shifting entity dwelling there SCP
054 also known as the water nymph is a
being made up entirely of water with an
average volume of 90 L when it is out of
a body of water the being tends to adopt
the appearance of a humanoid woman
though it is capable of taking on a
variety of other shapes including other
humanoids animals and various inanimate
objects The Entity is also capable of
shedding its form and effectively
disappearing into a given body of water
in order to avoid shrinking or possibly
disappearing entirely from evaporation
SCP 054 is required to return to a
larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its
version of a body revealed that it is
made up of ordinary water there is no
apparent reason for its ability to move
and no thermal electromagnetic
biological or Supernatural anomalies
were detected the research team could
not determine what might make this water
alive and sentient and the nature of its
unusual properties is uncertain to this
day when SCP 054 was first brought into
containment at site 08 it displayed
surprisingly congenial and curious
Behavior often walking around outside of
the water and taking turns mimicking the
shapes of various staff and scientists
that spoke to it its demeanor began to
shift toward suspicion and aggression
however following a series of
experiments and an incident involving
the research staff the first experiment
conducted on SCP 054 sought to determine
what would happen if the entity was
denied access to any fresh water water
was drained from the fountain holding it
leaving only enough water for it to form
a humanoid shape but no additional water
in the Basin to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time SCP 054
became visibly frustrated as the water
was being drained out of its enclosure
for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
Fountain it became distant and even cold
to anyone who attempted to speak to it
054 only became friendly again once the
water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test SCP 054 reaction to
extreme temperatures particularly
extreme cold the temperature of the
containment facility was slowly dropped
until the room fell below the freezing
point of water as the temperature
dropped 054 became sluggish and
exhausted it lost its ability to shift
between forms remaining locked in its
preferred humanoid female shape its
movement slowed more and more as the
room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the
ice were chipped off and studied
revealing the crystals were identical to
those of ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero
testing the research team decided to
take things to the other end of the
spectrum and test the effects of heat on
SC SCP 054 the subject was placed in a
tank outfitted with heating equipment
and its temperature was slowly raised
over the course of several minutes when
the water reached a temperature of 95°
the entity's behavior became frenetic
and aggressive it pounded on the glass
walls of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous calm and Cooperative nature of
scp's 054 was nowhere to be found the
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this new
found resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
Dr ccll the acting head of the research
team conducted a study involving SCP 054
memory and ability to be conditioned The
Entity was presented with a series of
increasingly complex mazes and puzzles
when it failed to comply with the
experiment or solved a puzzle
incorrectly The Entity was punished with
an electrical shock or the release of
silica gel into its body both of these
options seemed to cause it a great deal
of pain and distress and it was eager to
avoid further exposure to them SCP 054
displayed impressive learning and
problem solving capabilities revealing
it is likely much more intelligent than
it was first presumed to be Dr Cesc
observing the experiments and with the
effectiveness of his somewhat unsavory
motivational techniques equipped to his
research assistant that they would have
it trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48h hour rest period
before experimentation was resumed yet
again this time Dr cesco planned to
expose SCP 5 4's water source to various
levels of acids and bases in order to
test its homeostatic capabilities
beginning with a5m solution of
hydrochloric acid prior to conducting
the experiment Dr cesal noted I have no
idea what will happen but if this thing
incorporates homeostatic mechanisms like
I suspect Zen we should get some insight
into how it maintains its form he also
noted that SCP 054 Behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned SCP 054 displayed a now
familiar reluctance when it was removed
from its containment chamber and taken
to the lab it thrashed around in the
fountain splashing researchers with
water and retreated from them as they
approached in spite of its efforts
however it was removed from its Fountain
and placed in the experimental tank the
solution of hydrochloric acid was then
dripped into the tank and then all hell
broke loose as soon as the acid touched
the surface of its water SCP 054 became
incredibly distressed it Formed into the
shape of a human face eyes wide mouth
open in a Silent Scream Of Rage and pain
the water churned so aggressively that
the lid of the tank was shaken loose
allowing it to escape the boundaries of
its containment the water formed into
two large hands which shot out of the
tank and grabbed the two nearest
researchers pulling them into the water
and exposing their skin to the acid now
present there as the men scrambled to
drag themselves back out of the tank and
their colleagues were busy helping them
SCP p054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its Escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment facility
the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns
on their skin as well as significant
mental distress they were given
immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on SCP 054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr cesco 04's object
class was changed to uid SCP 054 is
currently contained in a watertight
isolation room fitted with climate
control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entity's
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area area must
wear NBC suits while inside and must
spend 10 minutes isolated in a dry room
After exiting before they are permitted
to return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the
entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis and kept at optimal levels
for the health of scp's 054 during the
course of its containment following the
incident around the acid base
incorporation experiment 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep SCP 054 C no
male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because 5 years have passed since the
last incident involving SCP 054 its
object class has been changed from uclid
to safe on the the recommendation of the
lead researcher assigned to its case of
course caution should still be exercised
while interacting with the entity this
is the SCP Foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown the experimentation on SCP
054 has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate The
Entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself Dr reard had
lost everything his job the respect of
his peers and if everyone else was right
perhaps even his mind it was 11:00 p.m.
when he staggered to the edge of
Okanagan Lake in British Columbia eyes
and judgment clouded with booze this
Lake could have been what made his
career as a researcher for the SCP
Foundation but now that bright future
was slipping through his fingers like
the dry silt beneath his feet he looked
hatefully across the endless dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed
stupid empty place just hours ago he'd
been stripped of his ranks and released
from his position at the foundation for
wasting the organization's time and
resources on frivolous personal projects
frivolous he thought what a terrible
joke just because the higher-ups refused
to acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there Moonlight
shimmered off the water's surface wait
was that Moonlight or was there
something lurking underneath the water
to truly answer this question if any
answer is possible at all we need to go
back to the beginning and ask ourselves
a different question how does the SCP
Foundation actually find most of the
anomalies it cataloges and contains it
is a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
Foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of Interest like the global
occult Coalition and the Serpent's hand
if they so much as sniff the strange and
unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary Personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rarer but
still in incredibly important methods of
finding scps involve looking into myths
and local Legends sure it may seem like
a good way to waste time and resources
but the crossover between recorded scps
and folklore is surprisingly common take
SCP 1000 the formerly hyper intelligent
Apes that were nearly the dominant
species on Earth until humans and a
certain capricious Forest God pulled the
dirty trick on them they're better known
to most civilians as the legendary
Bigfoot or Sasquatch perhaps the most
most famous crypted of all time or SCP
1337 The Hitchhiker an anomalous
spectral entity that manifests in the
cars of those who don't pick her up and
performs horrific acts of violence
against them she's eerily similar to
Legends you can find not only all over
the us but the entire world of ghostly
hitchhikers intruding into the cars of
unwary Travelers and scaring them half
to death or worse if you're unlucky
another case where myths and legends
pointed the SCP Foundation in exactly
the right direction and of course
there's SCP 136 the terrifying naked
doll this was an almost featureless
children's doll found inside an
abandoned house but prolonged time in
its presence can make you the victim of
a warped Apparition that'll drive you
half mad with fear it's got such a
detrimental psychological effect on
people that the foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture
method during enhanced interrogation
sessions with captured members of rival
groups of interest and how did they find
it the foundation keeps track of
neighborhood rumors about haunted houses
with supposedly Supernatural inhabitants
clearly when it looks like it might
actually get results no myth or local
Legend is too big or too small to
Warrant an investigation from the SCP
Foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less Dr B Renard
set off with his team to Okanagan Lake
in search of what locals had referred to
as the legendary Ogo Pogo we've all
heard of the Loch Ness monster the lake
monster from Scotland that's been
turning heads for the better part of a
century and may be related to two other
similar scps namely SCP 3934 and SCP
5533 but Ogo Pogo is Canada's answer to
good old Nessie while the Loch Ness
monster resembles a plaur the yoogo is
much more Serpentine with a long coiling
body covered in green scales its long
tail is said to be able to create Fierce
storm along the surface of the water
with its vicious whips killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray
too close the name Ogopogo is also a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
forwards as it does backwards and is
believed to have originated in the
novelty song from the year
1924 however it's likely that the actual
Beast this somewhat Goofy name was given
to is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
Okanagan Valley Dr Renard very much
hoped this was the case of course he'd
explored the Legends heavily so much so
that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing the
schmeck and celix peoples the lake
dwelling monster was known as nit taka
which has been Loosely translated into
the sacred creature of the water the
water God and most menacing of all the
water demon the Beast was often
described in oral Traditions as being a
malicious Supernatural entity with great
power and ill intent towards those
trespassing on its territory Legend has
it that anyone who crosses Okanagan Lake
the supposed domain of the Ogopogo needs
to make a sacrifice to the monster in
order to ensure safe passage those who
refuse to give this sacrifice the Beast
demanded would pay a heavy toll being
devoured or dragged down to a watery
grave never to be seen again and this
monster isn't just some old folk tale
either contemporary sightings have dated
back to 1873 with both settlers and
First Nations people alike spotting the
Sinister Ogopogo in the intervening
years Dr reard had poured through the
files on hundreds of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
group Greenpeace moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in Okanagan Lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the FBI stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
Beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years later
there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
Okanagan Lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the Beast
underneath the water was more like
likely to be a pair of logs bummer 2018
was an exciting year for the yoogo with
three different sightings of the
creature being reported at different
times throughout the year Witnesses
describe the creature as being a giant
snake around 50 ft long which is
consistent with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the Beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python the non-anomalous
longest snake in the world so naturally
authority figures once again shot down
the validity of any claims that the
creature was actually real and out there
Dr reard found this almost funny they
didn't even need to suppress knowledge
of this creature if it really was out
there mainstream sources seemed to be
doing their job for them and keeping the
creature covered up he was determined
though that he would be the one to prove
to his superiors that this creature was
indeed real and lurking in Okanagan Lake
he organized a number of varied
investigative missions from actively
trolling the lake itself to conducting
interviews with firstand hand witnesses
as well as those who claim to see no
merit in their evidence and testimony Dr
reard noticed a strange phenomenon the
people who'd seen it firsthand were as
certain that it was real as the doubters
were that it was fake even for typical
Skeptics the non-believers seemed
shockingly Resolute that there was
really nothing down there and the
alleged photos and videos were 100%
bogus early diagnostic tests into the
lake directly overseen by Dr Renard
seemed to point to a creature clearly
being down there he found the direct
testimony both compelling and consistent
with what he and his team were catching
glimpses of so why were people so
adamant that nothing was down there it
was almost like the Ogopogo really was
as mythical as the First Nations Legends
said and it was casting a spell on all
the non-believers that's when it hit Dr
Renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with cogn Mago
hazardous Powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
sought up close would actually believe
that the creature was real anyone who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity nobody except those who saw
it directly would ever believe that it
existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous Hunter Dr reard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his Mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation SCP 1933 before
sending it back to his supervisors they
wrote back saying that they didn't feel
as though there was enough of a basis in
evidence to deem this entry worthy of
inclusion if Dr Renard wanted to have
his so-called Ogopogo dignified with
entry into the SCP Foundation archives
he needed to back it up properly this
presented a problem to Dr Renard how
could he provide documentation and
evidence for a cre creature that had the
defining anomalous power of making all
of its own documentation and evidence
seem phony he was caught between a rock
and a hard place with only one solution
create the most undeniably highquality
evidence of the creature that the world
had ever seen not long after that his
superiors at the SCP Foundation would
receive a video file from Dr Renard
according to the notes on his report he
set up a track using an ALK carcass to
lure the creature out of the water and
capture HD video of its feating when the
senior researchers gathered around to
watch the video they were astounded an
animatronic a cheap rubber suit around a
somewhat janky robot like something
you'd see at a theme park how much had
Dr rard spent on this absurd farce did
he think it was funny despite Dr
Renard's protests he was reprimanded
severely for this waste of foundation
resources the object class on his 1933
file was switched to explained meaning a
rational non-anomalous explanation for
the The observed phenomenon had been
found discrediting it and the 1933 slot
was instead filled with a strange fat
man dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are all Irish Cream the ultimate
humiliation Dr Renard was left with
nothing and we joined him once again
where we started with Dr Renard standing
on the ledge of Okanagan Lake staring
hatefully into the water as something
seemed to move underneath if Dr rard
screamed that night there was nobody
there to hear it his remains were
dredged out of the lake the next day His
official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating
accident though the boat in question was
never found reports that his corpse was
found half eaten have mostly been
dismissed as rumors after all there is
no such thing as the Ogo Pogo a giant
monstrous Crab likee Claw closes around
the throat of an unimaginably huge
eel-like Beast the Beast ter terrible
writhing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustation and then the
high-intensity beams of gamma radiations
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless Centaur swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
mither manned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95% of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something truly alien giant squids
organisms that can breathe nitrogen
luminescent predatory fish and sharks as
old as the Earth itself even the SCP
Foundation is still struggling to fully
grasp the depth of the ocean and the
strange beings that dwell there one of
the most unusual aquatic findings in the
history of the foundation is that of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters ofp 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 kilm in length the creature
is green with a mix of blue yellow pink
and red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entities four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stocks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creatures carapace in detail
will notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years years and years of
damage SCP 37001 has several anomalous
qualities in addition to its size in a
fight it is able to strike with its
appendages and produce cavitation
bubbles with a force greater than
several tons of Dynamite two of the
entities eyes are capable of blasting
concentrated gamma radiation at a chosen
Target the creature has the ability to
impact the weather around it dispersing
storms that impede its ability to move
with ease and can reach speeds at to 100
km an hour in spite of its immense power
SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP 3700 D2 speaking of SCP 3700 D2 it
is a 32 km long entity resembling a
pelican eel in all aspects except for
its massive size and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its
body these appendages which tuck inside
its body when not in use are similar to
the tentacles of an octopus complete
with suckers the majority of the
entity's body consists of a seny tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated 3 km
deep its flesh is black and it has white
purple and red bioluminescent lines in
the shape of a man's face on either side
of its torso SCP 37 100 d2's anomalous
properties include the ability to invoke
storms with a severity of category 5
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37001 wins the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
three-fold and the crop yield doubles
the ocean itself becomes increasingly
active and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase 5-fold
when SCP 37002 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the while SCP
37002 swims throughout the area praying
on unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until s SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP 37002 will also
regurgitate instances of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications SCP 37001 has
been implanted with donovian Hollow
projectors which disguise it as a pod of
humpback whales if SCP 37001 encounters
SCP
37002 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of Destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
37 00 d2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until as SCP 37001
is able to subdue it if this does not
prove effective and SCP 37002 cannot be
contained then the task force will
Implement protocol tumult at this point
Naval and civilian crafts in the area
must be evacuated trade and fery routes
to the archipelagos must be rerouted for
at least 6 months there will be constant
aerial and Naval engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappearance of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
tan arrived at a point between the orne
Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos in the
North Sea they were accompanied by the
usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away from the ship's
anchor points the water began to emit
intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this piece did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
SCP 37001 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through and beam down on the
foundation vessels 600 M ahead the ocean
waters began to rage and froth spraying
foam and surf into the air SCP 3700 D2
burst from beneath the surface its head
pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then stopped
to bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter maelstrom
Delta 7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
37002 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers open fire with a combination of
L cannons and conventional Weaponry in
order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines
taau dragging its head in a continuous
Circle while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP 3700 D2 and it grunted
in pain thrashing back and forth before
opening its mouth and spewing an
instance of SCP 3456 into the water as
soon as it hit the water the eoin
monster began to cut through at a pace
of 50 km an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the scps
selki the skki attempted to retarget its
weapons and prevent the creature from
reaching it but the monster moved too
quickly for the skki to adjust the skki
was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it reach for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the S was occupied SCP 3700 D2 was able
to attack again blasting another ship
with a stream of blue fire a loud crack
rang out from across the sea as the sky
dropped back into the water the SCP 3456
instant shrieking in pain SCP 3700 D1
burst through the surface striking the
creature with its Club likee limbs each
blow emitting another loud crack the
third blow tore the instance in half
sending its human torso careening
through the air and pass the scps mither
freed from its attack the skki moved
full steam ahead pulling the Harpoon
line Tau again and dragging SCP
37002 out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water SCP 37001
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
Harm's Way with the crew members rescued
SCP 3700 D1 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
mither ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 37001 shot several
concentrated blasts of gamma radiation
at its foe leaving large holes in the
creature in their wake SCP
37002 screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its new found Freedom SCP
37002 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately tried to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movements stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corpse into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps Str a beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
emitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP
37002 expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP
37002 as the crew looked on and helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity's gaping ma
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP 3700 D2 cutting the
tentacle in half and freeing the sty
beast from its grip SCP 3700 D2 shrieked
before closing its jaws and biting down
on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 3700 D1 returned the
assault in kind bludgeoning SCP 3700 D2
with its club-like limbs from inside of
its mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's
lower jaw was torn out of place dropping
into the water with SCP 37001 still
inside SCP 37002 thrashed fuly growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after 5 minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
side of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface where SCP
37001 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard cumo
nimus clouds in their place the waters
themselves remained choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps mither sent a radio
transmission to command uh this is Delta
7 to command we read you Delta 7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7 SCP
37001 and two are both down command was
silent for 10 seconds utterly baffled by
the information please repeat Delta 7
again the myther said SCP 3700 D1 and
two are both down command ordered the
myther to stand by 3 minutes of radio
silence later communication resumed as
they asked are either entity's effects
active uh negative command is there any
trace of either entity also negative it
appears the anomaly has been neutralized
Delta 7 is to return to base for Deb
following any recovery efforts with
their next steps clear Delta 7 attached
the St bees to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps mither began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of 3 km they
called command requesting permission to
deploy submersibles for exploration
purposes 1 minute of Silence followed as
the command arrived at a decision
request denied return to base for
debriefing and so Delta 7 began to
evacuate the area once more steaming in
the opposite direction of the battle
over the next 5 minutes CCTV cameras on
the vessels picked up an unusual sight
as the gamma radiation levels continued
to increase the ocean turbulence also
worsened tossing smaller vessels and
nearly causing them to capsize then all
of a sudden the water stilled and four
large yellow orbs appeared below the
surface approximately 300 M from Delta 7
they lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous contact and are
no longer detecting gamma radiation uh
we're detecting new contact 5 K deep
large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes be
advised should SCP 37002 manifest
exploration teams are to be considered
lost and you are to return to base the
consequences of this incident as well as
what else might be lurking down in the
depths beneath SCP 3700 are still
unknown the ocean is a terrifying Place
we've all heard heard the statistics
more than 80% of the ocean remains
unexplored that's most of the water
covering the globe completely unmapped
and unobserved by science it's a scary
thought to dwell on realizing that
there's more water than land on Earth
and the sheer expanse of that water is
so large that we've been unable to fully
explore all of it just think there are
places in the ocean that have never been
seen by a human who knows what's down
there if there was ever a
personification of fear of the unknown
the ocean could definitely be it ancient
shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor
unknown sea creatures hiding away from
humanity and the general isolation of
the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious depths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical Mysteries than the SCP
Foundation today we'll be taking a look
at SCP 5007 the bass straight a wave of
oceanic anomalies fit to make any
seasoned sailor shiver in fear the bass
straight is an area of ocean dividing
Tasmania and the Australian Mainland
it's also the location of an unusually
high amount of disappearances Sailors
disappearing from their ships fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming
back even civilians disappearing from
the shores that connect to the straight
the foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the straight
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bass straight and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the straight agent taberer and an
operative of the SCP Foundation was
vacationing with his wife Mary and his
three young children the Taber family
was simply enjoying their day when they
saw what looked like balloons in the sky
they were approaching quickly and
naturally the family moved closer what
happened next was a whirlwind and those
balloons the family were so interested
in Lifted them up from the ground and
carried them away agent tabner tried to
fight back but there was nothing he
could do except report to the foundation
what that occurred and the organization
responded in full force the foundation's
research discovered that reports of UFOs
and lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the straight and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost tabiner family members had
become a large scale investigation into
unexplained disappearances along the
bass straight and within 3 weeks it was
determined that these patterns were
consistent across the entirety of The
Straits coastal regions some witnesses
were interviewed but the vast majority
of these abduction cases had no
Witnesses whatsoever of the minimal
reports filed the foundation was told
that there were lights in the sky and
that appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the
appearances of balloons one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
Alan Stewart a witness who was present
during The Disappearance of former
Australian prime minister Harold Holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bast RIT anomalies during the
interview steuart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff Stuart had no idea what Holt was
talking about but Holt was insistent on
seeing them he swam deeper out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them steuart and Hal's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen steuart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping Holt away but
he couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer Stuart saw Holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the Prime Minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
Holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked
steuart for the interview and continued
their investigation two years later in
1982 Emergency Services received a large
number of calls pertaining to UFO
fightings off the coast of Norman Bay
Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as SCP
57 they evacuated civilians from the
area and successfully managed to capture
the creature which was later transported
to site 40 for containment it was a
sight to Behold The Entity now
designated SCP 5 2007- S1 was a cluster
of human bodies fused between a grouping
of black tentacles of varying length
each tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the Bucy of
which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpes
appeared to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of SCP 5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered SCP 57s behavior during
abduction scenarios was documented
during the initial containment event and
due to the foundation's painstaking
research a pattern was established
between all SCP 5007 encounters first
the victim would be alone or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location SCP
5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass straight in small
coastal towns beaches or boats SCP 5007
will then move towards the shore
stalking the V vitim before lowering its
tentacles and appendages to grab the
individual snatching them into the sky
an SCP 57 instance can even abduct
multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
SCP 57 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where SCP 5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
SCP 5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
Waters of the bass straight and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encountered them in
1985 the foundation's research efforts
paid off and several survey teams oper
operating in the area reported a
sighting of an extremely large SCP 5007
instance heading towards a coastal town
a mobile task force was sent to track
the entity the team observed The Entity
from afar as it stocked a private
fishing boat even from the distance
Foundation Personnel recognized the
likenesses of several missing persons as
faces of the corpses of SCP 5007 the
task force Captain had to remind his
team to keep it together claiming that
they were not people but just parts of
the speci
but everyone secretly knew the truth the
fishing vessel was a private one
occupied by a small family The Entity
slowly approached and quickly pulled a
woman into the air the family panicked
and quickly tried to reach cover for
safety running into the Ship's Cabin The
Entity ran its tentacles along the boat
until it pulled the door open snatching
another two victims the task force was
unable to help them as their mission was
to track the instance to its origin
point it was a horror to watch the task
force implanted a tracking Beacon onto
the entity and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next 4 hours they then
discovered a large gray Reef with
several shipwrecks dotted across it 13
SCP 57 instances floated over the area
some holding on to the land Reef with
their tentacles The Entity dropped the
abductees from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each of
duct T was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the SCP 57 instances watched disgusted
the task force reported what they
observed to the main site and the reef
would be designated as SCP
57- the foundation's analysis of the
reef led to the discovery that The Rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the rec
ships and aircraft that washed across
the shore of the reef were covered with
a dark stone The Reef was teaming with
anomalous marine life including SCP 5007
a red algae that fed upon the freshly
grown Rock Marine worms capable of
levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the waterline small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented as
SCP 4159 in a separate investigation SCP
5 57 often rested their tentacles on the
outcroppings of the reef while inactive
but what caught the foundation's
attention the most was the giant pit
located in the reef center unmanned
exploration drones found that it had a
depth of at least 4,000 M and water
samples taken from the pit revealed
large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries
even when fully surrounded by the liquid
and unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in the storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boy said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
island we are all a fear but there is
not we can do but Beach ourselves and
help for rescue should I be k killed in
the crash I want my mates to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to SCP 5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pilot engaged in a training flight over
the bass straet in 1978 valentic
disappearance was marked by his latest
Comm Comm unication with air traffic
control when he mistook an SCP 57
instance for an unidentified aircraft it
seems like it's stationary what I'm
doing right now is orbiting and the
thing is just orbiting on top of me also
it's got a green light and sort of
metallic like it's all shiny on the
outside shortly after this Valenti's
transmission was interrupted by what was
described as metallic scraping sounds
believed to be the SCP 5007 instance
attacking the aircraft and jamming its
propellers with its map
after crashing into the reef it was
believed that valentic and his aircraft
were pulled beneath the surface of the
pit just as the abductees had been prior
the foundation decided to construct a
provisional secure research facility on
the reef they named it site 40- and
documented all returns and departures of
SCP 5007 they also set up a series of
containment procedures that resulted in
SCP 57 returning with its victims 83%
less often than before the site's
Construction
but this was shortlived in 2008 the site
logged over 36 instances returning to
the reef with only two not having any
fresh abductees the instance's origins
were unknown and it was as if they
appeared out of thin air no other
monitoring post had documented their
appearance or even spotted them before
they arrived at The Reef it was years
later in 2017 that the foundation
eventually was able to successfully
explore what was deep inside the pit at
the center of The Reef they already knew
that there was a large entity lurking
beneath as evidence by what happened to
the victims of SCP 5007 that were later
deposited inside the pool all previous
attempts to explore the pool were met
with failure as the water pressure of
the Pit's depths caused all craft to
collapse due to Hull damage this time
however they managed to construct a
high-tech submarine labeled the scps
Nautilus which was capable of diving a
maximum of 13,500 M underwater they
decided that a d-class Personnel would
be trained to man The submersible and
carry out the exploration the mission
was simple the Nautilus was to dive to
the bottom of the pit and to describe
the depth readings cameras and
microphones were equipped to the vessel
due to the depth remote viewing of the
footage was impossible instead the
foundation had to physically recollect
the vessel in order to view the footage
upon recovery some of the footage
suffered data corruption but what was
there shook those who viewed it to their
core the footage showed the d-class
experience going deeper inside the pit
at first it seemed ordinary the trench
had a number of Rocky outcroppings doted
with black yellow Vines growing along
the walls also present were various
marine life forms such as the spiders or
the fish going deeper the sub observed
an SCP 57 instance clinging to an
outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16 SC P 57 instances were seen
resting along the walls each clinging to
the outcropping as the sub went deeper
the declass remarked that there were
dozens of plane and shipwrecks but also
well over 100 SCP 57 entities most of
them were held there by the black
tendrils the d-class as the sub went
even deeper began noticing human remains
no short amount of them either deep into
the pit there was a large mass of human
remains covering the entire of the pit
bodies crushed and drained of blood but
still possessing intact eyes each
individual was still alive kept
preserved by the life sustaining
compounds found within the water the
body stared at the sub and moved
attempting to grab onto the vehicle the
declass swore they were trying to say
something mouthing words to the camera
of the sub as the sub passed through the
mass of bodies it emerged into a
completely dark black clearing at the
bottom of the pit for a second the
decline thought he was safe but then a
large black tentacle rapidly emerged
from below and grabbed onto the Nautilus
dragging it even further Into the Depths
the d-class screamed and panicked but
there was nothing he could do the
tentacle possessed a large cluster of
eyes mouths and human heads seemingly
grafted onto its mass and then there was
another tentacle and then another the
Nautilus was pulled to the bottom of the
pool the D class's screams were still
heard even as the picture cut out
sometimes times graphic body altering
images of the tentacle features were
visible on the screen but most of the
footage was indecipherable after minutes
of distorted corrupted footage the
Nautilus was seen again rapidly
ascending to the surface somehow it had
managed to escape the entity at the
bottom of the pit upon recovery of The
Craft it was found that the Nautilus was
covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was shortlived
after the containment seal was fitted
site 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
4-r went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma- 6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site 40- was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep keep an eye on the
creature and the ecosystem of the
anomalous marine life that live on the
bass straight never knowing what their
next move might be and always keeping in
mind the risk that comes with dealing
with these poorly understood entities
the diver screams A Silent Scream as the
giant Squid's beak digs into his skin
it's many grasping tentacles grabbing
him and holding him in place nearby his
fellow divers are driven half mad with
Terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the MC and
strange Russian voices speaking in their
heads nobody can help them they're down
too deep too consumed by the darkness
and the pressure of the sea they're now
at the mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage What followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitched during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 as United States citizens
feared they were teetering on the brink
of nuclear war in July of 1968 the
Soviet Union the United Kingdom and the
United States came together to sign the
treaty on the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater wreckage
of a Soviet submarine that sank in March
of 1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what be
came of the crew wherever they went they
seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a man EX Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described in incident report 1741 D
divers a26 through a30 embarked from the
Icebreaker yamal into the waters below
with the intention of studying the
potential anomalous activity surrounding
the wreckage as the group of divers
approached the submarine they could feel
the shift in the water around them the
oppressive feeling of abnormally
increasing pressure bearing down and
threatening to crush them if their
specialized diving equipment were to
fail they knew that that would be it and
the command would have to come and fish
their corpses out of the water or even
worse they would vanish entirely meeting
the same mysterious fate as the crew of
that doomed submarine but they couldn't
fix it on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the sight of movement from within the
rec AG spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
proceed to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when the team checked the radiation
levels in the area they remained stable
whatever the source of the glow was it
wasn't radioactive at this point his
Neutron counter began to register
something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerg from the darkness it
was only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted The
Apparition 2 and began to panic some
checked their nitrogen levels believing
it to be some sort of nitrogen Narcosis
While others pointed out that they
couldn't all be suffering from nitrogen
Narcosis at the same time the unknown
voice continued speaking saying help me
it is getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a 5 m long squid swimming
around the wreckage its presence
startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US government
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basti was patrolling the area
around SCP 741 when it sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching SCP 741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
bisti attempted to reach the contact via
sonab Bui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an undersee missile launch and
bisti responded with the utmost urgency
the ship broke away from its original
area and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds after the
bisti launched its torpedo missiles of
an unidentified configuration were seen
breaking the water flying at a height of
1.8 m and a velocity of .92 Mach the
missiles did not emit any detectable
radar nor did they respond to any launch
chaff or flares from the basti both of
the missiles were engaged by bti's 3K N5
Kinsel surfac to- aair missiles and
castan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 M and 210 M from
impact respectively after the missiles
were neutralized the Hostile vessel
could be heard engaging in evasive
maneuvers at this point there were four
closely spaced explosions and the sound
of a submarine disintegrating the
identity of the attacker as well as its
intention toward SCP 741 have not yet
been determined the incident resulted in
the foundation research team suggesting
an expansion of the acoustic sensor net
as well as additional Patrol and defense
assets placed in the area additionally
they advised an acquisition of unders
sea retaliatory capability the incident
was classified incident 1741 DC the
sonar recordings from the scps bisti
during incident 1741 DC were taken for
further analysis by the research team
the in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government or organization following the
incident involving the scps bisti an
American intelligence agent reached out
to the foundation offering further
insight into the secretive government
programs looking into SCP 741 he agreed
to sit for an interview with a
foundation researcher assigned to the
project on the condition that his
identity remained protected the SCP
researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crew Men
reburied Just Uniforms also the nuclear
device we recovered wasn't a missile or
torpedo Warhead it was a demolition
charge does that make any sense after
all those Clues I had to come forward by
the director and didn't is something I
can't fully explain this particular
statement puzzled the foundation
researcher raising questions he hadn't
anticipated only uniforms did this mean
that the sub had been unmanned the
informant replied no no not unmanned
there were no bodies but personal
effects were everywhere along with
uniforms there was some blood human
before you ask on one of the Torpedoes
and a bit of skin where somebody
probably crushed his hand load in the
thing just no bodies left when I first
looked into all this I had no clue what
the hell had gone on down there but I
started putting things together the
foundation agent began to speculate
based on the mounting evidence could it
have been a Soviet weapons program a
deadly biological agent of some kind no
no it wasn't that I thought maybe it
could have been so I dialed up some of
my contacts at bio preparent as spies
wind up owing each other favors after a
while and they denied it vly not your
usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redacted doctor
do you have any idea what it takes to
make a bioweapons researcher sick now
that wasn't what really bugged me though
what really kept me awake at night was
the KGB file that fell into our hands
they mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if to
ever find me but it was worth the risk
and by what I can gather sounds like
Russia thinks so too loan and you half
the Pacific Fleet in all the interview
continued after this point but the rest
of the conversation was considered
irrelevant and stricken from the
official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any move movement of SCP 741 is grounds
for an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets SCP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea violent
chaos unfolds across the shoreline huge
fleshy tendrils Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant harpoons
made of bone whiz across the beach
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
droves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million years be able
to guess its source on April 10th 2010
something strange began to happen in the
three Portlands now the anomalous
extradimensional city state that
overlaps with the locations of Portland
Oregon Portland Maine and the aisle of
Portland is no stranger to unusual
occurrences so it took the population a
little while to notice that something
was happening but for some unknown
reason sailboats and motorboats were
beginning to vanish from the city the
disappearances occurred overnight when
there was no one around to witness them
but slowly the citizens began to notice
that their friends and family members
were going out in their watercrafts and
never returning home by April 15th the
civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned fearing the worst on April
16th their worst fears were confirmed
when two local ghosts Anar Ahmed and
Greg Moore went for a nighttime stroll
along the harbor they heard a sudden
commotion and rushed to the scene of the
disturbance they arrived just in time to
see a living individual being dragged
into the watery depths by a large
veinlike tendril ammed asked Greg to
wait on land while he ventured out into
the water to look for the victim
unfortunately ammed never came back and
Greg took his story to the three
Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local maned
and clam populace to migrate the FBI
unusual incidents unit mounted a formal
investigation on the morning of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 2st
the threat that had been praying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11:19 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in in or out civilians watched
in shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert ISAT
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach ISAT a city security Gollum
interfered sadly though the gollum put
up a valiant fight the anomaly was able
to destroy it by Falling onto it again
and again until the Golem was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the GRL was in the middle of a
busy brunch service at the sight of the
invading watercraft the GRL set down his
piture of bottomless mimosas wiped his
hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual wield swords from underneath
the C en counter he kept them there in
case someone attempted to dine and dash
but he figured they would do just fine
against a blood drinking Tugboat while
the GRL kept the tugboat busy uiu forces
were able to break through the barricade
of boats for a brief period of time
allowing more security Golems to enter
the area as well as allowing more
citizens to escape unfortunately this
little victory was shortlived as further
unforeseen Horrors drudged themselves up
from the deep the reanimated Corpses of
various species native to the harbor
began to crawl out of the water
surrounding the GRL and allowing the
tugboat to escape the fight as it made
its way back to the harbor every boat it
passed attempted to toss bodies onto the
tugboat covering it in fresh blood
slowly but surely the damage to the
tugboat began to repair itself once the
boat had regained its strength it set
its sights on a previously untouched
cargo ship an observing uiu officer
determined that the boat was somehow
attempting to to convert the cargo ship
to transform it into another one of its
fleshy allies but before the
transformation could take place a cargo
crate broke open spilling over 1,000
hard Tac crackers suddenly the tugboat
stopped everything that it was doing it
took one tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
while the tugboat was distracted with
its task a citizen offered the uiu use
of their rare Metals Cannonball
collection in the fight to apprehend the
aggressive boat one particular
Cannonball made from electrum was able
to puncture the hole of one of the
infected ships rendering it motionless
they were elated to have found a weapon
that worked against these boats while
the tugboat continued to count the
remaining towns people gathered all of
the electrum they could find and began
to fight back against the boats one by
one the boats sank and all the while the
tugboat continued to count in the
meantime uiu officers managed to free
the GRL from from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the guru barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the GRL
then threw the TU booat out of the water
and continued The Savage beating before
preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat careened through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the aisle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
an Hess boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the GRL and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker CL CL Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a constant state
of rust and degradation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
cations The Entity does not only use the
absorb blood to improve its appearance
but is also capable AP of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tendrils spotted
in the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP
6426 C masses of reanimated tissue that
the boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP 6426 uses its tendrils
to grab prey and drag them towards
itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow heart scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 daa these instances are used to the
entities's advantage helping it to
extract blood from victims at a distance
as well as providing an additional line
of defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use SCP
6426 to convert the vehicle into an
instance of SCP 6426 DB these converted
boats are similar to SCP 6426 and are
able to function on their own however
they are unable to produce their own I
stocks or canons unable to create SCP
6426 daa instances and do not appear to
be as intelligent as their creator in
the early days of its containment the
exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that SC SCP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher
sjad Williamson in spite of his protests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks salatian yes
right how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's
first question concerned SCP 6426
apparent intended victim back in three
Portlands Albert ISAT SCP 6426 responded
Albert his first name is really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless Man
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me me he was leading a
search party of those barbaric naop
files intending to gut me like a seal
what do you mean people like you Dr
Williamson inquired freethinkers of
course people who are unafraid to break
from the mold to carve their own path in
life instead of following the
predetermined route set by that ignorant
check valve the church is buil upon a
foundation of lies no one's really a
petty officer on this ship we're all
just cabin boys stumbling around in the
dark as we follow the commands of an
offhand
coob if you want real power real Freedom
all you have to do is listen for the
call of the Beast open the port hole and
he'll squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and how you arrived
there well after I got the B swans off
my trail I found a cave to hide in I was
forced to hide in yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as o Zealot stock the ser
I spent my time preparing Gathering the
strength necessary to face them once
more until I was ambushed assaulted
within my Hideout by a b swine I fought
for my life as I was forced out into the
open and descended upon by a manner of
monsters and freaks of this orchestrated
by that scumbag eard I was beaten within
an inch of my life before I'm not quite
sure what happened after that I believe
I was knocked unconscious you'll have to
Illuminate Me on how I came to be in
your custody at this point the interview
began to Veer in an odd Direction the
boat expressed confusion about the
nature of Williamson's questions
specifically how little they related to
the subject of sharks and punching them
it was at this point that the site
director sought guidance from the multi
U Department a researcher there informed
Williamson about the confusion SCP 6426
had mistaken the SCP Foundation for
another organization the punching Center
Dr Williamson resumed the interview
prepared to play along and keep the boat
comfortable unfortunately Williamson was
a terrible liar yes we are the shark
punching Center we will determine if you
are a suitable candidate to carry out
the mission to search punch and contain
sh I mean cations this verbal misstep
caused SCP 6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently SCP 6426 is kept in a 39 m x
39 m x 50 m containment chamber beneath
the chamber there is an artificial lava
tube the tugboat has a naval Ram through
its Hull and engine holding it in place
this Ram is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly immobile if the ram
is ever removed or damaged somehow a
failsafe system will activate releasing
100 hardtack crackers and two pieces of
electrum into the containment chamber
this is intended to keep the tugboat
occupied until the naval Rod can be
replaced if for some reason the naval
Rod fails and the boat runs out of heart
attack to count while there will be
nowhere on water or land that we can
hide
what is a mirror speaking in strictly
literal terms it's a reflective paint of
glass that we use to check our hair or
the clothes we've decided to wear
seriously how did you match that shirt
with those pants but think about it
another way what is a mirror for well
it's for showing us ourselves allowing
us to see what everybody else around us
does when they look in our Direction in
that way you could say that a mirror is
honest a mirror doesn't lie but that
doesn't mean they can't hold secrets
behind that Looking Glass also known by
the alternate name of the Red Sea object
SCP 093 is not a mirror itself it's
actually a red disc that has been carved
from cabar cabar for anyone not already
aware is a toxic ore of mercury that has
been crafted into jewelry and ornaments
in many parts of the world over the
centuries thanks to its Ruby like red
coloration the SCP 093 disc itself is
only around 7.62 cm in diameter fitting
comfortably in most average size Palms
all around the object are a number of
symbols carved into its surface strange
circular Engravings of Unknown Origin
the color of the Redstone disc will also
apparently change based on whatever
regrets are being carried by the person
who holds it there seems to be some link
between color changes and the mental
state or level of knowledge possessed by
the subject to put it in much simpler
terms think of SCP 093 is color like one
of those novelty mood rings you see in
gift shops that change to different H
supposedly to match a person's mood
although in actuality it's normally
Changed by their body heat the same
cannot be said of the Red Sea object it
is stunningly accurate in peering into
your soul and diagnosing the darkness
within if ever you come into contact
with this baby you might even discover
that it knows you better than you so a
weird Stone disc doesn't sound all that
impressive does it and what does that
have to do with mirrors well SCP 093
happens to have have a certain
attachment to mirrors and we mean that
very very literally if the Red Sea
object is ever not in front of a mirror
or not being held by someone it will
speed towards the closest reflective
surface as it rolls its way in the
direction of the nearest mirror or
mirrorlike Surface SCP 093 is capable of
building up phenomenal speeds although
curiously it never appears to cause any
impact damage when it finally arrives
neither to itself nor the mirror it
latches onto which brings us to the next
inevitable question what happens when
SCP 093 is placed on or attaches itself
to a mirror does it create a copy of the
person who last touched it a clone that
reflects all the darkest parts of
someone's personality maybe it can allow
the holder of SCP 093 to themselves
become like a mirror bending light away
from their body in order to become
functionally invisible well it's
actually neither of these the truth is
far more strange and existential during
extensive test in the SCP Foundation
investigated the potential anomalous
uses for SCP 093 paying especially close
attention to how the Red Sea object
interacted with mirrors after a number
of unsuccessful tests they finally
learned what happens when someone places
the disc onto a mirror they move into
the mirror any mirror that SCP 093 is
placed against or otherwise attaches
itself to is transformed into a portal
of anomalous origin and destination
naturally the first instinct of the
foundation person while examining this
artifact is to send through an
expedition to explore the other side of
this newly formed mirror portal so
that's what they did they gathered up a
member of d-class the imprisoned
criminals that the foundation uses as
Expendable subjects for Dangerous tests
the subject was given water ready to eat
meals a flashlight a gun and a concealed
knife the latter of which the d-class
was not made aware of the first subject
despite having a pass of murder and
attempted suicide seemed to regret his
actions and willing ly agreed to
cooperate with testing and as a result
SCP 093 emitted a blue glow that also
tinted the view in the mirror perhaps on
the other side he expected to meet his
end and expected it as a righteous
punishment for his life of sin stepping
through the mirror to the other side of
the Looking Glass the d-class found
himself in an empty field not another
person or even a single tree in sight
traversing forwards he quickly came
across a section of grass that was
Barren wilted and dying in the Center of
which was a hole climbing in as per
Foundation instructions the man found
only dirt for about 100 m but then
something strange happened the dirt
around him gradually gave way to a
concrete enclosure that the man remarked
stank of something awful the room was
lit by a series of ceiling light
fixtures some of which were already
broken three doors were positioned on
either side of the enclosure with an
extra door at the far end blocked by
some Fallen metal shelving the existence
of a place like this seemed seemed to
imply that someone was present beyond
the portal or at least they had been
this ancient underground bunker lost to
time seemed to have traces that people
had once lived there in one of the
adjacent rooms the ceiling seemed to be
coated in a smelly brown sludge but it
was in here that the d-class discovered
a makeshift cot wooden crates containing
food stuffs and empty water bottles and
a book lying next to the cot when he
attempted to approach the book he was
assaulted by a screeching noise like
grinding metal the door was beginning to
close as the d-class dashed out the body
cam he'd been fitted with seemed to pick
up a figure standing at the end of the
corridor where the seventh door was it
opened the door from behind just to
crack looked in and silently shut it
once more finding only crumpled
newspapers and food rations the
foundation ordered the Intrepid declass
to return to the mirror suddenly
something tugged at the lifeline secured
around his waist something was pulling
him up out of the tunnel while trying to
get back to the Mirror the d-class
witnessed a group of 37 figures all of
them faceless with no discernible
features to speak of in his Escape he
opened fire with the gun he'd been
issued but not at the crowd at something
bigger a massive humanoid creature
around 50 times bigger than an average
person was crawling around on the ground
like the other figures this giant was
without a face pulling itself towards
the mirror as the d-class was reeled
back through the Mirror by a cable and
pulley after their first glimpse into
the world within SCP 093 naturally the
foundation was curious to learn more the
next test revealed more about this other
reality for one that the Red Sea object
seemed to choose its locations based on
the personal history of whoever was
traveling through a mirror this time it
was a female d-class who had killed two
children while stealing a car she
arrived at a farmhouse which had a
bunker of its own like the first test
much like then there were definite signs
that someone had inhabited the bunker
before her arrival but most telling were
the three skeletons and empty revolver
it seemed that everyone in this world
lived in bunkers at some point possibly
to hide from the various faceless
creatures that roam the landscape
additionally any remnants of a
civilization that were uncovered seemed
to fit the aesthetic of the 1950s
however this civilization also seemed to
have technology compared to that found
in the 21st century the d-class
discovered a laptop the casing of which
also seemed to resemble a 50s style
booting the machine up revealed the
final moments of its operating system
something called faithful OS instances
of the same operating system seem to
crop up everywhere the more the
foundation sent expeditions through the
mirrors the world that SCP 093 had
offered access to seemed to be brimming
with advanced technology far more
impressive inventions than anything that
exists in our world not just computers
either but this world even had
functional self-driving cars suck on
that Elon Musk and yet even even with
all that advancement they were still
stuck in the' 50s 1953 to be exact as
one Expedition discovered that this was
the last recorded year of this world but
something had clearly occurred here some
sort of devastating event that had wiped
out almost all of humanity and driven
the survivors into underground bunkers
where they eventually perished but what
the sudden arrival of those faceless
creatures or was it more to do with that
strange viscous Brown sludge that seemed
to be cropping up all over the place
this world seemed to be abundant with
religious imagery even down to the
naming of faithful OS symbols of hands
clasped together in prayer and other
iconography linked to Christianity could
be found everywhere from the outer sides
of buildings to the computers and
folders found when the foundation
Expeditions delve deeper into the cities
and offices in one they discovered a
waiting area assumed to be connected to
a doctor's office which provided more
clues as to just what had happened here
examining the contents of the
receptionist computer in this office
revealed that the doctors of this world
were deeply ingrained in Theology and
were responsible for treating their
patients for a number of strange
symptoms one entry described a woman
citizen Jennifer mizerka who seemingly
suffered a lapse of the heart this
apparent condition caused her to sin
committing adultery before she was
admitted into the Lord's and our hands
for cleansing of Mind and Body it
appeared that this world took religion
to an extreme employing doctors to cure
Sinners of their trespasses through the
use of of something referred to as the
Lord's tears that brown fluid splattered
all over this mirror world this
substance as the foundation soon Learned
was harvested from the giant faceless
creatures that roamed freely around this
place but the question still remained
why the answers were uncovered in
another Expedition This Time by a
foundation service technician who was
able to make SCP 093 turn a bright red
color when he affixed it to a mirror it
was transported to a room with a
rotating pillar with beams of light that
Shone upon other copies of SCP 093 these
various copies of the mirror portal
system seem to be leading to other
mysterious worlds as if looking back
behind the curtain the technician found
an adjacent room filled with computer
equipment monitoring these other worlds
and categorizing them as either clean
unclean or lost so what do we have where
does all of this leave us besides
scratching our heads clearly some sort
of cataclysmic disaster occurred in one
of the these mirror worlds it had once
been a place where technology had boomed
in the 1950s but that was also steeped
in religious beliefs to the extent where
Sinners were treated with a strange
substance extracted from those faceless
creatures it seems as if some time ago a
Godlike being known only as him arrived
in one of these worlds and this served
as the Catalyst for such an advancement
in technology however he had also deemed
this world to be unclean and full of sin
mandating a purge of all sinners in
order to to cleanse the world as a
result a holy war took place to
determine who was worthy of Salvation a
deeply religious Society formed around
the arrival of him and their primary
weapon against the Sinners was this
brown liquid his holy tears and those
monsters prowling around one part of the
unclean their sins given form except
none of that was true there was never a
war no fight between Holiness and
cleanliness the truth was this being
this eldrich Abomination had arrived to
conquer using the discs like SCP 093 he
traveled to that world fed them lies and
turned the people into his followers
becoming the master of their world and
eventually its Destroyer ultimately as
SCP 093 is a warning a look at what
happens when a being like this takes
over the broken dead world that the Red
Sea object transports us to is a legacy
of his destruction a false god praying
on Humanity and their beliefs like a
theological Predator then when his work
is done he moves on to find a new world
to conquer we can only hope that his
gaze never rests upon ours or that what
the Red Sea object knows of our many
sins will be the least of our problem
there was blood in the water but at
least the screaming had stopped it had
been an ill-advised party boat floating
out in Dangerous Waters where a bachelor
party full of rich and naive men had
ignored every warning some had told them
don't you know that pirates operate in
these Waters others had cautioned you
might get confused for pirates and shot
down by military boats nobody had
expected The Impossible monster that had
actually killed all 10 people who'd gone
out there on that warm ocean night but
in the chaos that unfolded the day after
they would find out a cargo ship
carrying hundreds of millions of dollars
with the products and valuable raw
materials was scheduled to cross CR
those same Waters if they could have
gone any other way they would have but
with corporate shipping deadlines to
reach they couldn't afford to take the
scenic route and potentially add over an
entire week to an already long trip the
cargo ship would need to take the risk
they would need to face the Pirates on
their own turf if it came to that
meanwhile on a number of secret
compounds on land the Pirates were
preparing their corrupt government
shipping sources had given them a
valuable tip about the ship and they
were doing everything they could in
order to ensure this flagrant Act of
piracy would be successful they loaded
fuel into the tanks of their speedboats
they clicked magazines full of
armor-piercing bullets into their AK-47s
they slipped on bulletproof body armor
and clipped grenades to their belts they
were a terrifying force to be reckoned
with but they had no idea that within a
few hours they would be encountering
something far more dangerous you see
strange things had had been happening on
some of the world's coastlines it
started with Surfers fool hearty
Sunkissed Thrill Seekers with an
addiction to catching the biggest waves
possible of course there are plenty of
surfers who get claimed by the Sea every
year it is an occupational hazard
especially for fledgling Surfers but the
mysterious circumstances of all the
workers had something in common blood in
the water of course it didn't stop with
Surfers anyone who swam a few feet
further than the edge of the water
seemed to be at risk lonely Moonlight
swimmers went first but it didn't take
long for whole families to start
disappearing in the waves a few here a
few there nothing that most people even
noticed just a whole bunch of
unconnected isolated tragedies the sea
is a cruel mistress though when looking
at these cases nobody ever considered
that something else entirely could be
behind all these terrifying
disappearances but back to the cargo
ship making its way across the turbulent
Waters and those Waters were indeed
turbulent far choppier than the forecast
had predicted the waves were huge
towering even but that was no excuse to
delay their important Mission their
comms had recently received a communic
from the local government about the
missing party boat and all its occupants
assumed dead the previous night Pirates
most likely the cargo ship had come
prepared for this eventuality the
company sponsoring their efforts had
lost too much time and money to let
their ships be sitting ducks floating
goodie bags for violent criminals that's
why they'd spent a little extra money on
a precaution heavily armed mercenaries
patrolling the ship ready to kill in
order to protect their boss's products
the scene is set for a blood bath and
certain things out there in the deep
love a good blood bath the Pirates ready
to make a lot of money by any means
necessary loaded into their ships and
speedboats their assault rifles slung on
their backs they took to the waters
howling battlecries as they zeroed in on
the cargo ship across the Bucking waves
they prepared to fire but they didn't
expect their target to fire back with no
mercy The Mercenaries ran to the edge of
the boat and started firing down on the
smaller boats surrounding them with
machine guns several Pirates went down
chalk full of bullets dead before they
could even figure out what was going on
as their bodies sank amidst the waves
their blood flowed on the surface like
big red plumes while the Pirates were
shocked at the resistance they weren't
unprepared you don't get to become the
rulers of this particularly tough part
of the ocean without being ready to give
it even harder than you can take it in
accordance with this the Pirates loaded
up the handful of RPGs they brought out
with them and fired their deadly
payloads at the side of the cargo ship
boom boom boom the ship was rocked by
explosions knocking over some of the
many mercenary standing on the hole some
fell screaming down into the water where
Pirates quickly cut them down with
bursts of Ruthless gunfire but one
mercenary who fell off the back of the
boat got lucky or unlucky depending on
your perspective no pirate spotted him
potentially leaving him safe and sound
until he noticed a large wave coming
towards him it took more than a little
water to frighten this hardened Soldier
of Fortune until he saw something
nightmarish hiding in the dark the flash
of white fangs and an ivory jaw it
hinged open and bore down on him as the
wave prepared to crash the mercenary
screamed and after the wave hit him he
was gone meanwhile the violent battle
between the mercenaries on the cargo
ship and the Pirates trying to claim it
raged on using grappling hooks the
Pirates were climbing up onto the hull
having disabled the back Rudder with
sustained gunfire and targeted bombing
the ship was soon suffused with
Bloodshed as pirates and mercenaries got
gunned each other down in bloody combat
men were falling left and right but
there always seemed to be more little by
little as each man fell there was more
and more blood in the water out in the
depths as a storm began to rage and the
waves whipped and roared something
hungry could smell and taste the blood
one boat full of pirates kept circling
the cargo ship like a Hungry Shark one
worked the engine with practiced
efficiency while another three aimed
AK-47s up at the ship waiting for the
moment when another unfortunate
mercenary stuck up his head ready to
receive a bullet but their true enemy
wasn't even on the ship it was sneaking
up behind them only the man working the
speedboats engine spotted it before it
was too late a wave rose out of the sea
moving with a speed that shocked even
this veteran seaf farer at first he
thought nothing of it too busy to keep
out of the range of mercenary bullets he
was hardly the type to worry about
getting wet and then he saw that teeth
as the wave Rose well above his height
and only a few feet away he saw
something impossible floating in the
water a shape he'd been seeing hanging
above the fireplace and a bar he'd been
frequenting for years the jaws and teeth
of a great white shark perhaps it was
just refu from a dead shark floating in
the water that was the most reasonable
explanation right but if that was the
case why would the Jaws be spreading
further apart as though ready to receive
him he screamed so loud that his crew
mates first assumed he'd taken a bullet
but when they turned around they saw the
truth a huge wave was crashing down on
them and they saw the teeth not just one
set the one that the engine man had seen
but a different set of teeth for each of
them Hungry Shark mouths without sharks
bearing down they all screamed their
desperate sounds of Terror blending into
an incoherent chorus before being cut
off by the crash of the Waves the boat
was wrecked empty and bloodstained when
the water dissipated sinking lifelessly
to the bottom of the ocean but of course
the worst was yet to come the anomaly
and the waves wasn't satiated all the
mercenaries and Pirates it had taken so
far were just the appetizer and now it
was ready for the main course everyone
now on the cargo ship pirate mercenary
and sailor caught in between who was
fighting and even dying for money had no
idea what was coming the wave rumbled
and Rose behind the ship getting taller
and taller and taller until even the
giant vessel looked like a toy boat in
its wake in the darkness of the wave
hundreds of pairs of nashing sharp Jaws
the sharp edges of their teeth
glistening the wave fell upon the ship
sending fles eating water coursing
through every nook and cranny when the
water cleared there wasn't a single
Survivor the ship irreparably broke it
sank to a metal graveyard down below
nobody in the normal world would even
know what happened for those with a fear
of sharks and deep water this particular
anomaly is a living Nightmare and one
that the French division of the SCP
Foundation has encountered with
unsettling frequency it's been recorded
manifesting off a number of different
coastlines and who even knows how often
it's manifested out in deeper waters
despite its uclid classification
containing this anomaly has been no mean
feat it's involved shutting down a
number of coastlines completely on the
pretense of animal research the
administration of Class A amnestics to
Witnesses and class b amnestics to
victims as well as a complicated
disinformation campaign to suppress
photos and reports of the phenomenon
online but even with all of these
containment procedures in place many
have still lost their lives to the jaws
of SCP 054 dfr or the Great White Wave
by the foundation's current current
estimations recorded attacks by the
Great White Wave have been fatal 68% of
the time with survivors often
experiencing wounds consistent with
those of an abnormally bad shark attack
in case our opening case study didn't
clue you in the Great White Wave is a
set of ravenous shark jaws most closely
resembling the karadon karius or great
white shark manifesting inside ocean
waves any waves over 4 M tall can become
a host to a Great White Wave event with
there theoretically being no upper limit
to the size of a wave capable of causing
this kind of anomalous catastrophe the
power of the great white waves bite is
also directly proportional to the size
of the wave it manifests on two meaning
that in theory a tsunami playing host to
the Great White Wave could devour an
entire town while every attack that the
foundation has failed to prevent is of
course a tragedy the number of attacks
has allowed the foundation to uncover
some extremely interesting data for
example while attacks Could Happen
anywhere at Sea they're most common in
the 250 M ocean radius around a
coastline when a human or non-aquatic
animal is present in the attack zone
Great White waves move at three times
the speed of a normal wave in pursuit of
its unfortunate prey the Great White
Wave isn't picky about its prey either
divers swimmers and even aquatic
Vehicles like boats or jet skis have
been devoured though the waves seem to
show a particular preference for Surfers
which is gnarly in the typical sense but
not in the sense that Surfers say it the
ghostly shark jaws will only become
visible next to the part of the wave
closest to the victim meaning that they
often aren't spotted until it's too late
but that doesn't mean it can consume
multiple victims at once as you saw with
the unfortunate Sailors and pirates in
our opening story many sets of Jaws can
manifest in the case of having multiple
victims to Devour the actual consumption
occurs as the wave crashes crashes down
upon the victim so the only recorded way
to survive being on the wrong side of
the Great White Wave is to dive into the
water before the wave crashes the French
division of the foundation conducted a
series of experiments in hopes of
understanding the Dynamics of the Great
White Wave which had results both
encouraging and disturbing based on
nonanomalous shark ability to
electromagnetically sense blood from
extreme distances the foundation wanted
to see if the same could be said for the
Great White Wave after pouring several
liters of animal blood into the water of
an affected area they found that a Great
White Wave regularly manifested within 2
minutes crashing down and devouring the
affected blood however an extension of
this experiment found an alarming result
the same amount of human blood attracted
a Great White Wave in under 60 seconds
even a small amount of human blood
attracted a Great White Wave
significantly faster than a large amount
of animal blood interestingly
non-anomalous great white sharks will
rarely ever ever attack humans on
purpose whenever they do it's often
because they mistook a swimming or
surfing human for a seal their natural
prey you'll often find that most shark
attack victims are only bitten once a
common shark behavior known as a testing
bite once the shark realizes that it
isn't eating a seal it will quickly move
along yes this probably won't make the
person with a shark bite taken out of
them feel any better but the shark
didn't truly want to eat them great
white Waves by contrast enjoy eating
humans significantly more than animals
but that doesn't mean they won't eat all
kinds of animals several Maritime birds
were eaten by a great white wave when
they flew in front of the wave that was
over 4 M tall we suppose the Great White
Wave has never heard the salty old Sea
Dog tale that it's bad luck to kill a
seabird the foundation discovered a few
useful things from their experiments if
you want to avoid getting eaten by the
Great White Wave you should avoid
getting into the water if you're
suffering from any any kind of injury
wounded people are four times as likely
to be the victims of attacks with a
great wide wave manifesting in less than
60 seconds you can also improve your
chances of surviving by following Sam
Neil's advice from Jurassic Park don't
move a muscle movement especially
panicked thrashing has a tendency to
lure this unique aquatic Predator into
your vicinity But Here Comes the
disappointing part other than staying in
a landlock area there's basically
nothing else you can do in order to stop
a Great White Wave event weapons have
proven completely ineffective with the
bullets of even the highest caliber
weapons simply disappearing into the
wall of water stealth Beyond avoiding
movement is also ineffective no attempt
to camouflage the smell of humans has
been effective in helping them evade the
detection of the Great White Wave you
can probably imagine how many
unfortunate DCL classes got devoured in
the process of finding that one out the
Great White Wave is a disturbing
reminder that perhaps we shouldn't worry
about what lurks in the deep ocean when
nothing has a greater capacity to
destroy us than the unimaginable power
of the ocean itself it was a beautiful
September day but Shawn Taylor was
trapped in his car in one of the worst
cases of gridlock he had ever seen he
tried to look on the bright side though
and while he was stuck in an unmoving
car at least he had a pleasant view of
the wide shimmering Lake just off the
road next to him he was admiring the
scene when tiny drops of rain started
landing on his windshield that's funny
there wasn't a cloud in the sky a moment
ago there was something off about the
rain though it looked dirty a rusty red
color was that blood he didn't have time
to think about it because just then a
thick dense Mist began to roll over the
lake a fog of blood just off the side of
the road he could see a huge silhouette
rising out of the water is that an old
submarine what Shawn didn't know was
that he was about to have have an
encounter with SCP
1861 also known as the HMS winter shimer
a ghostly submarine with strange and
terrifying effects Shawn and the other
drivers stuck in traffic that day were
far from the first people to have a
dangerous brush with this legendary
vessel according to SCP Foundation
records the HMS winter shimer has been
appearing since as early as
1916 the first recorded incident
occurred in the British Seaside town of
insouth on sea you won't find this town
on any Maps or in the history books and
you're about to find out why the 500
population of the town which had already
reduced by the wartime draft into the
currently raging great world war awoke
to Red Skies on February 6th
1916 citizens left their homes to
investigate only to find their entire
town had been enveloped in a thick Red
Mist the swelling Crimson clouds up
ahead began to rain showering the town
in a hail of viscous red goop anyone
unlucky enough to taste it would say
that this strange rain was a dreadful
mix of salt and copper this was because
as the foundation would later determine
the rain and fog was a disgusting
combination of saltwater human blood and
human cerebros spinal fluid but the real
threat was Rising just beyond the beach
technically speaking the HMS winter
shimer vessel is designated as SCP
1861 daa it appears to be a World War I
era British b-class submarine designed
by Vickers for the Royal Navy in 1904 by
1916 this particular type of boat was
already on its way to being Obsolete and
were largely deployed in Malta far from
the active fronts so one of these
vessels appearing on an otherwise
unremarkable stretch of English coast
line should have been a clue that
something was terribly wrong but the
poor residents of insouth on seeg didn't
know the half of it soon figures in what
appeared to be archaic diving gear began
emerging from the winter shimer and made
their way into the township they seemed
terrified running up to and frantically
screaming at any local they could find
please listen to me something terrible
is about to happen here we need you to
come with us or you're all going to die
you must believe us the locals were
frightened by what they heard they'd
been listening to news reports of the
Great War unfolding across the globe for
2 years now had it finally come to them
they pictured shells raining down from
the sky decimating their defenseless
little town in a rain of fire the Navy
must have been brought in to save them
before the German bombardment began
while some took more convincing than
others the men in diving suits known as
SCP
believe their eyes as they watch scores
of people disappear in front of them
into the dark bowels of the winter
shimer where were they all going how
would they all fit in there but it was
too late for any of them to back out now
the vessel submerged once more and
everyone was gone the entire population
of insouth on sea had disappeared in a
rain of fog and blood never to be seen
again the foundation wiped all records
of the town from existence and delivered
appropriate amnestic treatment to any
one who still mentioned or remembered
insouth on sea the fate of those who
boor the HMS winter shimer is always the
same vanish from the face of the Earth
explained Away by the foundation as
accidental death by extreme weather
event there have been hundreds of
documented sightings of SCP 1861 and the
anomalous weather event can occur near
any body of water wide enough to
accommodate SCP 1861 daa's comms Tower
and topmost platform depth does not seem
seem to be any hindrance of the
submarine appearing and it can even
manifest in water that's just a few
inches deep as Shawn and the other
unfortunate victims of the rush hour
traffic were being showered in thick red
droplets from above a crimson Mist
rolled in between the cars sea had heard
of so-called freak weather events before
like raining frogs and fish but this was
something different and it frightened
him he could see now that the silhouette
rising from the lake really was an old
submarine and he watched as a legion of
mysterious figures disembarked from the
vessel and began spilling onto the road
the men in ancient looking diving suits
walked among the cars and one of them
approached Shawn's car he began tapping
frantically on the window and Shawn
could tell he was yelling something
Shawn was scared and more but more than
anything else he was confused against
his better judgment he rolled down the
window just a crack to hear what the man
was saying his British accented voice
muted by the diving suit the man
frantically told him sir please listen
to me I'm Lieutenant Samuel Ramsey of
the HMS winter shimer we're evacuating
the area please you've got to come with
me we're in danger out here HMS Shawn
thought isn't that what they call
British ships what was a British
submarine doing in the middle of a lake
in the United States through his
windshield Shawn could already see other
men in diving suits leading people from
the cars out towards the submarine
something had to be going on here
something big Lieutenant Ramsey was
still banging away at the glass of Sha's
window becoming increasingly agitated
sir if you won't comply with my orders
I'm within my rights to take you by
force for your own safety Shawn could
feel the fear setting in but he didn't
know what else to do he turned off the
car and took off his seat belt he was
just about to open the door when there
was a tap on the passenger side window
of his car it was a soldier in what
looked to be Advanced tactical gear
there were several soldiers directing
cars to drive on the shoulder to get
around the mess of stopped automobiles
Shawn looked to his left and the man man
in the diving suit was gone the soldier
tapped again and Shawn didn't need to be
told twice he followed his directions
and drove around the traffic jam and out
of the Mist a half mile down the road
Shawn was stopped by another group of
soldiers and given an amnestic he drove
away never knowing how close he had come
to Vanishing in the bowels of SCP
to help those who had already complied
with SCP
1861-1867 instances since 1916 and now
they were finally going to figure out
what was going on inside the foundation
had already discovered that those taken
onto the winter shimer don't simply
disappear once on board the submarines
they are forced into a diving suit of
their own which transforms them into new
instances of SCP
1861-62 the foundation dispatched two
members of d-class personnel who were
familiar with one another into the Red
Mist one was instructed not to interact
with SCP 1861 B while the other named s
was ordered to enter the submarine his
mission was to report back all findings
to Foundation researcher Dr clutch
during the next 1861 event the d-class
who remained on Shore was brought in
Once More by the mobile task force
during the September event that Shawn
witnessed they checked each diving suit
wearing anomaly until they heard a
familiar voice muffled by The Mask it
was s and he'd been transformed into an
instance of SCP
1861 B the human d-class receiving
questions from Dr Dr clutch via remote
broadcast commenced the interview of his
former friend it is from this vital
interview that much of the foundation's
knowledge of the mysterious HMS winter
shimer is drawn according to S the
interior of the winter shimer which is a
long narrow passageway is a spatial
anomaly that seems to stretch on forever
this explains how vast number of people
like the entire population of inth on
sea can disappear into the submarine at
once s reported that about an hour after
entering the vessel the hatch closed and
the interior began rapidly filling with
water as the submarine descended
prisoners of the winter shimer were
faced with two choices suit up or drown
few chose the latter option and as soon
as the suit was on the transformation
had begun as soon as everyone was suited
up and the submarine had fully descended
causing the 1861 weather event to
dissipate on Earth the winter shimer had
effectively entered an alternate
Dimension the air lock opened and the
new recruits were instructed to step
outside and take a look around the
winter shimer veterans informed the new
Sailors that everyone on land was likely
already dead by this point when s first
exited the submarine he commented on
everything around him looking eerily
similar to how it looked on land before
the Mist descended but with one key
difference it seemed as though
everything was underwater well not quite
that it was almost as though everything
was water like the world had taken on a
kind of flowing liquid state s and the
others existed in this otherworldly land
of Living Water for 6 months and as the
months passed things only got stranger
they found that they neither needed to
eat nor sleep according to S all they
did was breathe and pass the time by
exploring and talking to one another
anyone who attempted to take off their
suit would dissolve and diffuse into the
same liquid that surrounded them Dr
clutch asked s about the other
inhabitants of this alien realm and this
was when things got truly disturbing
there were dead humans and animals
floating all over the place missing
their eyes as though they'd been scooped
out and missing their mouths as though
they'd been bitten out of their face by
some kind of huge Predator their empty
eye sockets bled constantly and S
theorized that this may have something
to do with the anomalous blood Mists of
SCP 1861 when asked to provide more
information on why all the corpses were
mutilated in this way s said that one of
his superiors on the winter shimer told
him the Watcher of eyes and biter of
teeth deemed them worthy whatever this
mysterious being was it seemed to be a
powerful figure within 1861 Water World
and S Felt lucky that he never had a
direct runin with the creature himself
for his final request Dr clutch asked s
to attempt to remove his suit the
foundation had learned in previous
instances of 1861 that the diving suits
have anomalous durability and it was
impossible for anyone other than the
wearer to remove them hence why the
foundation could never deal with 1861 DB
by using Brute Force naturally clutch
was interested in finding out what was
going on underneath s expressed fear and
anxiety at first wondering if after all
he'd been through whether he could ever
be considered human anymore eventually
he was convinced to remove the suit and
his worst fears were confirmed the
second s removed his helmet gallons of
sea water poured out and the now empty
suit collapsed to the ground s's body
was never found only some teeth and a
pair of eyes were recovered the eyes
were later confirmed to be belonging to
a young girl and the teeth were
identified as having come from a
European Red Deer and so the dark
mystery of the HMS winter shimer
continues because of the unpredictable
nature of its appearances and the
resulting difficulty of containing it
the winter shimer has earned a ker
classification the the only containment
procedure currently employed by the SCP
Foundation is for mobile task forces to
try and intercept the submarine when
appearances are reported and hopefully
prevent or at least reduce the
kidnapping of civilians with so many
questions left unanswered all we can say
for certain is that if a Red Mist ever
descends on you and a stranger in a
diving suit tells you you're in grave
danger he's absolutely right it is
certainly not unheard of for a young
girl to wake up in the the middle of the
night looking for a glass of water it is
somewhat more exceptional when this late
night water Run results in many many
deaths unless of course you're dealing
with a very special young girl SCP 053
also known as well the young girl she
possesses the innate ability to inspire
delusions paranoia and eventually
homicidal rage in anyone who spends too
long around her which as you can
probably imagine makes it hard to live a
normal life one night the young girl
woke up to something incredibly strange
the door of her cell typically tightly
sealed was wide open and a strange
flashing red light was shining in
through the hallway the sound of a
distant alarm is what had woken her up
what the young girl didn't know was that
the site confining her had just
experienced a mass Containment Breach as
a result of a major electrical
malfunction some of the most terrifying
creatures imaginable were roaming the
halls in search of violence and Carn
but when the young girl got up and
wandered out of her bedroom she only
wanted a glass of water to quench her
midnight thirst she wandered down a long
plain hallway washed intermittently and
R by the red flashing emergency lights
she robbed the sleep out of her eyes and
yawned all this strange commotion maybe
she's just having a bad dream but what
seems like a bad dream to her is a
Bonafide living nightmare for everyone
around her a few Halls over security
Personnel were being devoured powered
Alive by SCP 682 SCP 106 the old man had
just dragged a senior researcher into
his pocket Dimension to do unspeakable
things to him and a group of terrified
admin staff are being lured out by what
they think is a group of mobile task
force operatives but is actually a pack
of hungry SCP 939 imitating their voices
still the young girl persisted in her
quest for a refreshing drink even as
security Personnel began to Fan out
through the building hoping to get
control over this rapidly devolving
situation A group of five armed security
officers ran into the hallway and
attempted to intercept the young girl
but the high stress they were feeling
was only accelerated by the effects of
the young girl's anomalous Powers they
started to feel bugs crawling all over
their skin they started to get the sense
that their fellow security officers
weren't even people but monsters wearing
human skin suits their paranoia soon
evolved into a blistering rage
each of the men pulled out their guns
and began firing at each other until
only one was left standing wounded but
alive with all the others dead the
object of his rage now became the young
girl herself he understood then that it
was all her doing that she made him do
this she was a monstrous little creature
who took pleasure in twisting the minds
of human beings into terrible forms in
reality the young girl had no such
feelings her powers were pass
she had no control over them she even
suffered from some kind of strange
mental block that left her completely
unaware that her powers were even taking
a fact she was in a sense completely
innocent as the security officer pointed
his gun at the young girl as she began
walking into a nearby breakroom he
experienced her secondary anomalous
effect anyone who attempts to hurt her
will immediately die from either a heart
attack or a stroke the security officer
suddenly felt an intend pain sharp and
brutal exploding in his chest he
collapsed dead before he even hit the
ground and the young girl had no idea
she couldn't if she tried in the break
room the young girl found exactly what
she was looking for a classic office
water cooler complete with a stack of
plastic cups perfect she carefully took
one of the cups and pulled down the
lever on the cooler watching her cup
fill as the tank above the cooler
bubbled she took a sip cool Refreshing
Spring Water just what the doctor
ordered but the young girl suddenly
looked up shocked to see that the tank
above the water cooler was now shaking
violently as though it was going to
explode what was going on here had she
broken it she stepped back dropping the
rest of her cup of water to the ground
she felt frightened that's when a crack
formed in the plastic tank and the water
began slithering out not dripping or
pouring slithering as though it had
moved with mind and purpose and that's
because in this case it did the young
girl hadn't just drank any water she had
drunk half a cup of water from SCP
054 the water nymph a mysterious
sentient Woman made entirely from water
much like the young girl the water nymph
is often a misunderstood anomaly one
that has received far more harm from the
cruel treatment of the SCP Foundation
than she's ever given to another she's a
naturally curious and compassionate
creature whose trust has been abused so
when the contained alarm started to
sound much like the rest of the
foundation staff she had tried to hide
and find cover not wanting to fall into
the crosshairs of a far more dangerous
and hostile anomaly she had chosen the
water cooler in break room 3 which
seemed like a genius idea until the
young girl turned up after years of
being experimented on by Foundation
researchers the water nymph wasn't just
about to tolerate more mistreatment
whatever this strange little creature
was who had just consumed some of her
body the water nymph would fight back
and make it regret ever thinking that it
could take advantage of her the young
girl who really had just made an
innocent mistake began to panic and run
as frightening slithering tendrils of
pure water came slithering after her as
the unfortunate security guard
discovered earlier trying to attack the
young girl was typically a one-way
ticket to a heart attack or fatal
cerebral event but seeing as the water
nymph had neither a heart nor a brain
she was invulnerable and the young girl
was terrified she ran out of the room
past the bodies of the men who had
killed each other due to her influence
outside she wasn't even able to notice
them she kept running and the water of
the water nymph came slithering after
her the water nymph had never been the
vengeful type but after the abuse she'd
suffered she learned the value of
putting her liquid foot down she would
not tolerate mistreatment even from a
being this small the young girl kept
running Breathing heavily because of the
nature of her anomalous abilities nobody
could intervene and help her
occasionally she had run into groups of
foundation Personnel trying to fight
their way through the chaos only to be
anomalously affected and become part of
the chaos themselves they became violent
deranged monsters and started attacking
each other punching and biting as they
fell to the ground in a brawling pile
the young girl had to desperately climb
over them as the streak of furious
liquid followed her meanwhile across the
facility The Vicious Psych apathic old
man was hungry for more his mouth
stretched into a wide sadistic grin and
he continued walking further into the
base he would find new victims he would
feel their fear and drink in their dying
screams several mobile task forces were
dispatch from other nearby containment
facilities they'd likely reach the
embattled site within the hour but how
many lives would be lost before then the
death count was already well into the
double digits after all this running the
young girl was getting tired it was rare
that she needed to truly avoid and
escape a threat like this and as such
she wasn't exactly prepared for such a
scenario she found her way into a broom
closet and locked herself inside hiding
among mops and brooms she tried to quiet
her breathing holding a tiny hand over
her mouth red flashes continued to
occasionally illuminate the corners of
the door she breathed in and out in and
out with something waiting outside the
young girl gasped as water started bub
Ling underneath the door it started
looking around her feet then rising up
from the ground to the young girl it was
astonishing the water was forming the
shape of a woman standing right in front
of her her lower lip trembled with fear
for a moment she was at a loss for words
then she gulped dry and began to speak
in a soft little voice I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to hurt you I promise I was
just thirsty the water nymph tilted her
head slightly confused did this tiny
child really mean this
was it an honest mistake after all the
terrible things that had been done to
her the water nymph had difficulty
trusting humans but as the young girl
started to cry for reasons she couldn't
quite understand the water nymph felt
the urge to comfort her perhaps she
wasn't with the foundation perhaps this
girl was just another prisoner they were
allies not enemies while the water nymph
couldn't speak as a show of solidarity
she began to transform she got smaller
herself becoming a little girl made of
water almost mirroring SCP 053 she
raised a hand and waved the young girl
giggled seemingly put at ease it' been a
long time since she met a new friend
around here and it seemed like the water
nymph was ready to change that maybe
they could escape this place together
the young girl opened the door and the
two of them ran out together passing
through an adjacent hallway the young
girl ran while the water nymph slithered
formless along behind her they managed
to sneak around and avoid detection
ction from the many anomalies and
Foundation guards duking it out for
Supremacy in the chaotic Halls of the
facility in a sense it provided the
perfect cover for the unlikely Duo to
escape this bizarre situation but they
weren't out of the metaphorical woods
yet first they were cornered by a trio
of paranoid guards all wielding handguns
however the young girl's nightmarish
ambient ability came in handy once more
the three men lost their minds and
started killing each other giving the
young girl and the water nymph more time
to escape and keep moving though they
were about to encounter the deadliest
threat of all the young girl took Point
leading the water nymph down the nearest
hallway when suddenly SCP 106 the old
man emerged from the wall right in front
of her he had such a nomess malice in
him that the young girl's Powers was
effectively useless against him he
grinned and approached her his arms
extended ready to F her off to the
nightmare of his pocket Dimension the
young girl had never felt so afraid
until suddenly the water nymph slithered
in between them and she assumed her full
humanoid form once more forming a wall
between the young girl and the old man
this turned out to be the perfect way to
save the young girl's life scp-106 has
historically found liquid barriers
incredibly confusing and it's been
widely considered to be one of the few
ways to effectively delay the old man's
Rampages seizing the moment the young
girl turned and ran away the water nymph
had just saved her life
sadly for them neither the water nymph
nor the young girl escaped that day the
mobile task forces arrived and took
control of the facility again
recontained the various anomalies who
had escaped but even if they never saw
each other again the water nymph and the
young girl would forever remember how
they helped each other on that
incredibly strange day it's the late
'90s and an Air Canada flight
experiences severe malfunctions while
traveling from London to Vancouver the
pilots are unable to do anything in the
plane crashes into the woods of Northern
Alberta the crash was devastating only
10 of the nearly 300 people on board are
alive and even though they survived the
initial disaster their battle for life
has only just begun it's late autumn in
Northern Canada and there's no telling
when help will arrive if at all if the
survivors want to make it through the
night they need to find shelter and fast
as they trudge through the freezing
Woods the group finds a path that looks
like it might lead them to civilization
after all if there was a path in the
woods that meant they were probably in a
national park and if they were in a
national park there had to be a ranger
station around somewhere where they
could warm up and call for help they
didn't have many other options so they
followed the path which opened up to a
clearing but instead of finding a ranger
station or Campground they found
something none of them could have
expected it was a pond but there was
something off about it as they got
closer they saw that this strange Pond
wasn't filled with water but blood the
survivors were horrified that couldn't
really be blood could it it must have
been a weird allergy or chemical
reaction but one member of the group a
man named Thomas Dean who had been on
his way back to his hometown of Prince
George British Columbia thought there
was something strangely familiar about
this he remembered being a boy and going
to visit family in Alberta and hearing
an urban legend from the older local
kids according to the stories somewhere
out in the wilderness in the northern
part of the province there was a pond
full of human blood and what made it
even worse was that some said the pond
was a gateway to Hell the sccp
foundation was also aware of this Legend
and had been trying to pinpoint the
exact source of it for decades prior to
the Air Canada crash they would finally
receive definite confirmation of the
blood Pond when Foundation Personnel
intercepted a radio transmission from a
ranger station located within the Wood
Buffalo national park it was the
survivors of the crash who had managed
to make it through the night and they
were about to be escorted out of the
park by Rangers the foundation mobilized
quickly to cordon off the pond as at the
time there were unsure of what
potentially harmful properties the pond
might have had they set up watch station
Epsilon 38 and put staff on guard to
deter travelers from the area the pond
was given the designation of SCP 354 and
classed as uid Foundation scientists
made a number of interesting discoveries
about SCP 354 when they collected
samples for testing first the p was not
in fact full of blood merely an
inorganic liquid that closely resembles
blood in color and consistency second
and even Stranger Than The Red liquid is
that the pond doesn't seem to have any
definite Banks or a bottom instead the
liquid in the pond increases in density
as the radius away from the center
increases the liquid congeals at the
edges becoming more solid and blending
into the surrounding soil it also
becomes thicker as one descends deeper
into the pool and the bottom of the pond
has not yet been reached if it even
exists initially the foundation found no
signs of life within the blood Pond but
that would all change at 203 p.m. on the
day following the opening of Watch
Station Epsilon 38 when the science team
noticed an unusual level of activity on
the pond surface security footage feed
showed a shape rising out of the pond
followed by a deafening shriek after
that the feed was cut and Foundation
lost all communication with watch
station Epsilon 38 fearing the worst a
mobile task force was dispatched to the
location when they got there all
Personnel at the watch station had been
killed by what could only be described
as a gigantic bat the task force was
able to neutralize the entity and as
soon as they could the foundation moved
in to increase security around the SCP
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail after this
point the pond started to regularly spit
out a variety of monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP
foundation's increased security measures
after SCP 3541 the giant bat came SCP
3542 3542 was an aidel likee monster the
size of a bear that was virtually
bulletproof but unable to escape area
354 the foundation neutralized this
anomaly with Napal SCP 3543 was a
floating black sphere capable of firing
deadly beams of concentrated energy the
area's head scientist was able to hit it
with a sledgehammer causing the sphere
to malfunction and self-destruct before
it was able to escaped the area the
foundation wasn't as lucky with SCP
3544 this creature was a reptilian
humanoid that stood roughly 15 ft tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first Creature from
the pond to successfully Escape
containment and was only able to be
neutralized when the foundation sent in
Mobile task force Omega 7 also known as
Pandora's Box the data on Pond
incursions is partially corrupted so a
complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood Pond include
a killer robot a set of gigantic
tentacles that drag several d-class
Personnel into the pond a pair of
panther-like creatures one made of ice
and the other of magma that ignored
Foundation staff and instead fought each
other and one seemingly normal human man
who was executed as soon as he emerged
from the pond tests on his body revealed
that he was in fact totally normal and
would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months the head
scientist at the time noted I suspect
this means one of two things either the
red pool has died or powered down or
whatever the correct term for it is or
is charging up for something big to come
through ofi believes the former is the
most likely explanation and has recalled
30% of our total personnel and cut 25%
of our funding while I can only hope
that they are correct if the latter
situation is true we're soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it I worry for all of our
safety his words would prove eily
prophetic following the events of
exploratory Mission 354 Alpha the
foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to
explore the pond because of the strange
properties of the Pond's density the
craft was essentially made to be both a
submarine for parts of the pond where
the contents were liquid and a drill for
when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom the
exploration team consisted of agent
Swanson agent turquoise agent 86 Dr J
MacArthur Chris Simmons Leroy Tucker and
a pilot named Martin with the team
assembled the ship was sent down into
the pond nothing eventful happened for
the first 2 days of the mission but at
4:30 a.m. on the 3D day gravity suddenly
reversed for the crew of the ship this
seemed to indicate that they were
approaching the halfway point though
what would be on the other side nobody
could say on the fourth day the ship
surfaced proving definitely that the
pond was in fact some sort of portal the
crew looked out of the port holes to see
the darkness of night above them while
sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them the crew were wary of exiting the
craft the other side of the pond was
nothing like the world the crew knew for
one thing the night lasted for 28 hours
before Dawn came and when the Sun
finally Rose it was much larger and
redder than the Earth's sun under the
light of the strange red star the crew
could see the that the pond on this side
was massive compared to what they've
come into more like a large lake
surrounding the lake was sand and rocks
that were covered in a kind of moss that
disappeared under sunlight and regrew
during the night the team left the ship
and started to explore during their time
in This Strange World they found that
the day lasted just a few hours shorter
than the night meaning that whatever
Planet they were on had a roughly 43h
long rotation as opposed to our own
planets 24 the team found a number of
anomalous elements on their their
expedition including razor sharp grass
that can puncture skin and streams of
liquid carbon dioxide they heard some
loud Roars in the distance once or twice
but other than that the planet was
eerily silent with seemingly no animal
life and not even wind when it rained
the soil remained dry and based on that
the scientists theorized the plants in
this world were more efficient at
absorbing moisture on the 25th day the
team ran into a huge metal wall that
appeared to be artificially constructed
luckily Leroy Tucker a quick- thinking
researcher was able to rig a blowtorch
from camping supplies and melt a hole
through the metal on the other side
there was finally wind and odd black
grass that's the extent of what is known
about the other side of the wall because
the Expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point but we know
that whatever was in there wasn't good
because the team never returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log almost as if
being killed on the other side
completely erased them from history no
other Expeditions into the pond were
launched after that on an undisclosed
date a year following the discovery of
the blood Pond and construction of area
354 the site was completely evacuated
and power was cut to the area mobile
task force data 12 was dispatched to
investigate the cause of the evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated completely destroying the site
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a
convoy made up of d-class and other
low-ranking staff who had evacuated ated
area 354 it was apparent that there had
been some kind of mutiny within the site
and that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction the Convoy totally
annihilated MTF data 12 and no further
contact with the former Personnel of
area 354 has been made since following
the site's detonation a new site was
constructed called simply the red poool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research and
neutralization the new site is entirely
concerned turned with containment the
shift and directive came as a response
to the Pond's apparent reactive nature
each creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's actions and it was
theorized by some that the Mutiny at
area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself an
interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous
attempt to control and understand the
blood Pond according to an interview
with a foundation agent the head doctor
proposed a scheme to drain the blood
Pond using a system of pumps and hoses
all non-essential Personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency leaving
only the pump technicians d-class
personnel and a few agents for security
however as soon as the pump was
scheduled to be turned on everyone at
the side experienced a mass dissociative
episode the agent described the feeling
they all experienced as like being in a
dream and suddenly realizing that you're
asleep he said everything stopped being
real it was like we had to Escape right
now when asked what happened and when
the pump was turned on he simply
explained that it wouldn't let them this
interview confirmed the theory that the
pond is not only capable of releasing
monsters out into our world but also
that it's capable of powerful but much
more subtle psychological attacks this
suggests a chilling possibility that the
pond isn't just blindly reacting to
being attacked but it's fully sentient
and the actions of the SCP Foundation
have only served to annoy it and worst
studies of the ponds banks have proved
evidence that the area of congealed
liquid around the perimeter of the pond
has been steadily expanding that's right
the pond is getting bigger the last
thing the foundation agent stationed at
the site said before being dragged out
of the interview and sedated was it gets
bigger and stronger every day and now
we've made it angry boom on May 12th
2588 the town of Kangas Greenland was
destroyed by a devastating 4 kiloton
explosion accompanied by a massive
electromagnetic pulse the few survivors
that made it through the incident alive
described seeing a pale green light in
the area at the time of the explosion
shortly after an omka class scenario or
end of death scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inex explicable
occurrence as the Panic mounted the 05
Council of the sccp foundation held an
emergency meeting in order to address
the possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world 05- one made a
statement to the UN regarding the
reality of the worldwide anomaly
advising citizens to remain calm and
await further instructions 5 days after
the world learned the truth of the SCP
Foundation the pale monster arrived in
St John's New Finland where it was met
by mobile task force new7 hammer down
for what they hoped would be a quick
fight and neutralization instead 2 years
of devast daating bloody combat ensued
by July 4th 2590 90% of the Task Force
personnel had been killed and
regenerated an average of five times at
this point MTF news7 abandoned the city
of St John citing anomalously poor
working conditions after being held in
place for 2 years the monster was able
to break through the defensive line and
continue its Rampage on October 10th
2590 the SCP Foundation and the global
ult Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated SCP
ubu and stopping its reign of terror but
project Beluga was unable to neutralize
the entity before it reached Columbus
Ohio on December 29th 2590 once it
arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a 2 km
deep hole in the city's Center next it
gathered a total of 2.9 Million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly 1 year
and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow board with Columbus and
moved to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10th
2670 when SCP ubu was contained at SCP
Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted for 2 minutes at
which point The Entity escaped and made
its way to New York City where it was
found howling and attempted to defile
the Statue of Liberty several countries
used their nuclear arsenals to attack as
CPU over the course of its Rampage until
this connectic agreement was signed on
February 10th
2674 cementing an agreement between NATO
Powers the Russian Federation the
People's Republic of China and the
global occult Coalition all signatories
agreed that due to concerns around the
environment any additional nuclear
strikes against the entity would be
prohibited after the signing was
finished SCP ubu crashed the ceremony
grabbing several lengths of rebar and 15
foreign dignitaries which it used to
construct itself a bead necklace the
next notable incident occurred when SCP
ubu showed up at site 19 interrupting a
round of testing with SC SCP AF a woman
capable of turning matter into Stone by
speaking to it SCP ubu broke through the
ceiling crushing AFF beneath its weight
SCP 682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
U responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at SCP 682 in gibberish SCP 682
seemed to understand this vocalization
and attacked SCP ubu demanding that it
take back the insult at this point SCP
ubu slapped 682s cheek causing 682 to
let out a horrific Scream the slap left
behind a glowing green Mark which spread
over the entity of 682s body before
breaking the bonds of its cells all at
once dissolving the reptile into a pool
of toxic fluid SCP ubu then spent 5
minutes bathing in this fluid while
giggling after finishing its bath
devouring the reconstituted SCP and
screaming into the microphone for 20
minutes SCP U broke into armed
containment area 179 and swallowed SCP
2317 whole on March 5th 2686 SCP ubu
conducted an assault on Thal class SCP
2000 rendering it neutralized again
years of Hell passed as project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods
that had not already been exhausted
meanwhile civilians did their best to
find ways to cope with the state of the
world on March 25th 2750 former film
star Nash degut published the zon
Manifesto a book based around a simple
principle life on Earth was no longer
worth living consciously and the only
way formed was to enter an eternal coma
through the combination of chemicals and
guided meditation this kickstarted the
social movement the international zon on
June 24th 2790 project Beluga forces
managed to drive SCP ubu into the Bay of
Bengal where it remained for 3 years
causing very little trouble aside from
underwater seismic events meanwhile the
international continued to grow and one
massive adherence known as cutopia
reached its goal of 5 million residents
on June 10th
2793 SCP ubu flung SCP 3000 out of the
ocean leaving it beached on the soil of
India several cities were destroyed in
this process The Entity then spent a
week pointing and laughing at The
Beached sea monster before grabbing it
by the tip of its tail and beginning to
drag it across Asia SCP ubu continued
car in a path through Asia the wriggling
SCP 3000 in tow until it reached the
bearing straight then it began to cross
the straight into Alaska returning to
North American territory once more but
it didn't stop there instead advancing
toward South America until it and SCP
3000 arrived on the eastern coast of
Brazil on August 29th
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
2017 93 SCP 169 or the Leviathan emerged
from the depths of the ocean there are
some reports that SCP 3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between SCP ubu and SCP 169 came to a
halt much as it had with SCP 682 SCP ubu
slapped SCP 169 across the face with
such force that its cell bonds dissolved
and it melted into a puddle of fluid
which was lost beneath the ocean waves
scp-69 was reclassified neutralized
December 11th 3020 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for SCP ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's
centuries of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international zon movement
has persisted gaining more and more
traction and popularity as conscious
life became less and less bearable an
enormous floating zon pile consisting of
international zon followers using
anomalous methods to achieve the perfect
zon began to form eventually this pile
earned the nickname new zland by May
28th 3028 the archipelago was abandoned
and the 140 remaining conscious humans
retreated to the SCP foundation's scps
naith there they lived in relative
safety for several months until SCP ubu
was spotted in the water off the port
bow of the naysmith on January 14th 3030
it emitted several sounds that Witnesses
described as mocking before swimming off
towards new zonin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the 05 Council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all of our anomolous options
for neutralizing ubu where's the corn
crake we've been overse sorence soing
the corn C in this mess is only going to
it is anchored 57 clicks due Southeast
for why the hell did you tell him that
well friends it seems the the Omega K
has had us up in about so long that our
personalities have run out of fuel we
were given from birth in all likelihood
we'd see better professionalism and
teamwork in new zland as a matter of
fact that's a good segue into what I was
about to propose and frankly I hope you
find the nicest cleanest spots in the
mass grave where are you going that
depends which way is southeast at this
point 05-11 left the room presumably to
track down the corn CR leaving the
remains of the 05 Council there and
leaving the remains of project Beluga
with the question of how to handle SCP
ubu according to its official SCP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12th 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength and speed as
well as reality bending capabilities and
the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the end of death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extradimensional
human organization based in SCP 2922 DC
or the afterlife known as corbenic this
organization was founded 14,000 years
ago with the purpose of establishing a
human colony in the afterlife and has
long maintained a peace treaty with the
SCP Foundation SCP
2922 a method of communication that
allowed a human mind to make calls to
any pre-established phone number ceased
all functions next the extradimensional
space known as The Wanderer Library a
magical Archive of all the knowledge
from all known worlds and every book
that has ever been written will be
written and several that have not and
will not exist was severed from Earth
when the SCP Foundation pressed the
Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that the
reconcilable security concerns regarding
Earth had come up and forced them to
make this decision a representative of
Marshall Carter and dark limited somehow
gained access to the personal contact
information of the 05 council's members
and used this information to reach out
to them with a business offer the
company is ordinarily on unfriendly
terms with the SCP Foundation due to
their conflicting interests namely
Marshall Carter and dark's interests in
acquiring and selling anomalous items
entities and exper iences to the highest
bidder however in this case the
company's representative approached 05
council members with a mixture of
politeness and Desperation begging the
SCP Foundation to purchase large amounts
of the company's stock the forest known
as SCP 4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and
disconcerting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with SCP ubu's first first
appearance was what happened to SCP 3008
the infinite Ikea though this sort of
thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ikea branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combined to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was SCP uu it
appears to be impervious to most forms
of damage including blunt force trauma
heavy caliber machine gun fire
temperatures up to, 1600° Kelvin
artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that the only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SCP ubu was on August
14th 2784 in which the entity bit its
left thumb seemingly for no reason other
than curiosity after biting it thumb The
Entity screen for 7 days straight then
entered into a month-long crying fit 30
years and 14 days later the thumb had
completely healed SCP ubu stands at a
height of 4.3 M while an exact measure
of its weight is unknown a tempet
measurement during its brief time in
containment showed that its weight is at
least
15399 kg its exact anatomical
composition is unknown but a superficial
examination of the entity indicates that
its body shape resembles that of a large
androgenous humanoid covered in hairless
white skin similar in texture to that of
a dolphin or small whale The Entity has
no eyes ears or nostrils but seems to
still possess the ability to see hear
and smell it's only visible sensory
organ aside from its skin is its5 M wide
mouth humanoid in nature with a
prehensile tongue of unknown length on
its lower body it has no apparent
features aside from a kowa that it uses
to dispose of waste SCP ubu is prone to
vocalizations mainly screaming laughing
and babbling but it does not appear to
understand speech in any known language
nor does it seem to be attempting to
communicate with anyone it encounters
its primary interest appears to be
destruction and causing as much of it as
possible it will attack anything that it
can get its hands on but seems to show a
particular preference for attacking and
consuming human beings in large populous
areas such as cities it's deme is both
sadistic and childlike and it has been
seen playing with its victims for hours
before moving on to a new Target due to
its regenerative effect present in SCP
ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted it
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
be project Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it will be the
staunch efforts of one extremely
dedicated researcher on May 12th 2588
The Entity known as SCP ubu manifested
in Kangas Greenland like something out
of the most nightmarish Kaiju movie
never made soon after there was no more
death but the world was filled with such
chaos and despair that Humanity longed
for that Eternal release from its
enormous stomping feet to its cloa to
its face featureless save for a gaping
grinning devouring mouth The Entity was
pure malice with all the time in the
world ubu decimated the planet breaking
the spirit of mankind and raising every
city to the ground in the earlier days
of ubu's invasion when there was still
dry land and people still wanted to talk
to each other rather than joining
floating islands of Eternal chemically
induced Slumber they would commiserate
about the shared misery of the state of
things oh UVU my daughter hasn't spoken
to me ever since that monster shoved my
whole body down her throat someone would
say another would pipe up trying to one
up the first man in sort of a trauma
Olympics
didn't you see me in the news ubu
carried me around for a week snacking on
me every now and then like I was his own
personal Turkey Leg it was hell but
honestly part of me felt a little bummed
out when he threw me away yet another
person would chime in like veterans
swapping War Stories over a drink at the
bar ubu made me eat a pair of my pants
whole thing zipper and all then he
decided he thought that was funny made
me eat pair after pair after pair of
them rinse and repeat by the time he got
bored I'd eaten probably around 20 Pairs
and sort of got a taste for them after
that everyone on the planet had good
reason to despise
scpu but no one held more hate in his
heart for the pale Wicked creature than
Dr Lawrence mikal before the world was
turned upside down sometimes literally
Dr moud was a member of the mysterious
05 council at the SCP Foundation to be
specific he was
05-11 but that prestigious position at
the foundation couldn't protect him or
his loved ones from the r of ubu when Dr
moud was off duty ubu attacked him and
his wife first it impaled his wife on a
broom handle next it threw Dr moud into
an open pool of sewage in the street
then it bathed him in the filthy water
using his screaming wife as a scrubbing
brush all the while whistling a horrible
little bathtub song Centuries after that
awful experience as Dr mow watched most
of his colleagues give up and choose the
closest thing to death in this broken
world he became even more determined to
do something about it on January 14th
3030 Dr moud abandoned the scps naith
and his fellow 0 council members in
search of the scps Corn crate an
abandoned craft to the southeast it
wasn't an easy Journey rowing all the
way there in a Lifeboat never knowing
when the Great White Beast would emerge
from the water and choose him as its
next unfortunate play thing he could see
the scps corn cek still floating there
untouched but before he could row any
closer something collided with the
lifebo From Below snapping it in half Dr
macau's stomach dropped at the sight of
pale flesh but it was soon replaced with
relief when he saw that the thing that
had broken his lifebo was not in fact
ubu it was an injured narwhal behaving
erratically due to its wounds the
culprit was almost certainly UVU it
wasn't content to just torment humans
but instead must have been targeting any
life form that could feel pain and fear
in his own words Dr moud had put it at
least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal after the life
boat broke apart moud swam to the conre
exhaustion and cold straining his
muscles it took him 2 hours to reach the
abandoned cargo barge and containment
site but eventually he managed to climb
up over the side and get on board there
was one very special thing about the
corn crate the thing that made it worth
crossing the ocean in a fragile little
Lifeboat to find every anomaly that made
the gamed list the list of anomalies
considered too dangerous to abandon even
in an apocalyptic scenario was contained
on the corn crate if there was anything
left that the foundation or anyone else
hadn't tried to use to defeat ubu it
would be on that ship after taking a
little while to recover Dr moud embarked
on an initial exploration of The Craft
all the staff were gone as he had
expected thankfully he still had his 05
ID card and it still worked like a charm
unlocking all of the automated security
systems on board a lot of what he found
was in Ruins but some things had
survived he found 10 hominid replicators
from SCP 2000 in perfect working order
there was a cage containing the remains
of SCP 2845 the deer though ubu had done
significant damage to it SCP 319 a
curious device was there contained in
the space locked vacuum chamber this one
was notable for its potential ability to
destroy the universe he found a couple
of safe class anomalies such as SCP yez
crowd control for the Practical Optimist
and SCP FNA the portable warehouse the
latter of the two was a portable door
frame to a pocket Dimension he also
stumbled upon SCP 001 Last Ride of the
day an old Prometheus Labs prototype of
a time machine and possibly most
importantly he found SCP
076 the coffin was open but Abel didn't
attack Dr maoud he wasn't consumed with
murderous rage and blood lust the way he
always was before instead he was just
sitting on the edge of the ship silently
staring at the sea when he spotted moud
he gave him a small wave and did nothing
else the centuries of a world without
death a world without killing without
victory in battle had taken its toll on
him for possibly the first time in his
eternal life Abel was depressed N9 days
after he first inspected the corn CR mik
began to formulate a plan he loaded all
the hominid receptors into SCP FNA using
a thankfully still working forklift next
he was able to unseal the sealed portion
of SCP 001 Last Ride of the day and get
his hands on the details of the anomaly
it read SCP 001 is capable of temporally
relocating to its relative position
15,000 years prior to activation this
temporal displacement is Divergent
Paradox irrelevant relevant in other
words a separate timeline is created as
a landing point for example if an
occupant from timeline X were to murder
their parents in utero in Timeline y the
Y iteration of the occupant would no
longer exist but the occupant themselves
being from X would be unharmed when in a
fully active State SCP 001 deploys a 5
met High telescopic antenna that
functions as a coloo wave energy syn
essentially coloo waves could only be
produced as a byproduct of the universe
suddenly being exterminated and ZK class
reality failures produced the most Colo
waves in one of these scenarios SCP 001
would be able to use these waves to go
back in time 15,000 years effectively
resetting reality to a point far before
the catastrophe happened this
information allowed him to put his plan
together to resurrect project Beluga
step one plant explosive charges around
SCP 319 step two hide anything
potentially useful against SCP ubu
inside of SCP FNA step three get into
the cockpit with SCP FNA and Tow step
four raise the Colo sink and step five
blow the whole thing up 3 days later it
was time to put the plan into motion Dr
moud placed the charges around SCP 319s
vacuum chamber there was enough in place
to implode the walls of the vacuum
chamber he closed the bulkhead and began
deploying the Colo sink 10% 25% 30%
suddenly he could hear a loud crashing
sound the ship began to tilt oh no he
could hear the distant sound of menacing
Giggles the sync reached 45 57 but as
ubu grew closer he quickly overrode the
system to lower the sink 45% 30% 25% 10%
ubu grew closer and closer and as it
approached it began to whistle the tune
it once used when it bathed moud and his
wife in the sewer ubu began to pound
against the blast door becoming
increasingly frustrated as it struggled
to break through suddenly another voice
cut through the air an unexpected one
SCP 076 Abel called out to maod
encouraging him to carry on while Abel
held the Beast back as Abel and ubu
engaged in an epic battle maoud suddenly
remembered something there was an
Express deployment module for the col Co
syn with no time to waste he activated
it all at once he hit the Detonator and
then the year was
11,970 and the date was February 14th
13,960 years later the SCP Foundation
discovered something beneath a mound of
Earth and snow near the northern border
of Lapland Finland it was a shipping
container with a reinforced exterior the
interior of which could only be accessed
through a fortified bulkhead on one side
the words SCP 001 were written on the
side in black paint in spite of this the
object was given the designation as CP
848 a narrow winding tunnel through the
mound of Earth and snow was discovered
leading from the door to the outside
world the tunnel had significant wear
clearly having been used as a foot path
by someone but who well on April 12th
1993 the foundation got their answer SCP
848 bulkhead opened and a man stepped
out snapping his fingers and promptly
sealing the door behind him he was
designated Pole 8048 he was a
32-year-old man of French Canadian
descent answering to the name of Dr
Lawrence moud he made a series of claims
that the foundation found dubious but
noted it in the official file for SCP
848 just the same these included but
were not limited to SCP 848 is a time
machine he held the office of 05-11 in
the year 3030 from an alternate timeline
said timeline experienced a modified
Omega K class endof death scenario that
coincided with the inv invasion of a
Tiamat class anomaly known as SCP ubu
SCP ubu was an extremely dangerous and
sadistic entity who was capable of among
other things neutralizing SCP 169 and
SCP 682 his timelines version of the
foundation launched project Beluga which
resulted in an impossible war with SCP
ubu that lasted 441 years Paul 848
deliberately sabotaged SCP 319 to act as
a power source for SC CP 848 thus
arriving in Lapland in the year
11,970 BCE SC SCP ubu will arrive in
Greenland on May 12th
2588 Paul 848 was able to extend his
lifespan by sharing his Consciousness
between a central computer with an SCP
848 and several thousand bodies created
by his personal hominid replicators said
Consciousness sharing was achieved
through a book classified in the future
as SCP yez he wishes to assist the
foundation in the termination of SCP ubu
and has laid out a plan for its
termination as outlined in document 8
48- Zeta there were of course concerns
about the man's legitimacy but after
moud mentioned over 104 specific terms
and data points known only to members of
the 05 Council the foundation was forced
to take him at least a little bit
seriously a motion was filed requesting
that poll 848 be allowed to assist the
foundation with the termination of SCP
ubu as document 8848 dzeta 054 voted yay
057 abstained and the rest of the
council voted nay the motion failed to
pass a follow-up motion was filed in
response requesting that poll 8048 be
allowed to assist the foundation with
their own strategy to respond to SCP ubu
05-10 5-4 057 and 05-10 abstained from
voting the rest voted nay the motion
failed to pass on April 14th 1995 Dr
Isaiah Henderson and pole 848 sat down
for an interview when asked to State his
name Dr mcau also recited a mimic
passphrase that when spoken by anyone
other than 05-11 of past or present
would cause them to burst into flames
the two men were at odds from the
beginning Dr Macau expressed dismay and
frustration that his proposal was
rejected meanwhile Dr Henderson
countered with the insistence that
macau's proposed plan was rejected for
posing an unnecessary risk to the
civilian in public they debated for a
moment before Dr Henderson announced the
foundation's next plan of action Dr moud
was to be terminated the foundation
would proceed with its plans without him
at that point Dr Henderson terminated
moud as ordered he didn't count on one
thing though moud was no longer an
ordinary man bound to one body he hopped
into the body of a guard then into the
body of 0 5-4 to deliver a vital message
he had started this plan alone and was
ready to bring it to a close alone
project Beluga would continue with or
without the foundation's support Dr
Macau returned to the bulkhead climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him he
had hoped to have the foundation behind
him he had hoped they would be allies in
the fight against the greatest evil
mankind ever encountered but they
disappointed him he had waited thousands
of years only for the organization he
devoted his life to to try and kill him
well he wasn't going to go down without
a fight this was bigger than the
foundation bigger than anyone and no
living person was as equipped to handle
ubu as he was so he resumed project
Beluga as a one-man operation he issued
a mission statement which read as
follows on May 12th 2588 The Entity
known as SCP ubu invaded and pillaged
human civilization for no other
motivation than cruelty and selfish
gratification shortly thereafter project
Beluga was founded as a joint effort
between the goblo cult Coalition and the
SCP Foundation for the purposes of ubu's
Destruction ubu is not merely a threat
to human safety he's an affront to every
positive and loving Concept in the human
consciousness rather than our lives he
seeks to destroy our quality of life to
Safe his own sick desires think about it
the taste of ice cream playing with your
dog the way you felt after your first
kiss that is yubu sworn Enemy No fate is
too crol for him no hatred is strong
enough when project Beluga Charter was
ass sign 592 gocc officers and
Foundation staff were present at the
ceremony our troops numbered in the
hundreds of thousands I Dr Lin moud am
the only surviving member and always
will be what I lack in numbers is
compensated thousandfold by my weapons
my mind my replicated bodies and the ons
of experience the following record
serves one purpose alone that once
justice has been brought to ubu humans
in The Shining and golden ubu fre future
will understand that one person can
accomplish through the power of hard
science and ra motion entwined in a
perfect and indestructible braid and
while we are at it you are very welcome
over the next several hundred years mow
worked to secure ownership of conaso
Greenland through a project Beluga
civilian front he evacuated the civilian
population from the area then spent a
century constructing a super weapon with
100 high yield nuclear weapons heat
amplification runes a Target getting
Beacon for SCP dag and five antimatter
Gathering pods from SCP H&M in place he
was finally ready for ubu to manifest
again Dr Macau former member of the SCP
foundation's 05 Council had one sworn
enemy one being that he despised more
than anything else in the entire
universe the being known as SCP uu the
monster that had eliminated death and
destroyed the world the vengeful doctor
was able to successfully go back in time
to the days before scpu first manifested
desperate to prevent the horrors he
witnessed during ubu's centuries long
Rampage after the SCP Foundation failed
to help him with his plan Dr macod spent
thousands of years reestablishing
project Beluga in this new timeline the
project secured ownership of Kango
Greenland evacuated the civilian
population and constructed Beluga 1 in
the epicenter of ubu's manifestation
point it was outfitted with 100 high
yield nuclear weapons heat amplification
runes copied from SCP NSF a targeting
Beacon for SCP dag and five antimatter
Gathering pods from SCP H&M the Trap was
set and it was time to wait for SCP ubu
to appear when it did and the trap was
sprung SCP ubu managed to escape
unharmed rampaging through the world
much like it did the first time that
attempt failed but it was not the only
one Dr Macau was not about to give up
now he restarted the cycle again using
replicates in order to gain a greater
amount of control over both the SCP
Foundation and the global cult Coalition
25 years before SCP ubu's scheduled
arrival Dr maau opened email Bas
Communications with SCP
2803a P Hudson gawk a giant tumorous
blob of Flesh in an abandoned anomalous
office building with the genius Mind of
a former CEO regarding the threat he
informed gawk that in 25 years time
something was going to destroy the
entire global economy particularly the
Consumer Electronics Market this
massively distressed SCP
2803a at this point Dr Macau asked if
the anomaly might have a skill set that
could help prevent ubu from destroying
the economy and of course the rest of
the world SCP
2803a as it turns out did indeed have a
strategy in mind one year before ubu's
arrival 2803 D attacked parasitized and
fused with SCP 169 the Leviathan this
Fusion resulted in a creature 1.5 times
the original size of SCP 169 with
several heads the resulting collateral
damage was catastrophic killing billions
of civilians when the creature came face
to face or faces with ubu it lasted
centuries before ubu made the killing
blow maoud repeated the cycle again and
again and again and again in some Cycles
he tweaked his plans by the tiniest of
degrees other Cycles were dramatically
different from the ones that came before
during cycle 273 he increased the
aperture from the Beluga 94 project
teleporting the entire continent of
Greenland into another dimension Menon
after ubu first appeared both Greenland
and ubu vanished on 512
2588 however only 5 minutes later a
second ubu materialization event
occurred the Rampage continued on from
there Dr Macau was becoming discouraged
and considered modifying his Central
Consciousness containment unit to
forcibly redirect any negativity he felt
away from himself and his abilities and
toward ubu during cycle 530 maau
established site assembly in Cypress in
the year
10,485 BCE the Beluga X unit was
constructed over the course of 3,000
years there this feat was achieved via
the infiltration of the Church of the
broken God which was converted into the
false pretense Labor division of project
Beluga saric cult activity spread
through Europe as a result but this was
an acceptable amount of collateral
damage What mattered most was the Beluga
x a heavily armed construct based around
the design of SC SCP 2406 the Colossus
replicate 5818 one of the many mcau
replicates was selected for the role of
majority Consciousness holder then 10
minutes after ubu manifested Beluga X
was deployed Beluga X confronted SCP ubu
and declared the intent to stop its
Invasion at the sound of macau's voice
ubu responded with the
call it promptly began to whistle the
bathtime song the same one it had
whistled so very very long ago while
tormenting Dr mcod somehow this ubu was
the original one from the very first
timeline how did it survive how long had
it been following Dr Macau who refused
to answer any of these questions Beluga
X charged at ubu but slipped in a pile
of the beast's dung falling to the
ground the cycle was a failure and Dr
moud was filled with more dread and
hopelessness than ever in cycle 675 5
the moon's gravitational pole was
increased causing it to collide with ubu
during the materialization event this
Collision succeeded and the Earth was
completely destroyed there was too much
debris to determine if ubu survived
being hit by the moon or not this was
unacceptable to Dr mcau in the following
cycle Dr maau took a more human approach
over the course of 10 Millennia
replicates forcibly converted 90% of the
human population to an invented religion
called Spade of Triumph Al known as spis
the primary mode of worship in spis was
the creation of as many Beluga 900 units
as physically possible conflicts between
spis and the rest of the world religions
resulted in many wars and spads had
enslaved 5.9 billion people by 2500 CE
by the time ubu manifested there were
still not enough Beluga 900 units to
make a difference cycle 677 was
identical to cycle 530 in every way
until the year 25 500 CE at this point
Beluga x mark I was created and piloted
directly by the consciousness of Dr
Macau it was first tested on 1225 2500
at which time Dr Macau destroyed half of
Asia over a period of 8 hours billions
were killed this cycle was not intended
to stop ubu it was a prime numbered
cycle and thus according to macau's own
personal rules was to be used for stress
relief in the form of Senseless
destruction during cycle 678 moud came
to a troubling conclusion he was running
out of resources homed replicators were
broken Beyond repair leaving only 305
replicates where there should have been
Millions SCP 319 could not be secured
and there were no more stolen SCP 2700
cores to make matters worse there were
not enough resources to gather
additional working homed replicators
from SCP 2000 he would have to make
contact with the SCP Foundation again
and the goal of project mag Beluga would
have to be modified from termination to
containment he drafted containment
procedures to be implemented the moment
the opportunity presented itself these
containment procedures were unlike any
penned by the foundation before they
were not simply a containment method
they were a punishment they were a
Vengeance to ensure the internal Agony
that Dr maccau believed SCP ubu
empirically deserved area ubu was
constructed within SC Beluga met spatial
Mainframe area ubu is a pocket Dimension
where Dr moud is God it consists of 1
square kilometer of wide open nothing Dr
macau's will was capable of causing the
area to repeat at infinum depending on
where SCP ubu moved this essentially
meant that there was no Escape no Edge
only infinite emptiness in M's words no
one to run from him no one to fight him
no one to hurt there would be no death
in this space and it would be equipped
with an indestructible floor Dr M's plan
Illustrated how this Millennial long
battle had taken a toll on his own
sanity by his plan ubu would be kept in
this uncaring Solitude for as long as it
would take for the futility of his
situation to set in his laughter would
become confusion his confusion would
become anger his anger would become
whimpering his whimpering would become
begging his begging would become sobbing
and his sobbing would become wailing
this process would continue until ubu
began to eventually adjust to its
surroundings once it began to feel
comfortable and began to experience the
smallest glimmer of hope macow would
implement the next stage of his
containment procedure he would summon a
dark and Mountain High and unspeakably
strong version of himself with fingers
like gleaming scalpel he planned to
destroy ubu in countless ways warping
the monster squishing its body and
molding it like clay then it would only
get worst for the Beast as Dr macau's
plans for Revenge made him just as
horrific a monster as his enemy
according to macau's plans he would
clone ubu a companion a wife the first
real friend he has ever had and maau
will harden her heart and make her
despise him she will reject him cruy and
viciously she will curse the day she
ever met something so objectively
hideous s SCP ubu and if that doesn't
drive the point home enough she would
offer her heart to maod himself
effectively cuckolding his worst enemy
at this point Macau planned to destroy
the fabricated wife in front of ubu
these procedures were only the beginning
of the intake proceedings after that
maoud would move on to one of 148 level
two subroutines while writing these
containment procedures Dr Mout smiled
for the first time in over 1 million
years
in the description section of the file
he wrote only one thing reap what you
sow then it was time to try a new cycle
to begin a new in the year 2022 the SCP
Foundation was planning a full
exploration attempt of an anomally known
as SCP 001 daa SCP 001a was a shipping
container the exterior of which was
reinforced with an unknown substance SCP
001 A-1 was a flat metallic device
serving as the container's cockpit SCP
001 a-2 were 57 identical humanoid
entities of indeterminant gender or
identity dressed in blue jumpsuits with
the words project Beluga emblazoned on
them all entities were found in and
around the cockpit they were all notably
hostile and would attempt to attack
investigators when the cockpit was
opened it revealed SCP 001 a-3 an extra
dimensional space that consisted mainly
of interior corridors for a fortified
storage area on September 1st 2022 the
speaker system of SCP 001's internal
console began to loudly broadcast a
concerning announcement first it began
with emergency emergency emergency
followed by the mimetic passphrase that
could only be spoken by a current or
former
05-11 without the subject immediately
bursting into flames the announcement
continued likelihood of ganam me
protocol enactment if non-action is
taken approximately 100% XK SK ZK YK
class scenario all pending I am stranded
on the 50th basement level of SCP 001
a-3 there are possibly several children
down here with me this message will
repeat until my demands are met help me
emergency emergency emergency site
director nay Smith and the 05 Council
were both consulted on the matter and
researcher Daron gutii was chosen to
meet with whoever was responsible for
the distress call he had recently been
exposed to a faf near class infohazard
and was scheduled for termination
sometime soon anyway so he decided to
use his dying hours productively he was
equipped with a hidden microphone and
sent to speak with the broadcaster while
Ty entered SCP 001 a-3 descending to
level B15 he took 15 steps into the
spacious area calling out for an answer
from whoever called for help and first
there was no response gualtieri began to
grow impatient saying look no one
upstairs believes this broadcast of
yours but we all agreed it's too weird
to not come down and at least hear you
out so what the hell do you want again
no response irritated gutiri turned to
leave but as he did the blast door slam
shut trapping him inside he could hear
the sound of heavy machinery moving
toward him he was suddenly confronted by
the sight of an autonomous weapon a
massive mechanized structure equipped
with drills and saws he screamed at the
site hello it spoke my name is Dr
Lawrence M you going to follow my
demands scream if you agree the drills
word close to guti's face he screamed
this monster apparently what remained of
Dr Macau demanded to know his name
gualter demanded to know what the entity
wanted from him maau repeated the
request for his name gualter relented
introducing himself before asking why he
was called down here maal had a question
of his own response have you ever did
someone non-stop for
9,492 687 years like most human beings
would in that scenario gualter answered
no maoud snapped if not you have nothing
to say to me Maring responses to queries
and demands because we are not in the
same head space and only similar minds
are worthy of my friendship and tea time
now then onto business I need a minimum
of 20 homonid replicators from SCP 2000
and a card blanch access to scp3 19 this
is for the sake of Humanity's future in
the year 2588 if these demands are not
met then in tus 60 seconds you are going
to bang on the gates of hell and beg the
stewards of Eternal damnation to give
you Sanctuary gualtier offered a bargain
I I just want to know why you're doing
this this is too weird to be left open
call it a scientist's Instinct just tell
me that and I'll pull all my strings
topside and get you whatever you want I
swear cross my heart maau agreed to
these ter terms and used SCP yez to
briefly share Consciousness with gutii
everything Mout experienced with ubu
everything about project Beluga all of
those Millennia of suffering were
transferred into guti's head like a
vivid dream he saw the initial
manifestation of ubu in Greenland the
waking nightmare that followed macau's
own harrowing encounter with the Beast
its Twisted bathtime song his discovery
of potential salvation only to have his
hop dashed by failed cycle after failed
cycle it was all the answers he could
have ever wanted and plenty he never
ever would have wished to know but
before gualtier could hold up his side
of the bargain he promptly dropped to
the ground Dead maau made a note of this
unfavorable result running logic sub
routines confirm there is a non-zero
chance that this delivery is the
indirect work of ubu formulating
additional cation procedures to minimize
mental duris after his death gual
arrived in Corbin the plane of existence
that acts as a form of afterlife and as
a home of the three moons initiative
there he was retrieved by several agents
of the initiative who spoke with him
about his experience just before his
death shaken up he told the agents what
he learned about SCP ubu and the
impending doom that the Earth was facing
much to his surprise they were not
phased by his descriptions of the Beast
of its appetite for violence and
unnatural abilities in fact they had
seen beasts like it before they knew
exactly what SCP U was and they knew
exactly how to stop it for good from the
time it first appeared SCP ubu has
brought nothing but endless pain and
destruction without even the promise of
death as a release it dug holes in the
ground and buried millions of people
alive it threw cargo ships out of the
Earth's gravitational pole throwing them
so hard that several of them landed on
the moon it drove humans to abandoned
Society take to floating cities of
people drugged into a permanent sleep
the SCP Foundation could not stop it one
Furious Immortal researcher fueled by
rage and pain could not stop it but
still there is a home for Humanity in
the form of a child and a Frog puppet
one of the most fascinating and Powerful
groups of Interest known to the SCP
Foundation is the three moons initiative
what exactly is the three moons
initiative in short they are an
extradimensional human organization
based in corbic an afterlife Dimension
also known as SCP 2922 DC the initiative
was first founded approximately 14,000
years ago with the express purpose of
establishing human colonies in the
afterlife the initiative judges the sins
of deceased humans and selects their
Associated punishments and rewards via
2/3 majority vote of the ption committee
the humanity defense Corps is the
initiative's military branch which acts
as a multi-dimensional security Force
protecting the human race from harm this
Branch keeps a close eye on Earth
carrying out covert operations in its
Defense Initiative Personnel always act
in what they believe to be Humanity's
best interest but they are not a perfect
organization like any group they have
been guilty of poor communication
overreach and struggles with internal
bureaucracy in spite of these flaws the
SCP Foundation and the three moons
initiative have established peace and
cooperation via the Treaty of C Gazo
three moons initiative personnel tamino
and matapang were strolling through the
landscape of corenic on an ordinary
Patrol walking beneath the seag green
sky and black clouds when suddenly a new
person manifested in the area they must
have been recently deceased he
introduced himself to the two officers
as Aaron gualtieri of the SCP Foundation
they welcomed him to the afterlife and
ushered him to a proper screening area
as he underwent the usual intake process
gualtieri seemed incredibly distressed
about something other than his recent
death they asked the man to explain what
troubled him and he told them quite the
story on May 12th 2588 Humanity was
going to meet a destructive force it
would be entirely unprepared to combat
SCP uu an enormous hairless White Beast
with no facial features except a mouth
and an insatiable appetite for violence
which would manifest in Greenland where
it would cause an endof death scenario
and beat Humanity's Collective Spirit
into the ground it would hunt endlessly
across the globe turning every city to
rubble and destroying the ground until
the Earth's surface was mostly ocean and
garbage it would destroy SCP 682 once
thought to be a threat without equal a
former SCP Foundation 05 council member
Dr moud traveling back in time to try
and stop this tragedy and to warn the
SCP Foundation about it but his attempts
to defeat the Beast had been
unsuccessful the foundation had not
allocated him the resources he had asked
for and had not partnered with him as he
had hoped he had attempted to take
matters into his own hands creating
human replicants of himself and taking
over the world again and again in hopes
of creating a strong enough Army to
defeat the Beast he had a personal
Vendetta against the monster after it
had tortured him with a twisted
approximation of bath time using his own
wife as a scrub brush he had great ran
plans for the Revenge he would enact
once the Beast could be contained but no
matter what he did no matter how much
collateral damage it wasn't enough
nothing was ever enough the three moons
Personnel were horrified to hear about
this senseless tragedy but one aspect of
gualtieri's account stuck out to them
his description of the vile Beast that
was SCP ubu sounded incredibly familiar
the more they thought about his story
The more familiar it sounded soon enough
tamino and matapang realized exactly
what it was a creature native to corbic
that had somehow made its way to Earth
in the meantime they provided as much
support to the Fallen Foundation
employee as they could helping him to
acclimate to his new home in the
afterlife he was given a promotion and
welcomed into the ranks of their
Foundation continuance program so he
could continue the research he was so
passionate about even after death now
that the three moons knew what this
threat was they also knew how to stop it
and with the fate of humanity hanging in
the balance they needed to act fast
tamino and matapang were assigned to the
task with the help of an instance of SCP
5298 SCP 5298 is a type of three moons
initiative remote controlled military
drone but this isn't any ordinary drone
it has the appearance of a child between
the ages of 5 and 13 years old and
living under an individual assumed
identity they are always assigned a man
and a woman to act as the instances
parents in this case the parents were
tamino and mat tapping SCP 5298 may look
harmless but they are extremely powerful
and their combat capabilities include
machine guns hidden in their forearms
finger-mounted electroshock weapons
hidden in their fingernails and
neurotoxin injecting barbs hidden in
their teeth their innocent appearance
only serves to mask their potential as a
deadly threat so with the team selected
and prepared for their mission it was
time to take a trip to the Greenland
Tundra tamino and matapang dawned hasmat
suits standing behind an arched metallic
barrier for their safety on the other
side of the barrier their particular
instance of SCP 5298 pass the barrier
clad in white ceremonial robes that
would be much too cold for the weather
if the child wearing them was actually
human in the child's hand it carried an
oak Rod covered in ritualistic carvings
one one by one tamino and Matt tapang
checked the various equipment the camera
was set the blast Shield was Secure the
kill vehicle contained in mat tap pang's
duffel bag was Secure the executive
drone was in route and the celebrant
Drone was in place though it was briefly
on autopilot which caused it to talk
back to tamino before its function was
overridden all at once the executive
drone arrived with the sound of a small
explosion it resembled a blue and orange
puppet similar to in in appearance to
Kermit the Frog and introduced itself
with a cheerful greeting H kermy frog
here ready to dispense Swift and brutal
justice but tapang rolled her eyes at
the sight of the thing offering to
deliver the kill vehicle herself but
with everyone in place it was time to
begin the operation and they would be
using the Frog whether she liked it or
not she unzipped the duffel back as the
Frog's fingers were too thin to operate
the zipper and tamino ordered the
celebrant to commence with the next
phase of the operation the SCP 5298
instance sang A Hymn in an unknown
language for 24 seconds followed by a
large explosion and a burst of pale
green light SCP 5298 exploded at this
point and the barrier buckled matapang
opened her laptop checking it for signs
of Lambda waves thankfully they were
absent meaning that the end of death
scenario had been avoided with that out
of the way it was time for the next
phase the Frog drone exited the barrier
holding the kill vehicle in its hand the
kill vehicle was an unassuming sight a
pointed wooden stick approximately 1 m
in length engraved with the word
cleansing several hundred times there in
a crater not too far away was SCP ubu it
had manifested in a prone position but
slowly began to stand up straight
giggling wickedly it was searching for
its favorite victim the one it had been
doing battle with for Millennia it
called out to Dr mcod in its own
peculiar way looking around for any
sight of him but he wasn't there instead
there was an orange and green frog
tapping ubu on the shoulder it spun
around with a surprised snarl Furious
that its usual play thing was nowhere to
be found before ubu could do anything or
Babble another word the Frog stabbed ubu
in the stomach with the pointed stick
yubu responded not with a roar but with
a curious amused sound suddenly it
collapsed falling backward as soon as
its body hit the ground it crumbled
dissolving into a pile of white powder
not snow as it might have first appeared
but salt the target had been officially
successfully neutralized ubu was gone
for good shortly after this successful
operation the 05 Council received an
email from the three moons initiative it
read as follows foundation in case you
were not aware a researcher of yours one
Aaron gualtieri has recently passed away
upon his arrival to Corbin and
subsequent retrieval by three Moon
screening agents Mr gualtier informed us
that your iteration of Earth was due for
a bit of trouble with a certain creature
that is familiar to our world SCP ubu is
rather was a pantr or gargantuan vens
ferox in Latin a common nuisance in the
k Canon south of outer scalli though I
would not doubt its destructive
potential in a world free of its natural
enemies this specimen in particular was
unusually small and weak for its species
no doubt it was the Run of its litter
it's not unheard of for a pentag ruu to
access one of many jump points in the
Forbidden prefectures to cause Mischief
in other dimensions and it's likely that
this one had secured second Prince
naso's favor in one way or another in
order to anoint its living presence with
both the right of world ceiling and the
Eternal hunt but should this happen
again with separate pentag remember this
the indigenous tribes of outer scavi
hate pantr for obvious reasons a common
right of passage for boys who reach the
age of 13 is to leave the village not to
return until they've bagged a pentag GRU
this is how they pull it off this is how
we pulled it off and moving forward this
is how you should pull it off grab a
length of wood and sharpen it to a point
carve the word cleansing in any language
into it for a minimum of 200 times there
is no maximum but let's be honest doing
it more than 200 times isn't going to
make the pentag ruu any dead anywhere
that there's free space for carving left
on the stick engrave the following
phrase just as it's written here n Fu
jalakara stab it anywhere into the
pentag gur's body and there you have it
as for Mr gualtieri do not worry about
him he has been ly rewarded and offered
a position on the foundation continuance
program on Luna major I would suggest
naming something after him on your side
you owe him dearly you are watched you
are protected you are loved though the
instructions for dealing with future
pental infestations were helpful even
comforting there was a troubling element
to this letter as well
scpu the entity that had been decimating
the Earth and tortured all of its
inhabitants was the runt of its litter
if it had been able to accomplish Lish
so much horror what could a stronger
member of its species accomplish
hopefully the world would never have to
find out but not everyone was relieved
to receive notice from the three moons
initiative upon receipt of the notice
from the three moons initiative Dr maau
began to repeat one single word again
and again no all at once his plan for
vengeance was ripped away from him his
hope for seeing some sort of Justice
Done against SCP ubu gone in an instant
the thousands and thousands thousands
and thousands of years the violence the
death the human replicants of himself he
made over and over through any means
necessary it had all been in service of
this greater purpose now what was it all
for overcome with despair he sealed the
bulkhead of the shipping container he
had made his home all the replicants of
himself he had made over the years
suddenly expiring after over a month of
continuous screaming he booted up his
old computer to type out one closing SCP
file on UB be you his thoughts were
disjointed the combination of Despair
and denial he acknowledged that his plan
had almost certainly failed the plan put
in motion just under 10 million years
ago but perhaps there was still a chance
he could find closure perhaps he could
do it all he would need to do was keep
screaming louder and louder until one
day a higher power took pity on him and
sent him an SCP
U-2 and he could be the one to kill and
punish it no that wasn't a good enough
plan instead he would rely on his
willpower he would focus his energy via
eons of screaming and manifest SCP U-2
through sheer force of will then it
would be a good day then he would win
then he wouldn't have to scream anymore
until that day he would carry boundless
hatred with nowhere to put it no joy
only struggle without killing torture
without satisfaction con conflict
without resolution there was no one left
for maau to hate but himself the
laboratory was cold he wished someone
was there to cover him with a blanket
but no one was so instead he searched
for a distraction he remembered then
that the computer contained a morale
boosting video game one that had
attempted to get him to play it in the
past he had never wanted to play it
before but now maybe it was just what he
needed he saved his file and the
familiar prompt popped up on on screen
it's text a garish cheerful pink hey
user file Untitled 1.txt display
evidence of severe down in the dumps
stude Prometheus Labs cares about your
mental health why not take a break and
play a video game just type runor swinky
to join the hunt for Mr swinky after all
swinky Len needs you to catch that
sneaky Mr swinky before he misses
princess panky's birthday party with a
resigned sigh the being that had once
been an ordinary human man named Dr
maccau typed runor swinky into the
console why not after all he's been
through he might as well give it a shot
additional text scrolled across the
console please enter the 16-digit code
found on the back of the provided swink
kit to prove that this is a legitimate
copy of the hunt for Mr swinky there was
no kit that he could find nothing
anywhere in the shipping container if
there had ever been one here it was
likely lost a millennial ago again he
screamed once more a sound that has
persisted to this day maybe one day the
universe will bring Dr maau a new outlet
for his endless rage but for now he has
nothing left to do but scream until his
voice gives out mourning the loss of an
enemy the rest of the world has
forgotten the suffering he had felt
belonged to another timeline one that
would never come to pass leaving theow
without a place in this one so all that
was left to do was scream Robert Oran
and his partner in crime John stre
zipped through the murky Waters of the
Louisiana Bayou on a speedboat these men
were dealers in the elicit but their
specialty was not any kind of Contraband
you'd probably recognize Orlean and
Streep dealt in rare orchids IL legally
poached from areas where they're
considered in danger and sold to
high-paying wear plant collectors as any
seller or collector knows Rarity is the
Hallmark of value and what these two men
would encounter in the swamp that day
was truly One of a Kind the problem for
this pair of greedy opportunists is that
only one of them would live to tell the
tale and thanks to the SCP Foundation
the other wouldn't remember it for long
that's what happens when you have a
dangerous runin with a certain mean
green swamp dwelling creature that
doesn't take kindly to unwanted visitors
and and no we're not talking about a
crocodile Orlean and Streep continued
through the swamp keeping their Keen
eyes out for the flash of light blue
that had give away the orchids they were
seeking little did they know from the
murky Darkness between the Reeds a pair
of big yellow eyes were watching them
back they were Intruders in a stranger's
land threats just like the Badman they
would need to be dealt with accordingly
or a grim history would repeat itself
the boat came to a halt as the two
poachers finally saw one of the rare
flowers they were looking for arising
out of the muck Oran leaped from the
boat and began waiting towards his prize
the flower would fetch him and his
partner a pretty penny if they could get
it back in good condition the Motions
were so well practiced for oron so
automatic that he didn't even notice
something was moving through the waters
towards him Gators and snakes were an
occupational hazard for people like
Orlean he kept a revolver holster just
below his shoulder as a precaution but
the thing about to kill him was unlike
anything he'd ever faced before just as
his careful fingers curled around the
orchid's stem Oran heard stre screaming
from the boat he was frantically
pointing at something just beyond Oran
emerging from the reads Oran turned and
felt his jaw falling open in horror at
the sight of it at first it seemed
almost like a water logged corpse thick
matted black hair heavy with grease and
mudy Bog Water teeming with parasitic
swamp life her skin was green and bumpy
like that of a toad dripping with
viscous green sweat that seemed like it
could only be the byproduct of rot but
those eyes those big yellow amphibian
eyes they were alive as they were
inhuman this creature wasn't a corpse it
was something else entirely her body
cleared the water standing at Orlean's
height now and fac reling him eye to eye
she was naked her dignity preserved by
her long tangle of hair her body was
human-shaped except for her freakishly
long thin limbs her belly appeared
visibly bloated or engorged like a woman
in the mid-stages of pregnancy Oran had
never smelled something so foul in his
entire life which was mostly spent
waiting through swamps and bogs she
smelled like death itself stre was
screaming for Oran to climb back into
the boat but Oran knew it was already
too late he reached for his holstered
pistol but before he could clear leather
the creature let out a horrific guttural
Hawking noise and spewed a stream of
black goo onto oron's face it was hot
sticky and foul tasting like a kind of
tar rendered from corpses it plastered
his open mouth and nose shut and began
to suffocate him he tried desperately to
claw his face and tear the offending
substance away but all that succeeded in
doing was getting his fingers stuck
while or and suffocated and stre
screamed terrified obscenities from the
boat the creature just watched and
smiled through rotten teeth it was nice
to see them Panic just like the bad man
who'd come before they were in the wrong
they deserved this Oran soon realized
that nothing he could do would save
himself he'd spent his life in a
dangerous profession and been lucky
until now but the reaper catches up with
everyone eventually the last thing he
saw as the world went black was this
creature this swamp woman waiting
towards him through the water with a
hungry look in her eye she grabbed him
on either side of his face and just held
him there what was that sound was it
fizzling like something was burning or
even melting she just kept staring and
smiling with those awful rotten teeth
Robert oron went to sleep in her hands
and never woke up back back on the boat
a desperate John Streep was watching a
scene that if it wasn't for the later
intervention of the SCP Foundation would
haunt him until his dying day he watched
his partner undergo a process that was
somewhere between rotting and melting he
withered away in the swamp woman's hands
degrading into thick black sludge that
she drank through her thirsty skin as
much as it pained him to leave his
friend behind stre knew that there was
no saving him now all he could possibly
do was escape with his own life he
pulled the rip cord on the boat's motor
and tore his way back to the nearest
Township the shape of the nightmarish
swamp woman shrinking in the distance
behind him when he ran into the local
police station half mad with grief and
fear screaming about the monster that
had killed his friend in the swamp the
police understandably detained him for
further questioning when his criminal
history as a poacher was flagged up on
the database it became clear he probably
wasn't leaving for a while that's when a
foundation agent embedded in the
department passed a memo about the
case's strangeness up the chain of
command and a covert mobile task force
was soon dispatched to the swamp in
order to locate and capture the
anomalous creature that stre had claimed
took his friend's life after a few days
of searching the swamp woman was
captured by the foundation and
redesignated as SCP 811 before being
delivered back to a nearby containment
site luckily for foundation
disinformation agents the cover story
was practically gift WRA for them on
this one it had been a dispute between
two hardcore criminals and as the saying
goes there's no honor among Thieves stre
had murdered Oran over a pay cut dispute
and thrown him into the swamp where his
body was eaten by Gators a few falsified
records and implanted memories later and
the foundation was free to do what it
pleased with scp-811 but the swamp woman
would prove to to be full of surprises
and contradictions while designated as
uclid the containment procedures for the
creature were rather extensive for its
own benefit like a lot of creatures who'
never existed in captivity before it had
very specific needs in terms of its
artificial habitat the foundation needed
to be on top of everything from the pH
levels of its soil acidity to the
optimal temperatures and humidity levels
of its containment chamber built to
resemble the creatures natural swamp
habitat the swamp woman is mostly
non-aggressive to Foundation staff but
certain precautions need to be taken in
order to ensure everyone's safety around
her while she's largely humanoid her
internal physiology vastly differs from
that of humans her veins and digestive
system are nonfunctional she consumes
her prey by melting it into black sludge
with the highly costic secretions of her
skin before absorbing it back through
her pores the waste material collects in
her stomach which then expels
voluntarily through an action similar to
vomiting this is often used offensively
or in hunting prey as the unfortunate
Robert Oran found out as a result people
working in 81's containment chamber need
to do so in pairs and wear heavily
sealed hazmat suits for obvious safety
reasons the creature also proved to be
surprisingly intelligent well not a
genius by any means it was no mere
mindless animal the swamp woman had an
intellect and commun communication
skills on par with your average feral
child the one that had been brought up
and socialized in a relatively normal
home before being turned loose and
experiencing a decline in its mental and
Social Development her words have a
childlike construction to them as though
English isn't her native language and
she's still in the very early stages of
learning it she gave herself a name I
and began to cooperate well with
Foundation staff in exchange for having
her needs met met since being brought
into containment she's made a number of
requests these include some requests
that have been denied by the foundation
such as the regular provision of B Vine
prey for its chamber and a variety of
fish from its native environment to make
it feel more at home however there are
some requests that the foundation has
approved like a wooden hairbrush and a
d-class in a hazmat suit entering the
Room daily in order to help wash her
hair often bogged down by the frequency
at which her skin produces thick costic
oils in one particularly strange request
she asked for a turtle in a hazmat suit
to act as a companion in her containment
chamber as she reacted negatively to the
idea of having Turtles as food sadly
this was one of the denied requests
scp-811 was also involved in a few cross
tests with other anomalies leading to
curious results after realizing just how
dangerous scp-811 secretions could be
Foundation researchers naturally floated
the idea of using it on SCP 682 in its
seemingly endless termination
experiments a sample of 682s Flesh was
successfully decayed by the dangerous
mucus so a larger quantity collected
over a number of months was then sprayed
all over the Beast it managed to reduce
682s body mass by 27% melting its way
through the covered flesh down to the
bone however at that point it was unable
to Decay further and SC SCP 682 soon
returned back to its normal State who
could have possibly seen that coming
right however a much more interesting
and enlightening cross test occurred
with SCP 978 the desire camera if you
haven't already seen our video on the
desire camera it's pretty much exactly
what the name suggests a Polaroid camera
that reveals the deepest desire of its
subject and the foundation decided to
test it on a large number of staff and
anomalies one of those being SCP 811
when a photograph was taken of scp-811
just staring at the camera the resulting
photo depicted a human woman with the
same height build and facial features as
SCP 811 braiding yellow ribbons into her
hair and wearing a blue sundress the
attending researchers felt this raised
an interesting question were they
looking at an aspiration towards
Humanity from scp-811 or was this a
yearning to return to what had been
before there was only one way to find
out out conduct an interview with the
creature itself when the interview began
the researchers pressed 811 on some of
her earliest memories one of the key
details she shared was regarding a
mysterious man whom she claimed came to
her before she looked like she did now
back when her skin was soft and pink the
bad man he injected something into her
arm and whatever it was it changed her
mutated her took away her precious
Humanity the first thing she she
remembered feeling after that was an
allc consuming hunger and then melting
and devouring the one who changed her
destroying any possible answers as to
who he was or why he did it in the
process it was a story of victimization
and dehumanization so cruel and
upsetting that researcher watchel an
assistant researcher attending the
interview actually threw up later
debriefing interviews revealed it was
because he had a daughter of roughly the
same age with long dark hair if scp-811
has any parents herself we may never
know such is the strange tragedy of
scp-811 whether you wish to call her by
her number a nickname like the swamp
woman or her self-given name of I will
likely never know who she was before as
not even she knows now it is an
unsettling reminder that all of our
grasps on Humanity are looser than you
think sometimes all it takes is one
chance encounter to change who you are
completely there is something so
captivating about ice it can be
beautiful a shimmering cast of frost
over a meadow or twinkling icicles on a
cottage roof it can also be deadly a
slick of slippery glass on a dark Road
or that same icicle from before knocking
loose and careening towards your head
like a falling dagger it can be a SLE
storm or a mighty Glacier with Secrets
buried beneath its core in a remote not
part of Alaska the SCP Foundation
discovered a particularly unusual kind
of ice with a vivid red Hue and some
incredibly deadly potential the
foundation investigated the reports in a
remote area on the Alaskan Coastline
after a tribe of Local Natives came
across the mangled bodies of Shipwrecked
hunters in the area encased in a block
of strange Red Ice mobile task force
beta 7 also known as the hazmats were
sent in to the site to determine what
exactly had occurred and take samples of
any anomalous materials to be brought
back to the nearest Foundation research
site agent Bryce made the initial visual
inspection of the site and spotted three
middle-aged male bodies further
examination determined that one of the
bodies referred to as subject zero was
the original point of contamination for
whatever comprised the Red Ice and
caused the men's deaths it has been
posited by the investigation team that
the other men were infected when they
attempted help subject zero reach their
boat sadly kindness can sometimes be a
killer like that while sweeping the
perimeter agent Hughes spotted human
Footprints leading to the Northeast a
three-men team consisting of agent
Hughes Whitmore and Cassidy was
permitted to follow those tracks and
determine if any survivors or something
worse had escaped the site exploration
log a009 allows us to determine what
happened next and what the three agents
found hug and his team followed the
footprints to the entrance of a cave
with the tracks appearing to lead inside
the entrance of the cave was covered
with an almost solid sheet of ice sa for
a crack in the ice about 1 M tall Beyond
this wall agent Whitmore spotted the
body of a young man frozen solid in the
midst of crawling away from something
covered in crystals of Red Ice with him
was a frozen spear gun that appeared to
have been fired just before the young
man's death they could not touch the
body to perform a full investigation but
the way in which he was gripping his
chest indicated that he might have been
fatally stabbed there as the agents
moved further into the cave they
discovered a chamber about 5 or 6 m in
diameter filled with red ice with a pool
in the middle the pool was 3 m wide and
of an unknown depth as they pushed
further the agents came across a polar
bear startled they fired once at it
before realizing it was already dead its
fur was dotted with crystals of red Red
Ice creeping its way across the Bear's
body beyond the polar bear the agent
spotted dozens of bodies all dead
animals there were seals a snow fox and
finally a giant spider with a leg span
of over a meter at first the spider
appeared to be Frozen like the other
creatures but upon further investigation
it appeared to be made of Red Ice agent
Cassidy recognized the spider as SCP
3023 but was told it was impossible when
she pressed for further answers she was
told to ignore it and continue the sweep
agent Whitmore checked the collection of
bodies in the chamber looking for any
humans among them meanwhile Hughes
spotted a spear sticking out of the
enormous spider indicating a struggle
that took place before it and the young
man at the Cave's entrance froze Hughes
was interrupted in his task as agent
Cassidy called out from deeper in the
cave saying I I think I know where the
spider came from when Hughes followed
the sound of her voice he found
something troubling an aperture about a
meter in diameter absolutely covered in
Red Ice it looked like a tunnel with no
ice at all past its entrance with a dim
light coming from somewhere deep inside
he lost sight of agent Cassidy and
realized she must have gone inside of it
upon further observation Hughes
determined that the walls and the floor
of the tunnel were wet with a red puddle
about a meter in Hughes and Whitmore
called to Cassidy attempting to lead her
back out of thep tunnel but received no
response Hughes attempted to go in and
retrieve her but control forbade him
from going any further after a
conversation with control that had been
stricken from the official file Hughes
had relented and agreed to withdraw his
remaining team and exit the sight Hughes
and Whitmore left the cave without
further incident and returned to
Foundation headquarters in spite of a
d-class recovery team being sent into
the cave to search for her agent
Cassidy's body was never found the cave
was blocked off from the public in order
to avoid further civilian contact with
the red ice and the red water inside
though the origin of the Red Ice in
Alaska is not known for sure this cave
and the pool deep within it are thought
to be the source of this particular
infestation the official cause of death
listed on record for the bodies found in
Alaska was internal bleeding but what
really happened to them was something
much much worse these men had
transformed and Frozen from the inside
out their blood turning to ice and their
cells going solid one at a time the low
ambient temperature in the area are
thought to have slowed the freezing
process down you heard that right the
cold kept them from freezing faster as
counterintuitive as it sounds this
prolonged their deaths and kept them
conscious up until the very end even as
their bodies were freezing solid their
very cells turning against them they
were awake and aware of it all these
unfortunate men came into contact with
and lost their lives to a subst stance
known as SCP
009 SCP 009 in its liquid form
maintained at temperatures between
0° C resembles ordinary distilled water
aside from its bright red color it
behaves opposite of water reaching a
frozen solid state at higher
temperatures and vaporizing into a steam
like gas at temperatures below
-100° an attempt to examine SCP 9's
atomic structure was unable to achieve
conclusive results the substance looks
as if it was made up of normal water
molecules though obviously it is much
more than simple water SCP 009 appears
relatively harmless at first glance but
its real dangerous potential lies in its
ability to contaminate water-based
Solutions transferring its properties to
them a contaminated liquid begins to
exhibit the same unusual behavior as SCP
009 freezing at temperatures above 0°
and vaporizing at temperatures below
-100 it has been shown to effectively
contaminate ice steam tea fruit juice
seawater and blood in a process taking
between 3 minutes and several hours
these concerning properties raise
questions about what SCP 009 and liquids
contaminated by it might do if they made
contact with a human body several
d-class Personnel were used as test
subjects exposed to SCP 009 in a
controlled environment and observed from
from a safe distance when first exposed
to SCP 009 the test subjects reported
nothing unusual except a slight
sensation of warming on the surface of
their skin then Frost began to form
across the surface of the exposed area
as the subject's body heat raised the
substance's temperature this process
took between a minute and a few hours
during which ice crystals began to form
along the top layer of the skin this
stage is known as surface conversion in
the next stage deep tissue conversion
the continued increase in SCP 9's
temperature causes a ripple effect of
reactions through the subject's body ice
crystals forming in the cells and
throughout the blood the subject
remained alive and conscious during the
stage details about the fourth stage of
the process had been expunged from the
official record but it is safe to say
that something horrible happened after
several of these experiments were
conducted testing on live d-class
subjects was officially discontinued
there was a possibility of
experimentation on SCP 009 regarding its
potential application to Cold Fusion but
this was also eventually discontinued
following a disastrous accident at an
unnamed Foundation test site the site
was completely destroyed and pieces of
the lead agent conducting the cold
fusion research have still not been
recovered for now SCP 009 is kept under
strict containment and only tested under
particular highly regulated
circumstances SCP 009 is kept in a
sealed storage tank of heat resistant
alloy it is not to be exposed to any
temperatures higher than 0° C unless
there is a official Foundation sanction
testing being done no water-based
liquids are allowed within 30 m of the
containment area the storage tank is
outfitted with temperature sensors that
are to be monitored at all times in
order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three
different cooling units if the sensors
or cooling units malfunction for any
reason they must be f fix immediately to
prevent disaster when testing is done on
SCP 009 the containment area is kept in
a vacuum and the Personnel working with
it must wear protective gear after
testing all involved personnel must
quarantine for at least 12 hours any
living organisms contaminated by SCP 009
must be terminated promptly while the
exact origins of SCP 009 are unclear it
clearly does not follow the laws of
nature as we understand them a found
Foundation expert in xenos spatial
physics suggested that SCP 009 may have
come from a universe with alternate laws
of physics explaining its reversal of
the ordinary conditions for states of
matter during an instance of SCP 507 The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper shifting into
an alternate universe an instance of SCP
009 was unexpectedly observed that may
help confirm this theory in the test
area where SCP 507 appeared red snow
fell for about 20 7 Minutes grass
touched by this red snow began to react
and freeze over within a few minutes the
other plant life touched by the snow
turned bright red and expanded to a
larger size it also began to sprout
bright blue tentacles covered with red
melage upon closer examination the
mucilage turned out to be comprised of
small amounts of SCP
009 this raised additional questions for
instance how are these plants able to
survive constant exposure to SCP 00 9
this matter is currently under
investigation but the prevailing theory
is that this plant is an example of
plant life from SCP 9's native Universe
whatever it is and wherever it comes
from it should not be allowed to come
into contact with earth-based Organic
life forms well not unless being
horrifically frozen to death by your own
body feels like an appealing experience
to you the coastline where SCP 009 was
initially discovered and its first
victims on record were found was located
very close to the ocean thankfully the
exact area of contamination was dry and
cold enough to keep the Red Ice from
spreading but if it had been even a few
meters closer to the water it could have
spread into the North Pacific Ocean with
contamination of that scale it could
have very easily infected thousands of
people perhaps spreading into other
bodies of water and triggering a global
Extinction event because of this threat
several members of the SCP Foundation
proposed that SCP 009 be upgraded to ker
class in order to reflect its danger to
humanity however this request was denied
due to the currently effective
containment measures in place the Red
Ice is unable to spread to new hosts
infecting the water supply and turning
all living things into frozen husks for
now let's just hope we don't see any red
snowstorms anytime soon researcher Ellis
was having a very long day working at
the SCP Foundation can sound like a
pretty exciting job job to an outsider
the problem is when you deal with
something exciting every day of your
life it starts to become as mundane as
brushing your teeth or pouring your
morning bowl of breakfast cereal over
time everything loses its magic she had
the unenviable job of double-checking
the anomalies in sewing of sight 77
glorified box ticking she trudge from
containment chamber to containment
chamber everything seeming to be in
order tick tick tick it was all euklid
and safe class anomalies anyway hardly
major containment risks but when she
reached the chamber for SCP
2805 the security cameras normally used
to observe the anomaly were on the Frets
she'd need to go inside great when the
chamber doors opened she felt an
immediate chill her breath came out as
an icy fog in the distance she saw a jar
sitting on a Podium the glass so frosted
over she couldn't quite make out what
was inside no sign of a containment Bree
she ticked the box next to SCP 2805 on
her clipboard and moved on several hours
later researcher Ellis was at home
finally able to relax since she started
working at the foundation dealing with
deadly creatures and cursed artifacts on
a daily basis she'd long for the simple
Comforts of childhood in her downtime
that's why she decided to spend her
evening with a warm mug of hot chocolate
a bowl of ice cream and her favorite
animated Disney movie Mulan she had just
pressed play when she got a phone call
from an unknown number with a frustrated
groan she picked up the phone and
answered the voice on the other end was
a little grally but it sounded kind his
diction was old-fashioned a man from a
bygone era why hello there young lady I
hope this isn't a bad time he said the
name's Walt Walt Disney perhaps you've
seen some of my Motion Pictures I was
wondering if I could trouble you for
some help with a project of mine
this might have been some stupid prank
call maybe Dr bryatt or Dr klef was
bored and decided they wanted to mess
with her the fact that she was watching
a Disney movie at the time was pure
coincidence after all they own half the
movies out there these days but that's
when Walt carried on talking to her you
see my dear I'm a little short on time
at the moment I realize I um perhaps
don't have the longevity that I used to
I won't get into the illness right now
but what I do know is that I might not
be able to put my final idea into
practice and I believe that you and your
organization may be able to help your um
uh what what is it called SCP Foundation
and that changed everything researcher
Ellis immediately knew that this wasn't
a prank call a member of foundation
staff would never discuss Foundation
matters even as a joke over an unsecured
line and a civilian would have no reason
to even know about the foundation was
she actually on the phone with the Walt
Disney it seemed odd and a little more
than unlikely on account of him being
dead for over 50 years if only
researcher Ellis had checked her
clipboard a little closer then maybe she
would have realized that she was already
under the anomalous effects of SCP
2805 also humorously known as Disney on
Ice here's a fun question for you what's
your favorite Disney movie probably not
what you expected to to hear from your
friends at SCP explained but seriously
we want to know tell us down in the
comments maybe you're a classical purist
and you consider Snow White Cinderella
or Sleeping Beauty to be the best maybe
you're a fan of the Disney Renaissance
and it's the little mermaid Beauty and
the Beast or The Lion King that are the
true masterpieces or perhaps you're a
fan of their more modern outings like
Tangled Frozen and Moana or even their
Acquisitions like Marvel movies or the
Star Wars series personally I'm partial
to Tron legacy we could go on but
honestly we'd be here all day the Walt
Disney Company started by Walter Elias
Disney and his brother Roy back in 1923
has become one of the most powerful and
influential entertainment companies in
existence their corporate machine is so
huge and sprawling it Rivals the size
and scope of the SCP Foundation itself
and it's influenced the way we look at
everything from mice to Pirates to Norse
Legends to Space Battles some give the
United States president the title leader
of the Free World but anyone in that
position would happily drop everything
to take a phone call from the CEO of the
Walt Disney Company even today the
company may be a global superpower these
days but none of it would have been
possible without Walt himself born in
1901 Walt started his legendary company
at the tender age of 22 who would have
known that he would leave such an
indelible mark on human culture during
his 65 years of life but he's not just
an entrepreneur animat writer voice
actor and film producer he's also
decades after his death an anomaly
currently in the capable hands of the
SCP Foundation well his cryogenically
frozen severed head is anyway and simply
looking at that severed head is what put
such an anomalous damper on researcher
Ellis's nice quiet evening confused
don't worry let's start this demented
Disney fairy tale at the beginning by
which we mean the end of Walt Disney's
life Walt Disney accomplished more in
his life than many of us would be able
to claim in several lifetimes he' built
one of the most enduring entertainment
companies of all time won countless
Awards and made millions of dollars from
his Creations including the Disneyland
theme parks the man had essentially made
his own name synonymous with magic
childhood Whimsy and dreams coming true
however rather than focusing on the past
Walt wanted to keep his eyes on the
future his Grand Vision went far beyond
movies and theme parks he wanted to
shape the way Humanity lived for
centuries to come and the name of this
Vision Epcot or the experimental
prototype community of tomorrow while
you may know Epcot as a mere portion of
the theme park in the Florida Walt
Disney Resort Walt himself actually
intended it to be so much more as the
full name suggests he dreamed of
creating a functional community of
tomorrow with over 20,000 residents in
his own words Epcot will take its queue
from the new ideas and new technologies
that are now emerging from the creative
centers of American industry it will be
a community of tomorrow that will never
be completed but will always be
introducing and testing and
demonstrating new materials and new
systems and Epcot will always be a
showcase to the world of the Ingenuity
and Imagination of American free
enterprise it was certainly a utopian
idea though fans of Bioshock might find
their eye twitching with flashbacks to
Andrew Ryan's disastrous Rapture however
Disney's problem didn't lie in his plans
but in himself despite his achievements
and Larger than Life Legacy he was still
a mortal man when Walt tragically
contracted lung cancer he finally became
aware of the fact that he may not live
to see his beautiful Epcot dream
completed and despite having all the
money and fame a man could possibly ask
for he was beginning to realize that his
fortune couldn't buy him a second of
extra time or could it
this question would soon be answered
when representatives of a mysterious
company known as the onor Roy Collective
approached Walt the strange thing though
was that the entities that compris this
elusive group of interests contacted
Walt in his dreams you see the onor Roy
Collective are a group of entities known
as the onor Roy or dreamers who exist
only in the dream space but sometimes
interact with our world through
anomalous sometimes semiorganic
Creations they sell as products in that
sense they were the original imagineers
their Creations include SCP 2028 a few
hundred snow globes that allow the user
to remove and store their nightmares and
negative feelings within and SCP
1498 which are creatures made from
old-fashioned rotary phones trailing a
huge number of wires coiled and arranged
into sheeplike bodies by calling the
phone on the creature's face a person
can order a custom Dreamscape from the
owner Roy naturally as creatures who
depend on dreams to survive the onoy
were big fans of Walt Disney a man who
built a career of encouraging children
to dream their little hearts out in
exchange for his contributions to the
Dreamscape they'd cut him a deal they'd
give him a special kind of onoy
technology that would allow his
Consciousness to continue to exist and
interact with the Physical Realm after
his death all they need to keep was his
head it was certainly a strange deal but
Walt was thinking of his children his
grandchildren and their children and
grandchildren if he died now then his
Tomorrowland dreams would die with him
he'd simply be known for some charming
animated films and a couple of amusing
theme parks not for truly changing the
future it seemed that the deal with the
honoy collective was too good to resist
the deal was struck and Arrangements
were made to preserve Disney's head and
Consciousness after his death 10 days
after his 65th birthday on December 15th
1966 Walt Disney passed away but that
was only the beginning of his new
anomaly life while the public mourned
Disney's head was secretly removed and
preserved in a jar with anomalous
cryonics technology the device is also
fixed to a pair of rotary phones a
trademark of the onoy and an inscription
that reads Siberian solutions from the
onoy collective the anomalous effect was
simple anyone who looked directly at
Disney's Frozen head would receive a
phone call in the next 24 hours this
phone call would be from Walt Disney
himself presumably inhabiting the onoy
Dreamscape now with this handy trick
he'd be able to maintain his
Communications with the rest of the Walt
Disney Company in secret and see the
creation of his precious Epcot project
to its completion but unfortunately
that's not actually how it happened
following Walt's death his brother Roy
took over all Walt Disney Company
operations while the profitability of
the company didn't suffer under Roy's
control Walt's final dream did Epcot
mutated from the sustainable functional
community of the future that Walt
desired
into a mere theme park the disneyfied
world's fair that all Orlando Disney
park visitors of today would recognize
as it turned out most people in the
Disney Company weren't actually eager to
take orders from the former CEO's
severed head as a result he became kind
of a dark company secret hidden away
within the Disney parks after a number
of reports of calls from Walt Disney
after the entrepreneur's death the
foundation finally started to take
notice they conducted a thorough
investigation of the various Disney
bases of operation and eventually found
Disney's Frozen head soon redesignated
SCP 2805 in a secret compartment in the
legendary Pirates of the Caribbean ride
he was relocated to site 77 soon after
for further testing where his anomalous
abilities were later discovered sadly
for SCP 2805 while his calls to
Foundation staff have all consisted of
attempts in enlisting the foundation's
help in making his Epcot dreams a
reality nobody has yet taken him up on
the offer since his containment the
foundation's main priority has just been
suppressing conspiracy theories about
the existence of Walt Disney's
cryogenically frozen head a task which
they undertake with collaboration from
the Disney Company in order to muddy the
waters in 1981 they began Productions of
Walt Disney's world on Ice later known
as Disney on Ice a traveling ice skating
show since then they also released the
incredibly successful film Frozen and
its sequel to corrupt any searches for
key phrases like Disney's Frozen or Walt
ice it's been an incredibly effective
smoke screen as you can probably expect
from the SCP Foundation and sadly for
Walt and fans of a mid-century
perspective on the future it's likely
that Walt Disney's dreams will stay
within his disembodied head so if you're
hoping to prove the existence of This
truly wild anomaly or somehow get in
contact with Walt and help him bring
Epcot to its intended Glory you should
probably just let it go go as we grow up
and get older our bodies begin to change
sometimes those changes can be a bit
uncomfortable or even bizarre we feel
strange pains in new places we grow
seemingly a foot in height overnight
hair Sprouts up in new places and falls
out of other places whether it's puberty
or just the aging process it seems like
the human body never runs out of ways to
surprise us but those surprises are
completely normal and to be expected as
part of being alive unless you're one
particular young man whose body changed
overnight into something
unrecognizable and entirely anomalous
that's when a very special individual
will be calling Matt terara comes in
Matt was an ordinary 24-year-old man
with nothing particularly interesting
about him sure he was a nice guy he was
smart he was great at chess and video
games and had an impressive memory for
science trivia but there was nothing
unusual about him every day he would get
up go to work at a board game and comic
book store chat with his co-workers and
make a few sales head home make dinner
relax and go to bed ready to do it all
again the next day it wasn't a glamorous
life or that exciting but it was a
pleasant life and he was happy to live
it one night Matt was having a difficult
time sleeping he was tossing and turning
waking up every few minutes to a full
aching feeling in his stomach he didn't
feel feverish or sick and the pain
wasn't sharp or indicative of an
emergency so he Shrugged it off as
indigestion and tried to get back to
sleep we've all been there right
eventually he noded off all the way he
woke up the next morning blurry eyed and
exhausted from the rough night but
feeling otherwise fine he climbed out of
bed stretched and headed to the bathroom
to brush his teeth there in the mirror
he saw something that made him think he
might St still be dreaming he pinched
himself and found that he was indeed
awake while he was sleeping somehow his
body had changed into something
completely impossible where his stomach
had once been there was a blue green and
brown orb that reminded him of a
photograph he had once seen a picture of
Earth taken aboard the International
Space Station after calling into work
and explaining in a stammering voice
that he would not be coming in that day
Matt did the only thing he could think
of he went to the hospital of course the
doctors had no idea what to do with him
it wasn't like they could just take out
his appendix or give him an antibiotic
none of them had ever seen anything like
this before fortunately for him one
doctor knew a lot more than he was
letting on Matt wouldn't be the first
human to develop bizarre anomalous
traits and then stagger into a nearby
hospital for treatment that's why the
SCP Foundation has agents embedded in
major hospitals all across the world and
one such doctor was the man treating
Matt on the downside he wouldn't be
enjoying his freedom much longer on the
upside it cost a hell of a lot less than
a regular uninsured hospital visit so
the field agent called up his superiors
wiped Matt's record from the hospital
and soon after a group of foundation
agents came to collect the confused
unfortunate host of what soon would be
known as SCP
007 SCP 007 is found within an abdominal
cavity on the body of Matt also referred
to as the subject just below his rib
cage where his stomach would be most of
his abdomen is completely missing
including the muscles skin and organs
that should ordinarily be necessary for
his survival however he does not appear
to experience any pain or even
discomfort from his condition SCP 007
itself is a spherical Planet composed of
soil and water none of which actually
touches any part of his body the planet
resembles a miniature duplicate of Earth
about 60 cm in diameter with its own
weather patterns and gravitational pole
neither of which appear to have any
effect on the subject nor do they seem
to be affected by his movements or
behavior there are also a variety of
tiny organisms dwelling on the planet's
surface that cannot be seen with a naked
eye though it greatly resembles Earth
there are some notable differences
obviously instead of floating in space
and revolving around the Sun this planet
does not appear to have an orbit it is
uncertain where the organism on the
planet get their light from though it
does not seem to be our sun since the
organisms have not shown any negative
effects from the lack of sunlight and
presence of artificial light in the
foundation's sight there are continents
visible on the planet's surface
surrounded by its sea but they do not
resemble a continental alignment that
can be traced to any point in our
Earth's history as far for the life on
the small planet the organisms
navigating the surface of the world
inside Matt's abdomen there are dozens
of identifiable species that bear a
passing resemblance to creatures on
Earth there are blue cowlike livestock
species of bird that appear to have
scales red and orange trees and other
plant life and two intelligent species
that are notably and significantly
humanoid in appearance and behavior
observation of these intelligent species
via microscope and digital imaging has
revealed that they operate in societies
and are consistently developing and
improving their technology though their
technology was incredibly rudimentary
when Matt was first brought into
containment resembling early nomadic
human civilizations it has progressed to
the level of 15th century Humanity the
research team assigned to SCP 007 has
noticed the recent introduction of a
version of the printing press used to
produce what appear to be pamphlets and
even entire books the language these
books are printed in is unrecognizable
and so the contents of these materials
are currently unknown but but the
citizens of the planet clearly have a
grasp of the written word and both the
technology and the desire to share it
amongst themselves they have also
developed an agricultural system their
Farms have progressed to the point of
using new Innovations such as windmills
used to Mill grain wheelbarrows used to
transport crops and other supplies and
the practice of crop rotation
unfortunately with these positive
developments comes the ability to
escalate conflicts and wage Wars they
look to have created parachutes boots
gunpowder and other explosives and their
own versions of the muzzle loaded rifle
however in spite of the ugliness of
battle there is beauty too the people of
the planet have created new ways to
express themselves with what can only be
described as new instruments closely
resembling the piano the mandolin and
the bag pipes as exciting and even
moving as it can be to watch these tiny
beings grow and change building their
own miniature Society it is also a bit
troubling as these people continue to
progress at such a fast rate it stands
to reason that they will eventually
catch up to us or even surpass Us in
terms of Technology the research team
has not yet made any attempts to
communicate with the inhabitants of the
abdominal Planet concerned about
influencing the developments of its
societies in any way or compromising
their ability to observe them without
interfering but they may not be able to
keep this up for much longer what will
happen if these tiny beings continue to
follow in our footsteps and create their
very own space programs if they leave
their planet's atmosphere they will
discover the truth that their world is
buried in the abdomen of what is to them
a giant man that reality would be enough
to shatter the sanity of many of us and
it would likely cause chaos on their
world there has been a great deal of
debate amongst the research team about
what to do if this should happen some
insist that the team should continue to
passively observe until the issue comes
up While others believe that they should
attempt to make contact with the
inhabitants of the planet in order to
soften the eventual blow to their
perceptions when they attempt space
exploration currently the debate rages
on as the research team keeps an eye on
the progression of the little
civilizations hopefully if they do
eventually make contact they will find a
way to make it clear that we come in
peace so who is Matt Tera the subject he
is a highly intelligent young man with a
shockingly casual attitude toward his
body's anomalous properties when asked
about the planet he simply says I just
woke up one day and there it was I don't
have any idea how it got there testing
revealed that he is genetically human
and there is nothing unusual or even
notable about the rest of his body he
provided his name willingly upon
arriving at the SCP Foundation but no
one of his name and age has ever lived
in his hometown area according to public
records to verify his identity he was
able to produce a social security card
and a driver's license which did not
appear to be forged or altered in any
way however when the numbers were run
through the system there was no match
officially this man does not exist it is
not entirely certain where he came from
or why there is no record of him but one
researcher posited that he somehow
crossed over from a parallel Dimension
or that the presence of his abdominal
Planet added as a kind of Cognito
hazardous effect to him that erased all
perception of him from any records
whatever the case may be wherever he
came from he is here now because he has
not yet attempted Escape or even shown a
desire to leave the foundation's site
there are no strict containment
procedures in place the only active
containment procedures for SCP 007 are
for the subject's Safety and Security he
lives in a sealed room with furniture
and other items which are granted upon
request as long as they do not pose a
security risk the subject's room
includes an easy chair a bed a bean bag
chair a television with access to
several movies and television streaming
services a number of video game consoles
an espresso machine a microwave a
refrigerator an exercise bike and a
bookshelf filled with books and graphic
novels though he does not appear to
require food or water in order to
survive he enjoys consuming both food
and drinks and is especially fond of
coffee sodas grape juice sour cream and
onion potato chips mangoes and the
occasional treat of Chinese takeout an
opinion which he shares with the
eccentric Dr clef the head research
assigned to SCP 00007 Dr Cho has a
weekly game of chess with Matt during
which he evaluates the subject's mental
health and general emotional well-being
over the course of these games the two
have developed a friendly relationship
with each man winning about half of the
time Matt asks about Dr Cho's family and
in return Dr Cho checks in about his
containment situation seeing if there's
anything the foundation can provide to
make his time with them more comfortable
most recently Matt requested a computer
with an internet connection mainly so
that he could play his video games in
online co-op mode but this request was
denied out of a concern that it would
compromise Foundation security
sympathetic to his desire for company Dr
Cho has begun to allow the subject to
have visits with SCP 507 who will stop
by his containment facility during his
inactive periods for a movie night or
some video games Matt has described 507
as his best friend aside from Dr Cho in
spite of the intricate world
inexplicably floating in his body the
the subject leads a relatively simple
life he does not seem to be restless or
resentful at all in fact he seems
largely content though his future is
uncertain and he is living through a
completely unprecedented anomalous
experience he is probably one of the
happiest anomalies contained at the SCP
Foundation and definitely one of the
most at peace with his anomalous status
whatever happens next for him he will
probably be ready for it with a smile
and there's something we can all learn
from that a streak of of warm blood
splattered across the snow steam Rose
off it as it fizzled into the ice
crystals below the severed leg had just
spurted from lay twitching only a few
inches away torn clean off at the hip
like a broken Barbie doll I think it
might have belonged to Arthur it wasn't
the first time I'd seen limbs cut off
hell I've cut a few off myself in my
time don't worry I'm not a serial killer
just a med student we all were I
couldn't say the same for the nightmare
we encountered up in the mountains that
terrible day the thin cold air was laid
in with screams mine my friends and that
things all that had done to us all that
it was still doing to us and never once
did it stop shrieking and sobbing at the
top of its lungs like it wasn't even in
control of its actions it didn't want to
do this it just had to the violence was
as inevitable as the sunset I screamed
for Kyle the snow was coming down thick
and fast a curtain of burning brilliant
white I couldn't see anyone not even
that thing that was killing us the water
in my eyes was starting to freeze up it
was cold so damn cold what the hell was
going on here suddenly a dark shape was
moving towards me through the wall of
falling snow it was human vaguely moving
towards me with frantic speed I tensed
and anticipation when I then saw Kyle
emerging from the fog he was splattered
with blood his face red from screaming
and exertion his eyes pleaded for help I
couldn't give him the horror caused my
body to react on autopilot with my eyes
climbing closed in ter error all I could
do was open my mouth pointing with a
shaking frostbitten finger and force out
a scream behind you my words were
carried off by the brutal Mountain winds
and with the sounds of Mutilation ahead
of me all I could imagine with eyes
clamped closed as I hit the frozen
ground was a long gray arm emerging from
the flurry behind Kyle its gnarled
clawed fingers reaching for his head it
was meant to be the vacation of a
lifetime the kind of thing that you
could only experience once once but
you'd never forget we all thought in our
own ways that we'd look back on the
photos with Misty Eyes when we were all
old men we didn't know that within a
week of arriving in Switzerland whether
any of us would even make it to old age
would suddenly become an open question
all four of us were doctors in training
even if you don't know much about the
profession it probably won't surprise
you to hear that there's a lot of
practice and education involved before
you can ever really call yourself a
doctor without feeling like a fraud you
need to Ace your SATs then slog through
four years of Premed another four years
of medical school then the better part
of a decade doing your residency seems a
little much I know but believe me you
don't want some Cowboy sticking his
hands in your chest cavity without all
the proper training but after we finally
graduated from Harvard Med my friends
and I decided that we needed a break
before the profession swallowed us back
up again it was me Brandon Arthur and of
course Kyle a lot of people I attended
class with would probably make a tidy
sum over the course of their Medical
Careers many of them would have made
fine doctors but all of us knew that
Kyle Malloy was more than that he was
going to be a truly great doctor he was
smart confident driven and had the kind
of smooth effortless charm that made you
just feel safe around him where he went
we followed so naturally when he
suggested we take a week-long sojourn in
Switzerland the rest of us were all for
it we expected an easy week of gourmet
cheese fine chocolate and the occasional
Jaun down some old historic districts
the exact kind of relaxing break we
needed after the soul crushing pressure
of8 years studying the hollowed art of
medicine but of course that wasn't what
Kyle had planned for us it turned out
his tastes were far more extreme than
what the rest of us had in mind his
vision of a Swiss vacation was mostly
Forest hikes Backcountry skiing
snowboarding and a little mountaineering
through the Swiss Alps apparently he'd
spent a good portion of his childhood
taking Swiss vacation ations and wanted
to give us a little slice of his
personal Paradise as someone who wasn't
exactly crazy about Heights or the cold
I can't pretend I was eager at first but
Kyle always found a way of talking us
back around it wasn't long until we were
booking our tickets then sitting on the
plane watching the mountains get bigger
through the window and our feet were on
Swiss soil it was a beautiful country
never bit as cold as I feared but soon
enough the cold would be the absolute
least of our worries as I glanced over
the breathtaking view of the Alps I had
no idea of the terrible nightmare
lurking out there hidden in the dark
spaces of those great rocks something I
learned in med school is that human
beings are kind of like fleshy time
bombs their fuse ever burning when you
reach a certain age and believe me that
age is younger than you think the
Assassin that will one day sneak up from
within and take your life is already
waiting inside you the cluster of
malform cells that will one day turn
into an inoperable malignant tumor the
early Whispers of the heart defect that
gives your ticker its planned
obsolescence the microscopic ropes of
defective genes that will one day turn
into Alzheimer's or Parkinson's in some
cases it's just a matter of whether you
can catch it in time but in just as many
cases there really is nothing you can do
you're just waiting for it to get you
after 3 days in Switzerland we were
suiting up in our thick coats and
climbing boots having no idea that the
same principle applied to us except this
wasn't that nasty little assassin within
it was something outside something that
none of our skills or knowledge could
save us from something very old and very
dangerous we were in Fate's hands now
and sometimes fate can be cruel Kyle was
steaming ahead he didn't just want us to
ascend just any mountain peak he wanted
us to attempt the doofer spites the
highest peak of the monter Rosa massive
and the Alps as a whole Kyle didn't
think anything less than that would be a
challenge after all this was our one in
a lifetime vacation before we fully
started our residency didn't we want to
make this a truly remarkable experience
and because it was Kyle none of us
disagreed we started at the base of the
mon Roa and began to rise its lowest
levels barely resembled its Frosty Peak
over 4,600 ft above we took pictures of
some of the wildlife the grazing ibexes
Red Deer and shoa Arthur had brought a
pamphlet on the local Wildlife back at a
tourist friendly Mountain Lodge and took
great joy in pointing out the different
creatures to us as he saw them Brandon
got a good laugh about the fact that
there was a small bird native to the
area known as the nut hatch Kyle forged
ahead telling us Tales of his prior
conquests The Climb gradually
transitioned from calm to grueling as we
ascended the mountain I could feel the
blister forming on my feet as the cold
first made my face Sting and then go
completely numb Arthur still Consulting
his pamphlet expressed excitement to see
a marmot when we finally reached 2,000
ft of elevation Brandon started to
complained vocally pouring himself a cup
of coffee from his thermos Kyle
chastised him for wimping out already
after all he said the hardest parts were
Yet to
Come Oh if only he knew just how right
he was we ascended further feeling the
air thinning and our legs growing
exhausted beneath us I started to resent
Kyle as he forged on despite it all how
could he keep going when the rest of us
were faltering it just wasn't fair when
the rest of us needed to take a breather
we could feel the sting of his silent
judgment he was always so damn perfect
we're almost there he kept saying even
though we all knew it wasn't true things
took a turn during one of our rest stops
we heard this strange noise a kind of
pained wailing or Keening there was
nothing overtly menacing about it but
somehow just hearing that noise chilled
me deeper than any icy gust of mountain
breeze it's difficult to describe but
that terrible sobbing felt like the
purest distillation of true bottomless
despair as I've never heard a more
hopeless and mournful noise referring to
his pamphlet again Arthur speculated
that the noise could potentially be a
lynx such creatures were apparently
native to the area and their calls had a
bizarrely human quality to them but
somehow deep down I knew this thing
wasn't human and it wasn't an animal
either whatever was making those noises
defied normal metrics of categorization
to the surprise of no one me least of
all Kyle decided to lead the way in the
direction of that awful noise Brandon
and Arthur followed him closely over the
next Tundra getting closer and closer to
the sobbing I hung back a little further
gripped by the profound sense of dread I
didn't want to find out what was making
this noise I knew deep in my guts that
if ever we found out what was making
that noise something terrible would
happen and then moments later it did I
heard Kyle gasp for the first time ever
the snow was blinding my view and I
couldn't make out what was actually
happening until Arthur ran back toward
my direction and through the blanket of
white snow and with a voice barely
audible through his trembling said that
there was a long gray creature he said
it was naked and looked kind of human
but definitely was not I could barely
make out what my buddies were doing
ahead of me but from the looks of it it
seemed like Kyle was walking closer
every cell my body was screaming no no
no no no no but by that point it was
already far too late for all of us the
creature began to turn perhaps it was
raw animal Instinct that saved me but I
be began to turn two almost in unison to
look away from the creature I just knew
that whatever this thing was I couldn't
bear to see it and it was at that moment
as my body hit the snow and I forced my
eyes closed that the screaming began
first I could recognize the voices of
Brandon Arthur and Kyle screaming and
then something worse I can only assume
it was the creature itself making the
most terrible racket shrieking moaning
sobbing and then ripping and tearing
blood spattering across the snow I just
cowered and shook against the ground as
a massacre unfolded behind me I was
listening to my friends die powerless
Kyle all his strength and direction
Stripped Away by Terror was snatched by
the creature as freezing snowy wind gave
it a cloak I heard Kyle's scream and
then never heard anything from him ever
again soon enough it was quiet once more
no noise save for the howling wind and
the quiet sobbing of the Abomination
from the snow I don't know for sure why
the creature spared me but part of me
has always suspected that it was because
I never looked at it I'll forever be
Darkly curious as to what the Monster
truly looked like but my friends found
out and now I'd never see them again I
wandered through the unforgiving cold
for hours fully expecting that my frozen
body would be found in the Alps hours
days or even weeks later I didn't even
care anymore the cold numbed my skin my
limbs and my thoughts at some point a
helicopter descended onto the mountain
side full of men in tactical gear with
insignias I couldn't recognize they
wrapped me in an emergency blanket and
brought me in telling me I required
treatment it all turned a static as we
fluttered away from the mountain side
and all I could think about was the
monster that had taken my friends from
me it was still out there waiting the
fabric of our world is littered with
strange doorways if you know where to
look for them tears portals
anomalies all leading to places and
planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an SCP 2317 otherwise
known as a door to another world
certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of arm guards SCP 2317 appears
to be a simple and unsuspecting wooden
door in its frame it hardly looks like
it requires such extreme round-the-clock
security or needs a strange secretive
ritual that the foundation performs
presumably to keep the door closed but
of course sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed doorway isn't where
it leads it's what it keeps out even by
the foundation's already high standards
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to SCP 2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the MGR obedience
examination it is also mandatory that
Personnel assigned to maintaining it are
both unmarried with no children or next
of Ken as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and
objectives these may seem like strange
requirements after all SCP 2317 is just
a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about SCP 2317 buried deep
under layers upon layers of security
with only the overseer Council privy to
the full details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly still
if SCP 2317 is a door to another world
an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact according to the 05
Council this is done as part of a
procedure to maintain active containment
of something lurking beyond that old
wooden door frame but what could
possibly warrant such constant
maintenance and
surveillance in accordance with the
foundation's guidelines all staff are
required to rotate out of observing SCP
2317 after every 2 months and spend the
following third month in full
psychological counseling before they are
permitted to return to the containment
unit housing the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the
foundation he did make one request to
his commanding officer however he wanted
to know what had happened to the last
guard that had performed the
procedure didn't make it out of
psychological evaluation the officer
replied not letting this affect his
dedication the guard was told to prepare
for procedure 220
Calabasas along with a fellow member of
foundation security Personnel the guard
was instructed to gather everything on a
strange list the first was a
pre-selected member of Class D Personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing
scps class D's were usually prison
inmates repurpose forp testing and the
one chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told a
foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on next
the guard collected a live chicken an
obsidian edged knife a silver aspar and
aspersorium to be filled with 500 cc's
of holy water that have been blessed by
a priest of the abrahamic faith and
finally a 1 kiloton nuclear device which
according to instructions was only to be
detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure in
other words The Last
Resort after following his instructions
to the letter and without question the
guard and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining in leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
SCP
2317 and the nature of procedure 220
calabases the class D joining them
wasn't actually a Class D the assistant
as they were now referred to was in
reality another Foundation staff member
with a level four security clearance
specifically tailored to SCP
2317 every member of Staff entering
through SCP 2317 and taking an active
role in 22 Calabasas needed to be
informed that this assistant was not to
be harmed or treated as a member of
disposable class fighting back the
nagging question of why the foundation
would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the Sun was
highest over SCP
2317 solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the
foundation as they entered the old
wooden door Beyond lay a Barren salt
plane stretching out for kilometers in
every direction this alternate Dimension
according to the briefing was designated
SCP 237 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history procedure 220
calabases was carried out quickly but
carefully the guard watching as the
celebrant and assistant were careful not
to miss a step first the celebrant
scattered holy water into the center of
the pillars with the aspergum and
aspersorium looking down at his feet and
keeping a steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant anointing
his head with Holy Water Seven Seals
Seven Rings seven Thrones for the
Scarlet King he said aloud the assistant
with the obsidian blade in his hand took
the chicken and dispatched it in
sacrifice letting its blood mix with the
holy water he then repeated the
celebrant circuit in the opposite
direction before stepping into the
center of the stone
pillars blood for the old gods water for
the new king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the Seven
Pillars even though he knew it wasn't
his place to question the foundation as
the 220 calabases procedure took place
the guard couldn't help but wonder what
all this was for it seems so ritualistic
like something deeply religious or even
magical he never bought into all that
occult mumbo jumbo even while for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of
science little did he know that beneath
his feet was an ancient and unknowable
horror a beast Chained and lying in
weight contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid in a beast its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating branch-like horns
protruded rooted from its jawless head
pointing up to chains that hung from the
Seven Pillars above each one hooked into
the entity's back all but one of the
chains was broken a final withering
shackle keeping the devour of worlds in
its underground prison ever since 1894
BCE when arikian Mystics imprisoned it
the devour has been waiting patiently
for its inevitable Freedom it knows as
well as the foundation that nothing can
be done to prevent the final chain from
one day breaking even procedure 220
calabases won't keep the creature
contained it's nothing more than a smoke
screen an act designed to create an
illusion of active containment and
maintain Foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep SCP
imprisoned of course if the guard had
known this it would have also explained
the need for a 1 kiloton nuclear device
as part of this stage ritual procedure
220 calabases had all the components to
trick everyone below the 05 Council
emulating religious and occult rituals
The increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose and telling staff that any
failure to correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabases procedure will
result in an XK Class end of the world
scenario all these elements work
together to conceal the truth that one
day the devour will escape and lay waste
to our
Dimension knowledge is power and maybe
knowing too much truly is deadly perhaps
if the guard had learned any of this
he'd have understood why his predecessor
never made it out of psychological
evaluation maybe if he had questioned
the purpose of procedure 220 calabases
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP
237 and what that doorway kept out but
he was loyal to the foundation and
through and through as the team finished
performing 220 Calabasas and returned
through the wooden door the guard took
one last glance over his shoulder at the
vast salt plane the entire Dimension was
calm silent but not peaceful it was
patient The Entity had waited centuries
for its time and now all it would take
was the breaking of this seventh and
final chain one day the door was closed
behind the guard as he the celebrant the
assistant and his fellow security
officers step back through their work
done and as far as they knew preventing
catastrophe for another day only the
foundation hups the overseer Council are
aware of the true danger posed by SCP
2317 and its sole
inhabitant current predictions are that
at some point within the next 30 Years
the Devourer of Worlds will be freed any
and all attempts to repair or recreate
the chains holding it in place have so
far failed as such the 05 Council has
elected to continue providing Foundation
personnel with the ignorant hope that
procedure 220 calabases is an effective
strategy for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out in the case of
SCP 2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power that will one day break
free and wreck havoc in our Dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world and only the overseer
Council knows that any and all efforts
to do so are
futile with all that in mind we can only
hope that the doorway of SCP 2317 stays
closed at least for a little while
longer we've all heard of the lead
Zeppelin song Stairway to Heaven a title
that invokes the image of a Stairway
leading up to a land of Peace in
Paradise but where else could a Stairway
lead to a Dusty Attic full of old photo
albums to the upper level of a mall
where the movie theater and frozen
yogurt shop are neatly situated perhaps
it leads to a rooftop with a beautiful
view or maybe just maybe a staircase
could lead you to SCP 2427
SCP 2427 appropriately nicknamed a thing
full of stuff is an extradimensional
area filled with a variety of unusual
and anomalous objects SCP 2427 can be
accessed by way of a broken Stone
staircase located in rural Ohio
according to local Legend carrying a
sprig of Hemlock up the broken stairs
will allow a person to emerge into a
mysterious grass clearing that appears
to be in a forest somewhere in the
United States
no matter what time a person ascends the
staircase the solar time in the clearing
will always be 2:00 p.m. you know how
people say it's 5:00 somewhere well it's
2:00 somewhere too and that somewhere is
here the pocket Dimension that as SCP
2427 is thought to have been a holding
area for weapons prisoners and artifacts
belonging to an ancient cult known as
the Brazen heart little is known about
this relatively obscure cult other than
the fact fact that they worship the
Demonic entity molok a known Enthusiast
of violent human sacrifice and were
previously thought to have been
eradicated during the Spanish
Inquisition the existence of SCP 2427
suggests that they're very much not
eradicated and are still active they
refer to these holding areas as addicts
and though no confirmed members of the
Brazen heart have been contacted it is
considered possible that there are at
least a handful of other addicts hidden
around the world the foundation has
identified seven anomalous objects
inside of SCP 2427 so far each strange
in its own beautiful though often
terrible way like snowflakes if they
were capable of killing or Ming you the
first object in SCP 2427 AKA SCP
2427-3
the hydrant is made out of lead and when
opened it expels high levels of ionized
radiation no specific measurements of
the radiation have been taken yet but it
is definitely hazardous to human health
one unfortunate member of d-class
personnel has proven that it is a high
enough level to melt human flesh sorry
about your face Dave the hydron is
currently contained within an
electrified perimeter and is not to be
opened under any circumstances to
prevent any further flesh melting the
last thing we need is another Dave
incident the second object contained
with an SCP 2427 or SCP 24 27-2 is not
actually an object at all it's a
building only on number two and we're
already throwing curveballs at you trust
no one surprises lurk around every
corner this particular building
resembles a large multi-storage
sanitarium built in the
1860s though it is clear from the
outside that the building has or should
have multiple Stories the inside is a
different matter past the building's
front doors is a nonukan space
consisting of a single floor and three
sparsely decorated rooms with one
Central foyer the first room is the
holding place for SCP 2427-3 the second
contains SCP
24274 and the third room contains
nothing except scattered religious
documents bottled water and a selection
of canned food no unauthorized staff are
permitted to enter the the building in
order to minimize complications or
potential employee casualties the first
two anomalies on this list are hardly
even strange by a CP Foundation
standards sure the hydron can melt your
face and the building defies the laws of
physics and space but that's just a
regular Tuesday around these
parts been there seen that what else you
got well SCP 2427-3 is where things
really get strange if you're wandering
through the bowels of SCP 24 27-2 when
you make a wrong turn into the first
room you will find yourself face to face
with a startling sight this entity is a
combination of electronic circuitry a
cow's digestive tract the hairless head
of a human man a hat rack several
lengths of garden hose and an
unidentified crystalline structure this
creature is extraordinarily fast and
strong exhibiting carnivorous Tendencies
and a very strong point of view on the
world around it lucky for us it is
capable of speech and is able to tell us
just what it thinks though this
monstrosity doesn't have much of a right
to pass judgment on anyone C intestine
body and all it has expressed a violent
hatred of all life that it considers
impure anyone who encounters SCP 2427-3
experiences an overwhelming desire to
submit themselves for judgment allowing
the creature to determine their purity
there is a rumor that if one is judged
to be pure they will have a wish granted
if they are deemed impure however they
will be devoured alive if you're tempted
to introduce yourself to the creature
your odds are not especially great the
creature has not encountered a single
pure being yet in order to protect the
foundation staff working in its vicinity
the entrance to SCP 2427-3 room has been
sealed off with a reinforced steel door
and the windows have been paved over
with concrete armed guards are watching
the entrance at all times the creature
must be fed one live goat per day in
order to keep its appetite satiated the
foundation's goat budget is through the
roof these days but it's worth it to
keep the thing contained better to spend
money on goats now and not spend money
on cannibalized Personnel later SCP
24274 consists not of an object located
within a room but the room itself the
room which contains no furniture and a
lenium floor has a peculiar effect on
the human psyche once a person steps
foot into the room they lose
Consciousness for 5 minutes during this
time they will speak freely listing off
a variety of negative qualities about
themselves once they wake up they have
no memory of entering the state or
anything that they said during it it's
cheaper than therapy right but it's also
much weirder and less effective so you
get what you pay for in the end a member
of d-class personnel who was observed
inside of the room wax po itic about his
personal failings beginning his
monologue with my soul is a den of
spiders and ending it with oh here once
I awaken hesitate not to feed my flesh
and my soul to the judge Beast somebody
give this guy a hug because the room
seems to have no adverse effects on
human test subjects except for causing
everyone who hears their monologue a bit
of discomfort there are no containment
procedures in effect for it at this time
we've had rooms fire hydrants and
horrible meat robot hybrids and now you
can't even trust the clouds in the sky
SCP
24275 is a seemingly innocent Cloud
hovering stationary over the building
when looked at by a human for more than
3 seconds the cloud will eject a ball of
solid lead towards the person at a
supersonic speed that's right folks This
Cloud can and will shoot you it hates
being observed but it also hates when
you try to leave the perimeter it will
attack any person attempting to leave by
by firing the same lead ball at them so
far 14 Personnel have been killed by
this highly aggressive cloud and some
people still think thunderstorms and
hail are the worst things clouds have to
offer so naive as it is a little Cloud
there is no way to contain it so no
people in the vicinity of the cloud are
permitted to look at it for more than 3
seconds at a time SCP
24276 is a series of 18 small trees
spread throughout the instance of SCP
above ground the trees look normal
though their species has proven
surprisingly difficult to determine from
an external perspective they are simply
ordinary trees however radar analysis
revealed that the roots of these trees
are deeply strange instead of the usual
twisting tree roots the ground below
these trees contains a mass in the shape
of a human body much to the disgust of
the observing researchers these humanoid
masses occasionally twitch and move as
if alive
the trees themselves appear to be
growing from the crotch area of each
humanoid figure how's that for
Morningwood I know I get it bad joke
this Arrangement between tree and person
seems to be some kind of punishment as
each tree is marked with a plaque
reading the lrc suffer what they must
and it is beautiful until it can be
certain that the condition of these
human Roots is not contagious these
trees are to be treated as potential
biohazards and isolated in individual
containers
the final object in SCP 2427 currently
categorized by the foundation is SCP
24277 SCP
24277 is a pile of ashes and Wood
located just behind a posted sign that
reads the Liar's cradle extensive
testing has been established that the
Liar's cradle was almost certainly used
as a torture device in interrogations
performed by the Brazen heart a person
standing within the boundaries of the
Cradle which encompasses the
aformentioned circle of wood and Ashes
is unable to lie without suffering the
consequences namely they will be set on
fire the nature of how exactly the
Liar's cradle works is not certain and
more research needs to be done on it
however this much is known for sure it
contains no sentient intelligence it is
not aware of what it is doing it does
not kill its victims rather it keeps
them miraculously alive as it sets them
on fire prolonging their Agony and
allowing their interrogators to get the
truth out of them a series of
experiments revealed that it only ulates
a person who is knowingly lying d-class
Personnel give demonstrably false
information to repeat in the Cradle
without knowledge of its falsehood were
not set on fire however when those same
d-class Personnel knowingly lied in the
boundaries they immediately were set
Ablaze it is almost certain that the
Brazen heart cult used the Cradle as a
method of interrogating presumed Liars
in the their midst further investigation
will likely reveal human remains beneath
the Cradle itself though this is just a
hypothesis currently but come on there
has to be some bone somewhere beneath
something as ominous as the Liar's
cradle though they have only identified
seven anomalies inside SCP 2427 at the
moment there are plenty more lurking in
there waiting to be discovered in the
foyer of SCP
24272 the foundation discovered an
extremely ominous list of items clearly
belonging to members of The Cult of the
Brazen heart this list included some
familiar items such as Pilgrim
Provisions also known as the canned
beans and soup found in SCP
24272 a level three Purity Proctor a
purge engine disguised as a fire hydrant
and the Liar's cradle however it also
contained many things that have not yet
been discovered such as one slaughtering
perseverance 27 py children three
ascended cultivars seven Supreme
angelics Nine Dragons and the Brazen
heart itself Dr Gordon McElroy site
director of area 2427 put out a memo to
all level four and higher Staff assigned
to the area after the discovery of this
list understandably he was most
concerned about the Supreme angelics and
the dragons particularly the latter the
cult as most Cults are is fond of
deliberately obscure language but you
don't want to rule out the possibility
they've got a fire breathing lizard or
two stashed away in the meantime as the
foundation is working to better
understand the contents of SCP
2427 the area has been sealed off to the
public a 500 met perimeter has been
established around its entrance and a
fake private Country Club has been set
up as a front it's only a matter of time
before the rest of the anomalies on the
list are discovered and this thing full
of stuff gets even Fuller of even more
stuff let's just hope none of it ever
gets out because if there are more of
these addicts out there who knows what
else the Brazen heart is hiding their
little cult may not be as extinct as we
thought Norse mythology tells the story
of yorong Gand a Great Serpent so long
that it wraps itself the entire way
around midgard and bites its own tail
Legend says that when yorong Gund
unclasps its jaws and starts to unfurl
it will signal the beginning of Ragnarok
the destruction of the world and that
was about as much information as the
foundation gave to agent neelsen when
they assigned him to his watch Duty in
Greenland in the frozen tundra all day
every day he had been equipped with a
sniper rifle thermal goggles and put up
high in a watchtower if he saw anyone
anyone he had to shoot on sight no
questions asked whether it was his
squadmates the Brigadier general or even
his own mother
if anyone walked across the barren
stretch of ice ahead of him he was to
shoot them dead under no circumstances
was anyone allowed to enter that cave
the fate of the world could depend on it
but it was cold and the days were long
for months he'd been sitting there by
himself without seeing a single soul
walk across the glacier that's why it
took him so long to spy the figure
stumbling across the ice half a
kilometer away but the person didn't
look any clearer when agent neelon took
a look through his thermal binoculars
barely registering as much warmer than
the snow around him the man stumbled
forward seemingly unaware of the world
around him could this be the start of
the Swan Song of the world is this what
he had been warned about without a
moment's hesitation agent neelon
snatched up the sniper rifle and readied
his sights on the man somewhere buried
deep beneath the Greenland ice is one of
the most dangerous scps that the
foundation has ever come across to say
that SCP 722 is re Awakening could spell
the destruction of human civilization is
no Idol concern classified as a ker
level SCP SCP 722 has been nicknamed
yorong Gund after the Norse myth
researchers speculate that the creatures
existence could in some way be linked to
the early origins of the story of the
Norse creature 722 was brought to the
foundation's attention relatively
recently environmental activist group
Greenpeace was shooting a documentary on
the effects of global warming on
glaciers in Greenland a small crew
including a director producer three
camera operators and a sound recordist
headed out to get some close-up footage
from amongst the glaciers walking from
ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked
like deep Ice Caves surmising that these
openings were only accessible to them
because of the melting Glacier Ice the
crew climbed down into the caves to get
some neverbe seen footage some of the
footage of their exploration has been
recovered since and in the background of
several shots as they are adjust justing
exposure and pulling Focus you can hear
the producer and director theorizing
about where these caves have come from
they initially seem to think that the
caves are Millennia old preserved by
Sub-Zero temperatures but soon they come
across several markings on the walls
ancient hieroglyphs and symbols none of
the crew were language experts and so in
the footage you can hear them struggling
to identify which people group would
have carved those into the ice walls in
the decades since language experts from
around the world have studied these
markings on those walls and have still
been unable to identify any discernable
links to any known human script most
agree that it does seem to predate the
settlement of the island by Eric the Red
at the start of the 11th century during
this period it is believed that there
were no human settlements on the island
so the origins of this script remain
unknown as the footage goes on you may
start to notice something that the green
pieace crew does not one of the ice
walls is no longer a wall at all it
looks like ack Rock in some of the
footage but whenever a flashlight Shines
on its surface you can see a pattern to
it scales then an opening at the far
side of the tunnel the crew emerges into
an enormous Cavern estimated to be
upwards of 200 m in height and several
times wider even their powerful
flashlights struggle to cut through the
darkness inside that's the point that
the sound recorders notic is the scales
running alongside them as the camera
pans you see that they have been walking
alongside a tail several times taller
than them a tail that snakes its way
through the darkness of the cavern to
meet a hulking mass at the other side
shrouded in darkness that is where the
footage cuts off those green peace
filmmakers were next seen in a local
town that evening none of them had the
chance to extol the wonders of what
they'd encountered that day as they were
all sick a couple went straight to bed
in their lodgings complaining of intense
headaches and exhaustion others tried to
check themselves into the ER but never
miss made it each of the crew died of
different causes necrosis of the skin
internal bleeding kidney failure by 9:00
p.m. that day all of them were dead
fortunately there just so happened to be
a low-level Foundation agent staying in
the same guest house as them who heard
the commotion within 2 days a perimeter
was established within 2 years the
foundation gained the bulk of knowledge
of this SCP that they rely on to this
day it is unknown exactly how large SCP
722 actually is a hulking serpent half
buried in ice much of its body cannot be
observed it sleeps coiled up in the
middle of the cavern that the filmmakers
happened across some of its body is
buried beneath fallen in parts of the
caves others frozen into the ground
around it however based on what can be
observed of this SCP it is estimated to
be in the ranges of 8 to 12 km from head
to tail fortunately for just about
everyone including you this SC appears
to be dormant at no time since its
Discovery has this SCP been observed to
move make a sound or otherwise indicate
Consciousness sensors are installed in
the chamber to monitor its life
functions and study its heart rate
temperature brain activity and more one
concern to the foundation is that since
its Discovery 722 has had a 9% uptick in
neural activity researchers hope that
this is just a natural part of the sleep
cycle and that it will return to a
deeper slumber soon that is the hope at
least so what makes this SCP so
dangerous then if it's sound asleep well
let's go back to agent neelen staring
through the scope of his rifle the
barrel kicked back a puff of warm smoke
there and gone in cold air he watched
just long enough to confirm the kill
before radioing back to command what he
had observed within an hour the cleanup
crew arrived riding on snowmobiles they
waited at a distance for an hour before
approaching the body rather
unceremoniously they they wrapped it up
in a black plastic bag strapped it to
the back of their snowmobile and took it
away for cremation neelen just sat there
in his watch tower the whole time
observing it all the person looked sick
and not the kind of sick that you'd get
from spending too much time out there on
the ice their skin had gone rotten like
they had gang greine or leprosy it
wasn't just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a
jumpsuit standard issue for d-class
personnel only a v held in their cold
dead fingers was any kind of clue for
neelen as to what had been going on in
that cave but that was as close as the
agent ever came to understanding the
mysteries of SCP 722 the vial however
was in many ways all he needed to know
that is because contained in that vial
was a sample of the liquid secreted by
722 it is a liquid that the Green Peace
crew came into close contact with when
they found the creature and it's a
liquid that promises and denies great
power and great risk to the foundation
any and all attempts to study this
liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact
with it will immediately suffer acute
sickness interestingly however there
seems to be little consistency as to how
this sickness manifests itself some
develop a number of cancerous cells
whilst others lose cognitive function
due to brain swelling symptoms seem to
vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very
difficult hazardous material suits have
been deployed for researchers attempting
to study it but have all failed despite
being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive
threats how the substance is able to
infect them is unknown sadly a good
number of scientists had to die to make
this discovery another route of study is
to take the substance out of the cave
and observe it under laboratory
conditions this was what agent neelon
observed as he shot and killed the
d-class Personnel emerging from the cave
W the d-class had been sent in to
retrieve the vial of the substance for
external study while a safe and direct
route of entry and exit had been planned
for the man to take he became critically
ill whilst in contact with 722 and
developed an aggressive fever no longer
coherent over the radio he dropped out
of signal wandering through the tunnels
for 2 hours until emerging out of an
exit high up on the glacier two agents
with higher security clearance were
dispatched to deal with the body the
reason for their waight was for their
own safety 722s toxin appears to
denature with time away from its source
causing it to weaken in potency if they
had approached immediately they may have
well suffered similar Fates to the
d-class they survived but the sample was
ruined all subsequent attempts have also
been met with failure it seems almost
impossible to capture a clean sample and
transport it any kind of distance with
this toxin the foundation would have
possession of an immense biological
weapon akin to to the discovery of the
atom bomb but as of right now all it's
good for is killing d-class Personnel
initially the foundation believe the
fluid to be a defense mechanism for the
SCP something to protect it in its deep
sleep but the more time is spent
observing it the more time this
perception is Shifting SCP 722s toxin
appears instead to be a weapon as such
the containment of this creature is of
Paramount importance there are eight
known access points into the tunnel
Network that would Grant access to SCP
722 each of them has been sealed with
reinforced gates with additional layers
of sound proofing at regular 4-Hour
intervals nitrogen gas cooled to a near
liquid state is to be pumped through
these doors without fail it is believed
that the creature is a form of Proto
reptile and so is theoretically
coldblooded its internal temperature is
dictated by its surroundings therefore
by keeping a cool average temperature in
these caves it is thought that this SCP
Slumber can be prolonged how long is
unclear with Rising global temperatures
year after year the threat that the
Green Peace activists were proclaiming
is very real just perhaps not quite in
the way they'd envisioned Not only would
there be an increase in natural
disasters and a decrease in biodiversity
there would also be a 12 km snake
roaming around the planet killing anyone
in its path not ideal as such the
foundation has also planted a number of
Highly skilled individuals in prominent
environmental positions in the hopes of
turning the tide of global warming
sooner should the ice in that cave
system warm by even a couple of degrees
who knows what kind of Spike they might
see on the neural monitors this SCP
naturally is buried deep beneath layers
and layers of security clearances too
only in exceptional circumstances and
for Vital maintenance is anyone allowed
to approach this SCP a minimum of two
level three clearance agents are
required to sign off on any such Works
in in recent years a new Brigadier
General took charge of the containment
operations of SCP 722 after his
predecessor was stripped of his duties
overly zealous experiments and
increasingly desperate attempts to
harvest or synthesize the 722 toxin saw
an alarming uptick in neural activity
over 40 d-class Personnel were processed
and disposed of within a 2E period in an
attempt to assemble a micro laboratory
within the main chamber itself this
project failed and the no es of
construction threatened the peace that
had so long been maintained beneath the
glacier the new Brigadier General is
taking no such risks enforcing a zero
tolerance policy on anyone approaching
site 103 unless suitably cleared a
number of hikers have sadly had to be
killed this way but the foundation
believes it to be a necessary sacrifice
to keep the peace it is quite easy to
find a convincing backstory for their
untimely deaths and the lack of bodies
to bury just another person to get lost
lost and fall down a crack in the
glacier warning stories that are shared
and planted in local towns and on the
internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that
researchers have stumbled across a link
to a group of animals found halfway
around the world monitor lizards of the
genus varanus seem to share a similar
set of traits to SCP 722 namely the
nature of their toxins you may be
familiar with the bite of a kodo dragon
while the initial wound sure does hurt
the real damage comes in the following
hours and days as necrosis sets in from
the toxins in its mouth could these
creatures share a common ancestor could
722 be the common ancestor as of right
now it is just a hunch but it's one that
has taken roote amongst the research
staff in order to find out more though
they need samples tissue samples taken
straight from the SCP itself the only
way to do back is to go back into the
caves and start cutting if a a bit of
construction noise was enough to raise
brain activity by .9% taking a hunk of
Flesh could prove a whole lot more
dangerous not least for the Personnel
involved who will all have to sacrifice
their lives the potential benefits could
be huge a way to study fatal diseases in
a new light perhaps finding a way to
reverse engineer cures to some of the
deadliest conditions on the planet or
perhaps the missing ingredient to
synthesizing the most powerful
biological weapon in human history maybe
worst of all it could all trigger The
Reawakening do you remember how the
story of yorong gundur ends with a
prediction that when the Great Serpent
on coils the end of the world Ragnarok
itself will arrive but that's just an
old fairy tale right the Shinobi
crouched low on the pagota roof and
listened to the night air up here in the
mountains away from the hustle and
bustle of the markets in town it was
almost silent just the distant rattle of
shutters somewhere behind him the
mountain Shrine was tucked out of sight
so far into the countryside that no one
would stumble onto it by accident no one
would come here without a reason the
Shinobi knew the face of his Target a
warlord turned politician with more
blood on his hands than the Assassin
sent to kill him by the burning glow of
the night sky the Shinobi could see the
man kneeling at The Shrine the path was
made up of small stones so he'd have to
drop onto the grass creep around the
pond to approach his Target no guards no
one else was there at all this was the
spot where the man came to prey when he
was struggling to sleep perhaps trying
to atone for the lives he'd taken
perhaps he didn't care at all the ninja
drew the blade in total silence and
timed his Dro to the ground with a
rattling noise in the distance with each
dainty step he closed the distance to
his Target readying the blade over his
head it was done in a moment the man was
dead before his body hit the ground he
likely didn't even notice as the steel
had severed the nerves running down his
spinal cord so shred was the blade that
had slid through his bones like a fish
through water raising the blade to his
eyes the Shinobi cleaned it quickly if
he was seen with blood on his sword he
would immediately be implicated not that
he was ever seen But precautions like
this were what kept him out of sight for
all these years when you lived in The
Valley Of Ashes the burial grounds for
countless Wars you had to become a
shadow become one of the ancient Spirits
haunting the woods but as he wiped the
red from the steel he caught a flash of
light in the reflection an orange glow
marking a jagged line across the metal
that's strange Sunset was several hours
ago come to think of it why was there an
orange glow in the sky he snapped his
neck around to see the fires through the
gates into the pagota Garden down by the
Ocean's Edge at the foot of the
mountains was the city where he had
always lived and it was on fire leaping
up onto the walls he stood up straight
surveying the horror scene taking place
before him thick plumes of smoke bowed
up into the night sky so dense and large
that it seemed to become the Blackness
of the night it was hard to make out
much of what was going on down there the
Shinobi looked everywhere to try to see
the invading army or the rioter but
there were none just people running in
all directions like ants out of a
flooding Nest but there moving in
amongst the smoke were other shapes
impossibly tall lumbering around like
people people that towered over the
houses that had to Crane down to the
ground to scoop up the poor civilians
who were running this way and that the
Shinobi stood there terrified as he
realized that the rattling sound he'd
been hearing all night wasn't from any
shutters at all he could do nothing but
watch as the trees in front of him
trembled and buckled in all directions
as a hulking shadowy figure lumbered
towards him the Imperial Japanese
anomalous matters examination agency or
the
ajaa was a Japanese agency responsible
for tracking a number of mysterious and
often dangerous artifacts creatures and
anomalies prior to the second world war
in 1945 the AA was shut down and
absorbed into the SCP Foundation all of
these data historic records and
anomalies were all transferred over into
the foundation's control reasons for
this were partially political and
partially in the interest of world peace
the formation of the mmea was influenced
heavily by Japan's ties with Germany in
the first half of the 20th century the
Imperial German anomalous matters
examination agency was the blueprint for
their Japanese equivalent however with
increasing militarism in Japan
throughout the 20th century the mmea
became increasingly obsessed with trying
to harness their anomalous discoveries
in the interests of military power their
goal became the establishment of a
yo-kai battalion powerful enough to
establish them as one of if not the
world's greatest superpower following
the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
Japan surrendered in the second world
war and agreed to dissolve its military
including the a ma that left the
foundation with the task of picking up
the threads left behind and trying to
come up with new ways of securing
containing and protecting some of
Japan's most deadly scps few more deadly
and evasive than the entities that were
too much even for the yo-kai Battalion
SCP
2863 in 1946 cleanup operations were in
full effect trying to deal with the
Fallout from the atomic bomb dropped on
Nagasaki Crews dressed in bloodline
suits worked Around the Clock burying
radioactive material and trying to
remove as much contaminated debris as
possible rebuilding the city was still a
long way off at various points the wind
would kick up and carry the dust Left
Behind into the air creating a dangerous
radioactive Haze Crews continued to work
through such conditions as the
understanding of Airborne contamination
was still in its infancy wanabi Goro was
one such worker Midway through a night
shift and clasping a damp rag to his
mouth he pushed on through the dust
clearing out building after building
they had spent the morning carrying
corpses out of an unidentifiable
building the corpses themselves were
pretty much worn away too just skeletons
really charred by the blast from months
before as Goro staggered along the
street he kept feeling like he was
imagining things the long hours and
traumatic conditions were enough to make
him see all kinds of things in his
dreams but he kept feeling like his
dreams were starting to creep into the
real world Shadows kept moving through
the haze all around him taller than
buildings staggering around as if they
were drunk they had been appearing all
night just out of sight but always close
by he stopped and leaned against what
was left of a brick wall there was one
of his hallucinations now just up ahead
of him the husks of buildings on either
side of him were about as tall as their
knees it must have been 30 m tall at
least but its legs were strange there
seemed to be a gap in the middle of each
of them they were skinny no skeletal the
skeleton's foot crushed a car right in
front of him the crunch of metal was
loud enough to snap Goro out of his
stuper this wasn't a hallucination
hallucinations can't crush cars with a
Yelp he tumbled backwards staring up
into the haze of dust he saw the shape
of a pelvis above it what must have been
a rib cage the size of his house but the
creature disappeared into the darkness
and the dust if it was too tall for him
to see its face maybe it was too tall to
see him on the ground as well the
skeleton stopped standing directly over
him for a second he thought that maybe
he'd be okay but then with a great
rattling Rumble the monster hunched down
low and the enormous skull appeared out
of the haze flying right towards him he
managed to dodge its nashing teeth but
it caught his foot sending him rolling
through the radioactive dirt Goro didn't
give himself a moment to recover though
he took off running as fast as he could
hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
close behind his back you will be
pleased to know that wanabi Goro
survived this incident with only minor
injuries he managed to navigate his way
to the nearest police station where SCP
agents already familiar with the entity
he had encountered took control of the
situation the so-called starving
skeletons had been roaming the bomb
sites for several weeks by that point it
was the foundation's first exposure to
one of the oldest known entities that
the AA had been studying for years to
date 206 separate instances of SCP 2863
have been officially recorded however
the myth of the gasha doru had been
circulating in various parts of Japan
since the 10th Century at least giant
skeletons were said to haunt the sights
of particularly deadly battles hunting
by night and feeding on the blood of
their human victims these myths tally up
with what the foundation currently knows
about these entities instances of SCP
2863 only appear after sunset and will
lose all Corporal reality when exposed
to sunlight in the morning or any light
source over 1.1 luck to give you some
reference for that Moonlight typically
Falls between 0.25 and one Lux a typical
room with the light on will be 100 or
even 1,000 times brighter as you can
imagine this has made them virtually
impossible to contain as they manifest
and unmanifest outside of controllable
conditions they seem to have continuous
existence in some way however as as
previously neutralized instances can and
will reappear later on in folklore the
gashadokuro are spirits that take
control of skeletons some hesitant
researchers have posited that perhaps
the instances that dematerialize are
returning to their Spirit form little is
understood about what that means in
practice what's more this SCP cannot be
photographed all attempts to capture
them on film or digital cameras have
failed including video tests it is theor
that there is a link between them not
appearing on camera and their
disappearance when exposed to light
again the link between them is still
mostly unknown due to a steady increase
in urban development in Japan and
ongoing peace in the region appearances
of this SCP are growing increasingly
rare while this marks a positive change
for the people of Japan it makes it even
more difficult to study this SCP and
learn how to prevent it in the future
the most recent fatality to occur at the
Bony hands of SCP 2863 happened in 2008
and it was part of a foundation
experiment While most of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki had been redeveloped into
bustling metropolitan areas the
outskirts of each City particularly
several Parks saw occasional instances
of SCP 2863 appearing at night as such
the SCP Foundation conducted a series of
experiments under cover of Nightfall
releasing d-class Personnel into a park
in Hiroshima to observe how The scps
Hunted humans their enormous height
towering at over 30 m gave them a huge
Advantage being able to chase people
down with little difficulty another
notable thing about them is just how
quietly they move there is a gentle
rattling sound that follows them around
but aside from that they are very lightf
footed and difficult to detect until
they are right on top of you this isn't
helped by the fact that they hunt at
night as a result they are remarkably
quick at catching their prey once they
have sned snatch their victims up in
their skeletal fingers they perform the
same eating ritual every time they eat
the person and consume their blood
initially confused by this finding the
foundation was unsure where the blood
was going as the skeletons had no
obvious digestive system after the
release of several more d-class
Personnel into the park they still
weren't certain but they believed that
the SCP instances were absorbing the
blood into their bones in some way
further testing was requested but denied
due to the sheer number of d-class
fatalities in the area they were
starting to run out and would have to
ship more of them across to Japan which
was just a bit inconvenient for everyone
involved as the outskirts of those
cities have been urbanized the instances
of SCP 2863 have reduced to the point
that a smaller contingent of agents and
researchers are now left in place the
light pollution from these areas is
enough to prevent them from being able
to manifest in the first place for the
most part only on the rare occasion of
power outages have mobile task force 03
been deployed whilst researching this
SCP the foundation came across an
account from a Shinobi in the 1700s it
was rare to find any kind of written
document from a ninja for obvious
reasons but the account discovered
painted a harrowing picture of just how
much damage these yo-kai could inflict
upon a city the nameless Shinobi first
encountered SCP 2863 while assassinating
an unnamed Target in the mountains above
his fishing Town looking down on the
fires below him he saw human shapes
walking through the smoke dwarfing the
buildings they moov between before an
instance charge through the trees
straight at him diving out of the way
the Shinobi quickly melted into the
Shadows both man and Demon hunted one
another throughout the night he managed
to climb onto its spine and inflict what
he was certain would be a killing blow
to the skeleton only for his blade to
bounce right off the bone caught and
vulnerable for the first time in his
life the Shinobi was helpless as the
spirit threw him from its back into the
courtyard and charged at him it was only
the Hem of the Ninja's sleeve Catching
Fire from a candle that saved him just
as the skeleton was about to bite down
on his head the light flared and the SCP
disappeared entirely for a long while
the man lay in the courtyard pondering
his actions he should have died that
night yet he survived getting slowly to
his feet the man now knew what his
Destiny was a monster that strikes from
the Shadows scared of the light he and
the gashadokuro were not so different
understanding his Target was the first
step to defeating them snatching up a
lantern from the ground the Shinobi
descended the mountain into the wreckage
of his hometown and defended his people
by night he would emerge hunting down
the gashadokuro under the cover of
Darkness banishing them with the light
hidden under a dark sheet the man fought
night after night narrowly resing death
to save his people from the onslaught of
the evil spirit a small plaque was
installed by the Aja AA shortly before
the foundation took over the management
of the SCP it was installed at the foot
of an old pagota just outside a small
fishing Village on it was a simple Hau
walking in Shadow in the midst of our
demons we will find the light now check
out SCP 2662 cthulu and SCP 2935 o death
for more